In compliance with chapter 551 of the
open meetings act of the Texas
government code, I call to order a work
session of the board of trustees of the
Austin Independent School District for
Wednesday, October 29th, 2025 at 6:06
p.m.
A quorum of the board is physically
present at Austin ISD central office to
conduct this meeting. This meeting is
being broadcast on cable channel 22
through Spectrum Estan Broadband and on
channel 99 through AT&T Universe. Closed
captioning in English is also available
on these platforms for individuals who
are deaf or heart of hearing. Welcome
and thank you for joining us. We have
provided an opportunity for limited
public comment this evening. This is an
opportunity for the board to take part
in listening to our community. While we
wish we could respond or provide
feedback, Texas law requires us to limit
our questions to requests for
clarification or follow up directly to
the administration. The board has
allotted two and a half hours for this
workshop to give trustees the time and
opportunity to discuss the consolidation
plan, especially in the light of the
more than 6,500 comments we have
received from the community. Hundreds of
parents, teachers, and community members
have attended numerous meetings at
individual campuses, virtual and inerson
questions and answer sessions since the
draft consolidation plan was made
public. There will be additional
meetings after tonight,
Saturday, November 8th, from 10:30 a.m.
to 1:30 p.m. at Delo Activity Center in
conversations with the superintendent at
six elementary schools on October 30th,
October 31st, November 3rd, and November
5th. You may find more information about
these meetings at
austinisd.org/consolidate/meings.
Members of the public wishing to
participate in the public comment
portion of our meeting called a
dedicated AISD phone line in advance of
the meeting to audiorecord their
remarks. Tonight we have 20 who left a
recorded message. We will now play the
recorded messages for the public
comment. So, please listen carefully.
Hi, my name is Mackenzie Coronado and
I'm calling in regards to the
consolidation plan. We keep hearing how
you emphasize how important neighborhood
schools are. You have yet to ever visit
our campus, but if you had, you would
see that Brierwoods is a quintessential
neighborhood school. You would see
children walking and biking every
morning with their friends while parents
gather in the community out front of the
school. You would see our neighborhood
association meetings happening in our
cafeteria in the evenings. You would see
the neighbors having a football game on
Thanksgiving Day and our soccer fields.
Bikerwoods as a neighborhood does not
have a park, library, or meeting point.
Our school is essential in this
community, and it would forever change
the historical nature of our
neighborhood for generations to come if
it were closed. We need a concrete
answer as to why Brierwoods is closing.
Our trustee has said that she does not
agree with it being on the closure list.
Lastly, we are very proud of our IB
accreditation, one of which our own PTA
is paid for. You all have planted a seed
as if our new school, new zone school
could somehow transfer our accreditation
or work towards a new one. But that's
just simply not how the IB program
works. Our staff and parents have gone
above and beyond to make sure that our
children are receiving the best
education possible. And it seems as if
our amazing program is somehow working
against us in the eyes of TEA. Is this
true? Thank you for your time and
consideration.
>> Hi, my name is Gracie Hines and I'm a
Bear Creek Elementary parent. Griski is
our neighborhood middle school and
should serve all Circle B kids,
including those from Bear Creek. The
proposal fractures our tight-knit
community, isolating parts of our
neighborhood, including Avana where I
live. We already have a cohesive and
successful feeder pattern where all
Circle T elementaryaries attend Griski
and then Buouie. This should be a model
of success for the district, not one
that is destroyed. The rationale for
reszoning Bear Creek to Bailey is to
alleviate overcrowding at Griski.
However, ASC's own projections show
Griski's enrollment is trending down and
with our current zoning will be only 87%
full in 2029, making these changes
unnecessary. It is short-sighted to say
that Circle T has outgrown Griski.
Additionally, travel logistics and
safety are serious concerns that our
community has been incredibly vocal
about. Switching to Bailey means longer,
more congested, and less less safe
commutes requiring use of a high injury
network road, highways, and potentially
a toll road. We estimate a new bus route
would add at least 40 extra minutes per
day compared to the current commutiski.
AISD should be focusing on improving
enrollment at our schools to fill them,
not moving kids around like ponds and
making it harder for those of us who
want to choose public schools to do so.
Thank you.
This is Sharon Bane, parents of AISD
graduates. What I'm hoping to see from
tonight's workshop, more on the academic
vision. We're working towards most
parents need something more detailed
than every child attends well-resourced
schools and something less detailed than
a playbyplay of curriculum. What are the
milestones? What are the supports and
when will we get there? Two, details on
how the bond money will follow students.
Is there a rubric? What public reporting
will there be? Three, more specifics on
the plan to ensure that special
education students will continue to have
access to necessary programs amid
consolidations.
Four, can you explain with examples why
some options are only options because
consolidations and taps are being voted
on together? And last but not least,
what is the plan to bring more emergent
bilingual students into the wall-to-wall
schools once they move? Simply creating
proximity is not a plan. Good luck and
thank you.
>> My name is Ben Hooton. I'm a parent of
two Brierwoods children and this
consolidation uh consolidation plan has
a fatal flaw. It ignores attrition. AISD
is assuming Brewood's families will
simply accept reassignments and I'm not
sure what that's based on. The data
contradicts this entire premise.
Breerwoods is in good condition. The
facility is sound. The community is
engaged. You're closing a functional
school during a capacity crisis where
Austin is growing. Here's what actually
happens. Families leave the districts,
not just Rikerwood's families, but
families across AISD who see that
neighborhood schools can be closed
arbitrarily regardless of condition or
community. Every family that leaves
costs AISD 13 plus thousands in annual
for pre-pole funding. And when you
multiply that by hundreds of families
across multiple school closers, it that
isn't speculation. and it's documented
in every district that's tried this.
You're not solving a budget problem.
You're creating one. So, my question is,
how will AISD recover when this plan
triggers the exodus that you haven't
accounted for?
>> Hello, my name is Maddie Kaitton. I'm a
parent of a kindergartner at Breerwoods
Elementary, which is slated to close. As
a former ASD graduate myself, I'm
strongly supportive of our public
schools and I want healthy community
schools that anyone in Austin could
access. The decision to send our
daughter to an AISD elementary school
was an easy one because we have an AIAB
rated school with an IB curriculum, the
only elementary school in Austin with it
within walking distance of our house.
This school is actively keeping kids in
Austin and out of private and charter
schools. And in surveys, twothirds of
our families have said that they would
strongly consider leaving AISD if the
school closes. This is not just a couple
hundred kids. This is generations of
Central Austin kids that'll be more
inclined to go to private schools to
kids ASD has closed their neighborhood
school. They have no proof that closing
our school will save a single dollar.
And in fact, taking in consideration
attrition, transportation c costs, and
recapture, closing our school will cost
AIC money. Closing good schools will
push more kids out of AISD, leading to
even lower enrollment overall in a
spiral downwards for AID. This is the
last thing I or any other Breerwoods
parent wants. Please do not let this be
your legacy. Stop.
>> My name is Katherine Lions and I'm a
parent at Breerwoods Elementary. Um, my
comment is around the budget deficit and
closing schools. This administration has
already conceded that closing schools
doesn't save money and Breaker Woods has
provided research that backs that
assertion up. Um, closing schools does
not save money. It will not fix the
budget deficit. There will not be money
to support schools that are implementing
TAP plans and the district is sitting on
hundreds of millions of dollars of real
estate. Um the solve here is to sell
property and take time to do real
thoughtful analysis on how we can
balance the budget going forward. I've
heard that this is a band-aid. I love
band-aids. I have kids. We use band-aids
all the time. They prevent infection and
further in injury. And this plan is an
infection for the district and will
result in a loss of faith across our
community. Please, please, please take a
beat and reconsider this plan. It's not
going to work.
My name is Annie Edmonds. My son Owen
Edmonds goes to Breaker Woods Elementary
School. Look, people are losing trust in
our public education system, and this
plan is going to spiral the loss of the
trust. Families are going to leave AISD.
We can't have that. We know AIC has a
history of bad data and we saw in 2019
that they did not get money back. We're
going to continue to see loss of money.
Data scientists have pushed this. We
need the trustees to get this right and
push AISD to focus on avoiding the TEA
takeover and not pursuing this
boundaries and consolidation plan right
now. Do not let this death spiral of
AISD be part of your legacy trustees. We
need to demand better data and invest in
a process that will bring families to
the district. Please pause the
consolidation process. Please keep high
performing and rolled schools like Bryer
Woods open. It's such a special IB
school. We move to this neighborhood to
send our sons to this elementary school.
Please trustees, get this right. This is
not the time to invest in this
consolidation plan. We will not save
money through this plan. We need to
focus on avoiding a TEA takeover. We
need to focus on keeping good
>> Hi, this is Jackie Keller. I have a
student in fourth grade at Bear Creek
Elementary in the Avana and Grey Rock
Ridge communities. Our community is part
of the overall Circle Se community. All
schools in Circle Cer where my older son
attended, Clayton, and Bear Creek all
are zoned to Geriski Middle School. Our
community is heavily impacted by a
transition of shifting our students from
Bear Creek Elementary over to Bailey
Middle School. That represents a
hardship for our community because we
are primarily two working family homes.
We need support from our community for
transportation, for afterchool events to
get our students to and from school just
about every day. In middle school at
Geriski, this means we have neighbors,
older siblings, and other community
members already at the school, but can
support our families when we need it
most. Our students if they are shifted
over to Bailey would require
>> Hello, my name is Kil Pennaker and I'm a
break awards parent as well as an Austin
and high school alum. I'm calling
because I'm worried that this plan will
plunge AICS into a larger financial
crisis. Just at our school, twothirds of
parents are planning to pull their kids
from AISD if the schoolation moves
forward. And we suspect those numbers
are even higher given how acrimonious
this process has been. We know that
we're not the only school facing this.
We've heard anecdotally from many other
schools that families are looking very
seriously at charter schools and private
schools or leaving Austin altogether if
this moves forward. We need AISD to
pause this process and ensure that we
don't plunge into a bigger financial
crisis.
>> Spend time getting process right. AIS
has a problematic track record opposing
schools. Less we forget 2019 school
closures actually cost the district
money. Please please do this right. keep
the integrity of AISD EPA out and be
much more thoughtful about the process.
Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Andrew Edmonds and I'm
speaking about the AISD consolidation
plan as a parent of a student at Brier
Woods. Uh, six years ago there was a
similar exercise done with school
closures that were supposed to save the
district money, but they didn't.
Enrollment dropped, families left, and
AISD lost both revenue and community
trust. This plan is three times larger
without doing the careful school by
school analysis that should come first.
Independent data scientists reviewed the
numbers and found the district will lose
almost a half million dollars in the
first year alone. We can't afford to
repeat the same mistakes on a bigger
scale. Trustees, please pause this plan
and demand accurate, transparent data
before moving forward. Our communities
are focused around these school
locations as a driver for relationships,
growth, and community cohesiveness.
Please, please, please ensure you're
making the right decision to make Austin
a better place. Thank you.
>> My name is Kelsey Long and I'm a parent
with two daughters at Breerwoods
Elementary. This proposed consolidation
plan, which threatens to close Berwoods,
puts AISD at tremendous risk. President
Boswell herself says losing just 72
students means about $1 million less in
funding for the district. At Breerwood
alone, twothirds of families have said
that they would leave AISD if our school
closes. That's not saving. That's an
even deeper financial crisis. Our school
is growing in position to help AISD
thrive. Not true. We've had to turn
families away who want to be part of our
vibrant community, and it's the
district's only IBertified elementary
school. Additionally, three independent
data scientists found that closing Brier
Woods could cost the district $470,000
in the first year and create an ongoing
$170,000 annual deficit. And that's even
before accounting for lost enrollment.
Trustees, we need you to do it right.
Demand better data, pause this
consolidation plan, and keep
high-erforming, highly enrolled schools
like Brierwoods open. Thank you.
>> Hello, this is Cece Jung. Our family is
one of 117 students in East Silker being
reszoned and displaced from our
neighborhood school. The current
Sanchez, Becker, and Zilker plan creates
an avoidable domino effect on all
communities. Why has it not been further
explored to keep Sanchez open with a
robust turnaround plan? Merge Becker and
Dawson together as a non-zoned
wall-to-wall school to satisfy the goal
of supporting the local emerging
bilingual population. redistribute the
Becker and Dawson zones equitably
between Zilker, Galindo, and Travis
Heights and keep our e Zilker boundary
in its pre-draft version. The draft
recommendations create nonsensical
disruption for all families. The
proposed plan is vying to be season 3 of
Nobody Wants This except with confused
parents, new plot twists, and no happy
endings.
>> Hi, my name is Caitlyn Casten. I am a
mother of a child at Patton Elementary
with a another child that is um not
currently in public education, but I
would like her to be. Um I have been
involved in this process all summer from
the beginning. And last night on the um
Q&A session, I heard some things that I
really just do not feel like are being
applied equally across the board.
Multiple times, multiple members of the
district mentioned that highways are
being used as barriers and boundaries.
Yet my neighborhood, Becket Meadows and
um Western Oaks were moved under Mopac
to attend a new school. That's eight to
maybe 10 kids per grade level, maybe 50
families that already still choose AISD.
The rest of our neighborhoods have
chosen to get their education somewhere
else. We have invested in AISD and in
our community and in our schools. And we
were told last night that the reason
that our children are losing their
friends and connection is because we
happen to live between a school boundary
that is too big and a school boundary
that is too narrow. Those are the fault
of the district, not
>> Hi, I am an Austin ISD parent of two
girls and I'm pulling today to urge the
board to reconsider this draft
consolidation plan that AISD has given
you.
Right now, ASD is at a crossroads and we
need to focus on the pending TEA
turnaround. This has been a distraction
from our students, from educators and
it's frankly not needed at this point.
There is budget cuts to be made both at
headquarters and at administration that
can bridge the budget for another year.
However, AISD is not providing you with
those options because that would be hard
for them. They want us as parents to do
the hard thing. And I'm asking you as
the board to ensure that you are our
voice as public servants and that you
tell AISD to decouple the taps from this
plan and focus on our students and we
can come back with a community-based
plan later on. Thank you.
>> Hi, this is Melissa Brown. I am a parent
of Satie Brown at Breerwoods Elementary
and I just wanted to emphasize um the uh
hope that you guys will reconsider
closing um or not closing Berwoods. Um
we are an IB school. Um we have a great
rating. We are a neighborhood school. Um
and there's really no justified reason
to close Berwoods. We've done the cost
analysis. Um it will actually cost the
district money. Uh I think in the first
year we've assessed that it will cost
the district $470,000
and then an ongoing um over $100,000 per
year to keep that um if you close
Brierwoods. Um and there's there's
really no um reason to close it based on
data like the rubric that data that you
had um was incorrect as well. Um because
of all that it does it is irresponsible
and unethical really to close high
performing schools without any um any
real justification other than optics and
that's kind of how it seems. So just
want my voice to be heard. Um I look
forward to engaging um with the district
more on it. Thank you.
>> Good afternoon. My name is Laura Ramos
and I'm an Avana resident with children
at in second and fifth grade at Bear
Creek Elementary. Well, we appreciate
that AIC may allow our current fifth
grader to attend Grizzky Middle School,
which is where they're now zoned. They
would no longer have a bus, and this
doesn't address our concerns for our
younger child. Um, you mentioned that
Gitzky is being overenrolled, yet GMS
currently had allowed student transfers
into the school. The plan also, um,
resends kids from small to Gitzky,
taking our kids away from the school
that they're currently at. Um, GMS
enrollment is predicted to decline by
ASC prediction reports. Why not stop the
transfers at Gretzky and and not move
kids from small to GMs? Yesterday, it
was also mentioned that bus routes will
be decided after boundaries are set and
that no one has driven the uh routes
yet. That worries us because decisions
are being made without understanding the
true cost, safety risk, and daily impact
on families. Many in our community have
already said that they won't send their
children to Bailey. Um so families are
leaving AISD and it's already affecting
our Bear Creek enrollment. Um, we want
our kids to stay in AISD, but options
like Valor Vera, Host Regents, and EMS
are close by.
>> I ask that you consider Pan Springs
Elementary as the new unzoneed home for
Austin's Montasuri program. A school
closer to the current Montasuri campus
at WIN. Our Montasur community has built
something incredibly valuable. A program
where students and are thriving
academically, families are deeply
engaged, and educators are trained and
committed to the Montasur and dual
language model. That continuity in staff
leadership and students is what makes it
work and that continuity will keep it
succeeding and growing. 84% of
Winmontory families live within five
minutes of the current campus including
more than half of our transfers. 19
Windtory students already live in the
Peon Springs zone. Relocating the
program to Pan Springs would keep these
families connected and sustain the
culture that's already producing strong
results. Regardless of the location of
the Montasauri, we ask that the district
provide transportation for current wind
students to ensure accessibility and
equity as the program transitions.
Please commit to continuing the d
two-way dual language model that's the
cornerstone of our success. We ask the
district to identify specific
recruitment resources so families in the
new area know about this unique unzoned
opportunity and how to apply. Thank you.
>> Elicia Mlan Becker parent. In 2015,
there were 83,720
students in public education here in
Austin ISD. And in 2022, there were just
33,000 students. And now, in 2025, there
are about 69,000 students. That means
that we've lost approximately 3500
students from public education in 3
years. There hasn't been a decline of
students available to attend public
schools. As there's more than 35,000
students here in the district, their
families are just choosing charter,
private, and home schools. This draft
plan, as written, will drive more
students away, especially in a school of
choice systems with upcoming vouchers
and private charter schools ready to
recruit them. And if just 1,800 of them
leave the district, then the savings
from the 13 schools you close will be
null and void. Please listen to our
needs. Please reconsider these closions
closures. Instead of closures, we need a
plan that brings our students back to
public education, not pushes them
further away.
Hello, my name is Annie Croft and I'm a
parent at Bikerwoods Elementary and I
strongly urge you not to move forward
with this consolidation plan. You've
spoken frequently about equity in this
plan and process. But equity is not
punitive. It is about expanding
opportunity for those with fewer
resources, not creating pain for some
communities so others might catch up.
What's happening here feels like pain
for pain's sake. closing a small
high-erforming school in central west
Austin simply to spread the impact and
discomfort to that area of the city.
This is not equity. This is loss without
purpose. We are willing to have
difficult conversations and make
sacrifices if the benefits are clear and
measurable. But past closures haven't
shown that without datadriven proof that
this will save money and spare students
harm, moving ahead is irresponsible and
undermines public trust. Please pause
this process. demand accurate data and
choose a path that keeps families in
AISD and schools like Breerwoods
thriving. Thank you.
>> Thank you. This
>> Hi, this is Gerardo Coronado. I'm a
parent at Breerwood Elementary. Um, I
would ask of the trustees to uh take the
time to get this process right and push
the administration to get this process
right and to have the district focus on
avoiding TEA takeover and also maybe add
some additional time to pursue a process
that factors in student attrition, how
many students the district may lose if
this consolidation plan does proceed as
it is proposed. And then also of the
administration, I would like to ask who
on the academic leadership team has
successfully turned around a title one
elementary campus or facilitated a
turnaround plan. If no one has, how is
the district ensuring plans are informed
by proven experience and facilities
changes? Thank you very much. Uh
>> thank you uh to all of our callers. This
concludes our public public comment.
Trustees, are there any questions?
Seeking clarification.
All right. Thank you. Uh, as a reminder
to our public, you can share any general
comments or questions with the board by
email at trusteesaustinisd.org.
We will now move on to the consolidation
work session, and I will turn it over to
Superintendent Sigura. Thank you.
>> Uh, thank you, President Boswell, board
of trustees. Um I uh we've allocated two
and a half hours uh to this work
session. Uh this is based on the
available time that that we have as we
track um using kind of what time counts
for student based outcomes and which
does not. Uh we have an agenda as you so
I'm going to go through the first part
of this session fairly quickly to make
sure that we spend time with our
trustees and having them deliberate and
have conversations around each different
elements within the plan. Uh so the
agenda is going to be as follows. Uh
we'll have a brief overview of the
timeline. We'll talk about the feedback
analysis that's currently underway.
We'll identify some uh refinements and
clarifications uh right now that will be
reflected in the October 31st submission
or or release. And then we'll uh dive
deeply into um seven different areas.
The goal would be to spend about 20
minutes in each area. We're really going
to want our trustees to have an open
dialogue, you know, ask questions,
explore different ideas, uh, and then,
um, move on to the next. And as we build
up time, we may have some flexibility at
the end, but we certainly want to keep
us moving along. And so, uh, as we move
forward, you'll have you'll see
different folks kind of, uh, come up to
the to the table here and and engage
with the board. Um, as we get going, we
have Dr. Maxwell to my left, assistant
superintendent of academics K- through2.
We have Lisha Drinks, chief of staff. We
have Dr. French, director of planning.
And we have Christine Steampport, um,
operations officer. So, you'll see folks
come up up and and down just because
it's a it's a big effort and there lots
of folks available to answer any
questions. So, as we first uh move and
discuss kind of where we are in the
timeline,
uh, this uh, road map here shows uh,
where we've been and and where we intend
to go. This was first presented to our
trustees in a work session uh back in
February and March. Uh you can see here
that there's been a lot of work uh over
the last the last many months. Uh we are
in the process right now of working
through different refinements uh in the
draft plan and again this is a draft
plan. It will refine uh and adjust as we
move forward. Uh over this period of
time we've had uh lots of different
opportunities to engage with our
community. uh we uh first started this
back in May. I don't necessarily want to
go through each and every um opportunity
that we've had to engage. I do want to
point out there there are lots of other
engagements that we've had that haven't
are not um listed here either with the
team meeting with the CAC at a specific
campus. Uh many of these are by request.
you know, we're trying to be very
responsive and be wherever we can to
have those uh engagements to to learn um
and to improve and and to refine.
Uh we are also committed and there these
are currently underway um having
committee meetings with the 13 schools
that are identified within the uh
consolidation plan. Uh those are
underway. Uh and at the same time, we
are um having parallel committee
meetings at large. Uh three of them are
virtual. Uh one of them is in person.
And so as we move through, I just want
to provide a be a brief update on the
feedback analysis. Uh we've gotten lots
of feedback and and it's really helped
inform how we think through and uh
refine the plan. Uh early on we created
opportunity for um families and
community to engage with us through uh
community comments and comment cards. Uh
to date, we've received over 7,000 of
these cards. Um they're really great. Uh
there's lots of information in them. Uh,
and I will I want our community to know
and our board to know that each one of
these is uh evaluated. It's read. We um
spend time thinking through uh what it
means, what themes are coming out um of
the information we're collecting. Uh
we're providing responses and as themes
build uh we will take action and explore
and then if there is an action to be
taken uh we will make those adjustments.
Uh we're also capturing information
through these community meetings as well
as we hear things. uh you know from our
community or from our principles that
also comes into the process as well and
certainly this opportunity here as we
engage with our trustees.
Um as we move forward uh one of the
things that I I want to do uh is
communicate to you all as trust our
trustees as well as our community some
of those things that we've already
identified and we know will be reflected
in the next version of the draft plan
which is going to again be released here
in a couple days uh on October 31st. I
also want to note that I know it's
Halloween. Um we are going to be looking
to release earlier in the day. Uh we are
we're striving to to release, you know,
early afternoon. Um I I certainly do not
want to provide an update late in the
evening when our families are, you know,
collectively together engaging in
whatever they may be engaging with that
night. Um but some of the clarifications
uh are around uh transfer policies,
transportation boundary updates, and
programs. And so a couple that I wanted
to share and just be really clear about
uh was in the new plan or in the draft
or in the update. You'll see a um a
couple and I'm going to read them out. I
think it's really important that we list
them. Uh continuation continuation
transfers will also include rising sixth
and ninth graders if their feeder school
has changed. So this is based on
feedback that we got um from our
community around the fact that families
plan they're they plan to go to middle
school. they spend their entire
elementary school planning to go to
middle school uh or a middle school to a
high school. And to have a disruption
take place in that last year uh is
something we wanted to address. We
wanted to be really clear uh and and
show a commitment to ensuring that those
students no matter what happens have the
opportunity to go into that school that
they had been planning for all along. Uh
the next one, transfer students in a
school proposed to close or have a
program change will be guaranteed a spot
to stay with their peers at the new
school location. Uh so this applies at
multiple in multiple scenarios in the
plan. Uh what we're saying here is we
recognize that families transfer into a
program or or um access a a school or
area at a school and if that school
changes we want that student to stay
with their their cohort of students
right their friends the families to stay
together. And so uh we didn't have a
mechanism prior to the initial release
on October 3rd. we now um have created a
structure around it to ensure if a
family chooses to continue on with this
student population and the cohort,
they're able to do so. Uh the next one,
preK students will be allowed to
continue at their their current campus.
Uh just wanted to can be really clear
about what that um means and that is a
change. We can make that commitment. Uh
and we're um very happy to be able to do
so. This is a big one. Uh staff and
sibling transfers will be automatically
approved. uh unless otherwise not
approved by the superintendent. And so
what I what I want to when I'm out in
community, what I talk about is I as a
superintendent never want our families
to have to go to two elementary schools
to go drop a third grader off and then
go to and drop a first grader off. Like
that's not who we are. Um but I
recognize that without having that clear
um kind of mechanism within our system
to ensure it, it it's an unknown. And
so, uh, I know our trustees whenever
these appeals come up, we are very clear
about not wanting to have that burden be
placed on our community and our own
families. So, uh, we kind of
systematically address it in that way,
but we want to be really clear like this
is going to be, uh, preserved. Um, if
you are a sibling or you have a sibling
in the school, we're going to
automatically approve that transfer. uh
when it says not otherwise approved by
the superintendent. What I'm trying to
call out here is that you may have a
student uh that's at an Richards or at a
magnet program. Um what we're trying to
say is sometimes we do have transfer
requests for siblings into that program.
That's an application based program and
that's different. Um so just wanted to
make that clear as to why that was um
identified at the end of that um
statement. Students uh in attendance
zones for new schoolwide dual language
programs will receive transportation.
So, uh, when we when we talk about, um,
you know, how how we as a school
district want to support, uh,
schoolwide, um, dual language programs,
we wanted to be really clear about the
intention of, um, placing them in Austin
IC. We had numbers of emerging bilingual
students who could support all dual
language programs. But the one thing
that we wanted to ensure is that these
students had access, right? That's
really what we're trying to do. uh not
moving the program doesn't ensure
access. We wanted to go to one step
further. We heard this from our
community loud and clear. We've heard it
from trustees. We've heard it from um
families. And so uh we have looked at
it. We can do it uh in this plan. That
would mean Pickle, uh Sanchez, Wooten,
and ODM. Uh we would provide
transportation for the students that
reside in the attendance boundary of the
new location. That does that make sense?
Um go ahead.
the the schoolwise don't have a
boundary. So, they would be the pre the
current boundary of the school that's
being
>> That's exactly right. That's exactly
right. And we we uh
>> that's that's a we kind of were working
through the words on the way to describe
that accurately. Um but essentially what
we're saying is the attendance boundary
of the school, as you just said, that's
receiving the program. We would want fam
families in that in that attendance
boundary where the emerging bilingual
students live to feel welcome and to
provide that access and one way to help
ensure it is provide transportation but
within that attendance boundary
currently. So the Sanchez would be the
attendance boundary would use for
instance for that program. The next one,
uh, JSON language immersion in Go Valley
Monasuri students will receive
transportation unless within the two-m
radius. Uh, if there's a designated
hazardous area,
uh, this is not too much of a deviation.
Uh, we know that districtwide
transportation is already provided in
many cases, but we want to be really
clear that even with the move and with
the changes that we're going to be able
to provide and support that. Um the next
one is current third or fourth graders
not enrolled in dual language can stay
and participate in temporary English ESL
um strand at nonzone dual language
campuses. This is really wanting to
ensure that students who had been in the
school um still continue to feel
welcomed and can stay in that school
until they move into the next um kind of
school type middle school for instance.
Uh we've [snorts] worked through it. we
have the a way to to support that
transition and um that will be reflected
in the next version of the plan as well.
And the last one I wanted to just
clearly communicate was that the
Mandarin instruction uh that currently
is at Riley uh will be um offered at
Wooten. This is one of those things that
we heard loud and clear. We went back to
the drawing board. um given the
accessibility of of of DOSs where
Jocelyn is uh we really felt like given
um the opportunity and and if we could
facilitate it we'd like to do it we've
gone back to drawing board and we can do
it. So that's going to be reflected in
the next version which will be released
on October 31st. So go ahead
>> sorry trusty dad say
>> just to back up on the third and fourth
graders would they proceed to the new
feeder pattern of what their home school
would have been?
>> No. So, so once we move school types for
all transfers, then they would go into
the newly assigned feeder pattern if
that's changed.
Does that make
>> but I'm asking for if they're at the
non-zoned one, are they going to go from
where they would have been zoned?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So, um the other thing I'm not sure what
happened on that screen uh that I wanted
to share is that we are going to be
adding additional deliverables. I know
when we uploaded our documents on
October 3rd, I think there were 11 or 12
attachments. Uh we wanted to be really
clear about all the data being very
transparent. Um so we're going to um
uh um update all those and when you see
the new version, it'll have a kind of
open parenthetical kind of revision uh
with the new date so that it's very
clear. This has been updated, this has
been updated, this has been updated.
Perhaps there's one or two that stay the
same. I don't think there'll be many of
them, but it'll be really really clear
to our community what's been changed. Uh
on the um overall document, the larger
report, you're going to see annotations.
We wanted to, you know, if you look at a
new document and you don't know exactly
where you're at and you look at the old
document, it's kind of hard to tell
what's changed. So, what we're doing is
taking the old document and annotating
it and saying, "Hey, this is the comment
we heard. This is how it finds itself
into the report. This is what the change
is." and then tying it back to the
comment that or the set of comments that
inform that change. Um, and so that
should help uh kind of connect and show
to our community the work that we've
done and how it's making its way into
the document. [snorts] We are also going
to be releasing additional documents uh
to include um a couple attachments. I'm
going to read them out. The uh academic
framework addendum which is was
previously a narrative or portion of a
narrative in the report that's going to
be pulled out as a standalone um
document. uh special education
transition plan. Uh the finance uh
addendum uh that was previously
embedded. It's going to be pulled out uh
to allow for the detail um and not get
lost in the larger report. Uh and then
enrollment and transfer policies
addendum. You know, just given how
important that is, just having that be
pulled out and be really clear, it allow
us to make adjustments as we move
forward and not be tied to the all the
other things that are in that larger
report. Additionally, um this is going
to be a little challenging, but I think
it's really important that we um share
the data from that we've received from
our comments. There's a lot of it,
right? That all the and we have to
redact much of it because when people
have shared with us, they're sharing
with us things that are personal to them
and we don't want anybody to read a
comment and from it be able to
understand who where it came from or who
it is. So, that's a pretty significant
effort. Um we we're we are committed to
doing it. It's just I want you to know
that there's a lot that is going to be
pulled out because of just what people
shared and and that's okay. [snorts]
Um the comment comm uh comment card
community feedback themed. So as you can
imagine we over 7,000 comments cards
they're you can group them in themes.
Sometimes they're actually in conflict
right where there's Matias would you
what about this idea and there'll be
comments around this idea. And so we
decided to do was to theme it out as
well. We'll have the raw data and then
we'll say this is what these sets of
comments around this particular area
said to us. Trusty Hunter.
>> Yes. Um I asked to have access to that
uh document to read all of them. Do we
have access to that?
>> Um I'm not sure if we've been able to
provide access. I mean
>> we can. Yeah, we we can provide access.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Do we know when? Um
perhaps by tomorrow midday
>> by tomorrow
>> I think tomorrow midday yeah what I what
I will say is um what you're going to
see is is a working document from us as
well because we're we're adding columns
adding responses and it's it's building
all the time. Uh so it is uh it is a lot
but yeah we're happy to provide um
feedback. What I what I was trying to
attempting to do is to provide it
without showing like there's a lot
that's deliberating in the cells to the
right of the comments and so we're
trying to clean it up and just show you
what the comments were opposed to all
the different iterations ideations after
that we're doing. So that's kind of
added to the complexity but we'll make
it public to you all and make it
available. Um what goes public will have
things redacted.
Uh proposed change track changes
tracker. So anytime there is a change in
the plan we are tracking it. We wanted
to have that as a log. That'll be
included as well. And then outstanding
areas of exploration. I recognize that
there are things that we're not going to
be able to complete an analysis on or uh
get to a recommendation before we have
to go pencils down to sub to update the
document on the 31st. And so I I want to
be really clear about what those things
are. You know, hey, this is something
that came out of the work session. It's
going to require some more energy. I'm
exploring it. We are exploring it. And
so it'll be communicated out as a cover
sheet as well as an attachment to the
deliverable um that that is still
ongoing work. And so um now what we're
going to do is to transition to the next
um section of the work session uh and go
kind of focus area by focus area. Uh
these areas were pulled from different
conversations with trustees, different
um things that were shared with me. uh
we are trying to find the things that
really require discussion so that we can
get feedback and then take the next
step. Uh this is based on kind of our
pulling of information from our trustees
as well as conversations we've had with
with you all and what we've heard in the
community. Um I'm going to pause. I've
said a lot. I'm trying to stay on time.
Trust President Bwell.
>> So yeah, do we have questions? Anyone
have quick questions about what we've
heard so far in the adjustments?
Trusty Coffin. Yeah, I just have one
quick question about the commitment to
transportation for students in the new
um nonzoned
dual language schools. Would that apply
based on the same existing rules for
transportation that they have now?
>> Yes.
>> Like a student across the street will
not be wheeled over. They'll it'll be
the two-m radius and the safe. Okay.
>> That's exactly right.
>> If you could just be really clear on
that. I don't want someone to feel that
that's a broken promise that they're a
mile away and they think they're going
to start getting transportation when
they didn't previously.
>> That's a good point. I can make it very
clear.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you, Trusty Canenna.
>> Um I just want to clarify that any
recommendations or thoughts that are
shared tonight will be a part of the
draft on Friday. No.
>> Well, it so there's a lot in this. So it
depends on what it is. So if there is
something comes out this conversation
that is a a simple adjustment and we can
make that adjustment and we can get it
into documents get it translated then we
will do it. If it is a bigger idea that
requires more work then what I'm going
to do is make a statement and say hey
for this part of the of the report there
is still work ongoing and we'll release
an update you know over the next
sometime in the next week to kind of
pull that back in. There's simply just a
lot that has to get done between the
idea, the testing, confirming we can do
it, the translation, developing the
documents and posting the documents um
in a way that's accessible and and so
that's why I want to be really clear
about what we're continuing on. So there
will be some things but I don't I can't
say that all things depending on where
the conversation goes. Is that helpful?
>> Thank you Trusty Foster.
>> Uh just for for clarity so as we focus
it's sort of
kind of school by school and region by
region which is sort of geographic and
so focused on the schools. Um where do
sort of bigger picture or sort of
crosscutting issues come into our
conversation? So for instance, if
there's ideas about the theory of action
behind transportation and how it should
be applied that's not to one campus
that's kind of across and there's a
couple of other examples. So where do we
bring that up in the conversation? I
>> I think if there's an area where you
would want to um kind of apply that or
have that considered I would share it.
you know, I I don't I don't want to have
like a separate area to talk about
everything else like
>> Sure.
>> You know, maybe that idea came about
because we were talking about a specific
part of of the plan. I would just
introduce it.
>> So, just first first time it's Germaine
just introduce it.
>> Yeah, that's that's exactly right
because we and
>> Thank you.
>> that will help us. I mean, honestly,
just to kind of know when it's applied
when it's when it's when it's um
abstract or like large, it it's
sometimes hard to define and implement.
So really having an example like, hey,
this is how I could see it working here
and then we can test it and then having
the the the
example to work off is actually very
helpful.
>> Got it. And I'll try to be clear or
maybe we'll try to be clear to say like
it's been raised because we're on page
32, but this is systemwide
>> commentary. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Got it. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Trusty Wley, too.
>> Uh, yeah. Just just quickly, I want to
say I'm I'm I'm really grateful for
clarifying and improving some of the
transfer policies
um that I think they're very um family
and child focused and I've, you know,
been I'm excited that a lot of the stuff
I've been advocating for um is on here.
So, I do want to take the chance to
advocate for another transfer policy. Um
so, we have, you know, students who have
transferred staying with their group.
Um, right now the district does not have
a policy that um, gives a child any
preference in transfer policy if they
were zoned and then they have to move.
Um, so as a teacher, I'd see that a lot
where um, a child's, you know, had to
move to a different apartment when their
lease went up and even, you know,
changing a street can mean that that
child has to to go to a different
school. And I know this is something
that Trustee Singh has advocated for for
a long time that with with a charter
school um they don't have to to move to
another school and then and we've seen
families who a family gets divorced and
now the the child can't continue at
their school next year. Um so I just
want to put that out there and then
>> so um just because I this is helpful. Um
would would you expect that that child
to have lived in that attendance zone
for a period of time? Um would they have
had like would it have to would they had
to have been the in the school already?
Um
>> I think a child who's in in the school
already.
>> Okay. So [snorts] a student is in the
school. I'm in I'm in second grade. I
move away um because of some other
extenduating circumstance. Maybe it's
rent, maybe it's something. um be given
an automatic give be given a a transfer
a transfer priority because that's where
I was previously
>> be treated the same as someone who had a
continuing transfer.
>> Got it.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. I and
>> and I think that can come to our policy
committee too. I think that would be a
great thing for our policy committee to
work on. So thank you.
>> But I guess the but once they leave that
school
that wouldn't continue just the way our
other transfers don't to middle or high.
like if you moved out of an ele
boundary, then you wouldn't continue on
to the middle school if you weren't
already in that middle school.
>> So, yeah, I' I'd ask that they'd be
treated the same as someone who had a
continuing transfer.
>> Got it.
>> Given the same priority.
>> Okay. Yeah, I think I mean we that's
helpful. I just wanted some clarity on
how to interpret that.
>> Thank you. Thank you, Trusty S.
>> But did you have another one for Trusty
Wy?
>> Um this is just a question that y'all
might not have the answer for yet. um
with the split schools like how would
how would that work with staying with
the cohort because some of the cohorts
are being divided in the current plan
and maybe that's being addressed that
they're your student.
>> Yeah, that's one of the things. Um so
that's really going to apply to the
students that are transfers in, right?
So if you're zoned then you're going to
get the ability to go to the the school
that you're going to. Um if you're a
transfer in, one of the things we're
committing to is that you can go with
the cohort. what if a school gets split
50-50 or seven, you know, 7030. You
know, we would allow allow for
flexibility to be one of the two schools
effectively is what we would do. Um, you
know, that's kind of one of those
nuances and that's and so as we move
forward, we're going to add kind of more
clarity around the sub bullets, but
that's one thing that could happen.
>> Thank you. Okay. Now, trust us too soon.
>> Sure. Um, okay. So, I noticed that
there's a finance addendum in additional
um deliverables list. So, thank you for
that. Uh so I just wanted to request
that in that um financial projection we
have various models that have different
assumptions um that are like from more
conservative to less conservative and
acknowledge like different scenarios for
enrollment um different scenarios for
transportation. You know, all these
things sound great, but they they do
have a cost. And I think it's really
important for the trustees and the
public to really see that we may not get
a whole bunch of money, you know, saved
in the first year or two because we are
making a shift. But, you know, whatever
the projections are going to be three
years out, five years out, 10 years out,
I think that's going to be really,
really important for us to have public
and documented. and in addition a way to
um monitor that that is not something we
did after the 2019 closures and it's
really biting us um you know where and I
really want to not repeat you know that
mistake and just make sure that we are
very realistic with the public about
what the anticipated savings could be um
and when and really do look at the
enrollment um potential fluctuations in
enrollment and and the additional cost
of transportation in particular
Thank you, Trusty Hunter. Oh, do we
>> Well, I was just going to say one of the
things um
this is one of those areas that uh it's
challenging to determine kind of the max
and min of the sensitivity analysis
because um
there's there's going to be a disruption
and we recognize that it's just you know
the certainty around 5% 10% 25% and and
I I there's there's different school
districts that have gone through this
that have seen different things and then
we have our own experience experience
with what we went through right in 2019.
Now, that was obviously right before the
pandemic and everything kind of went in
a different direction. Um, and so, uh,
you know, what we're going to do is do
the analysis and then at the end apply,
um, kind of an assump an sensitivity
analysis on it being up or down. What I
worry about is, um, campus by campus, I
think it's easier. When you think about
the entire school district, the question
becomes, well, what's the the weight of
vouchers? What's the what happens if you
actually begin to improve academic
outcomes and stabilized schools in East
a in parts of Austin where they hadn't
been previously and you align feeder
patterns? There's lots of arguments that
you could actually see an increase in
those areas as well. So, there's there's
both that I have to kind of work
through. I really wanted to focus the
analysis on the the impact of the
schools tied to these changes. Um, and
then we can add on top of it other
considerations. It's just that second
part is is pretty hard to to quantify.
Um, but yeah, we're we're we're going
down campus by campus. Uh, so you'll see
that in in the in the version. Um, I
just I think sensitivity analysis is is
the way to do it. Um, it's just the
assumptions that you apply are
everything.
So, will we have that with assumptions
before the board vote?
>> Yeah. So, we Yes. So, the on Friday,
you're going to have a deeper analysis.
So, instead of it broken down as a
total, you're going to go campus by
campus by campus. Um, what we're not
going to show in that document is, you
know, what are what could vouchers do?
What happens, you know, if the federal
government changes? I mean, there's just
so many other things.
>> Uh, so we're going to really kind of
keep it to the what we believe the
impact of this is. uh and not bring in
everything else because okay I can I
just
>> you know there there's a lot that has
changed in the last 18 months
>> that you know I just so
>> sure no I appreciate that I think
>> that's just hard that second the second
part this this one we can do
>> okay but but like the enroll but like
the voucher part I understand we but you
can put like there are economist reports
and things like that that are out there
that do have assumptions so even though
that would happen regardless of whether
we consolidate or not like I get that.
But I just think like there could be
attrition um you know where with some of
this there is research you know around
it. I just want to make sure we're
capturing that and we're not afraid to
just acknowledge it because I
transparency and trust is just going to
that that's just part of the
transparency and trust um in this whole
process. So I would appreciate um seeing
that definitely before the vote. Thanks.
>> Thank you Trusty Hunter.
I was just going to say the ad hoc uh
budget committee already asked for uh
plus 1% plus 2% I mean plus 1% 5 no 1 3
and 5% and then negative 1 3 and 5% and
I think those are really good like round
figures that we could have and so that
they've asked for that and they've also
asked for um the budgeting account of
the 25 million so I think when they
share that with the budget just share
with us I mean it's one one task, we all
see the same thing.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Um, just a couple of quick
things. Um, I I hope that with this
change in plan for rising sixth and
ninth graders. We know that people are
doing campus visits right now that
elementary schools are visiting middle
schools, middle schools are visiting
high schools. I know that has been um
challenging for some of our students who
are expecting to be separated from their
peers. uh if we how are we notifying
families that this change will be
included no matter what happens going
forward that those kids will have that
option. I hope we're notifying those
families very quickly because people are
in the midst of making decisions right
now. Um we know that charters are coming
after kids that private schools are
recruiting right now. The sooner we can
let our kids and our our families know
so that kids can be fully engaged in
those visits. Thank you for that. Um I
hope that's happening quickly. um want
to be sure that the transfer students
can go with their peers at schools that
close at all of our campuses. I know um
the numbers at Breakerwoods, if Breaker
Woods uh closes, we're going to be very
tight and they didn't have a guarantee
in the same way some other campuses did.
Want to be sure that promise if that is
what happens that that promise applies
to them as well. Um thank you. And then
um I also want to make sure we're
talking about recruitment with uh the
dual language programs. I know families
really did a lot of that recruitment.
Families that were backing the dual
language carried a lot of that burden
last time and those programs would not
have been successful without that and
really want to be sure there's a robust
plan for that. We've heard that loud and
clear from families who were there 20
years ago when those programs were
created and carry that history with
them. Uh just want to make sure that is
heard and um planned for. And then um so
the boundary responses we're not going
to talk about tonight, but we'll see on
Friday. Is that correct?
>> Yeah. So we so um if we did boundaries
right now the So on the back of the
presentation
on the Well, did we add some of the
slides or we took them off?
>> They're the slides are should be
printed.
>> They're at the end. So there we started
to we have
>> examples of ones that we've already been
able to address and accept
>> um at the weighins but going and doing
it one by one.
>> Yeah, I know we can't do all of it. Just
want to be clear on what people expect
because it's listed on the table of
contents but not shown in the same way.
So just want real clarity because people
will be wondering and asking. So thank
you for that. And then I just want to
add my voice to the financial
information. I've asked quite a few
financial questions that I know many of
my colleagues have shared. Um that to me
is a really essential thing to have
ahead of a vote and I appreciate the
modeling. I know it's a wild card. I
know that. Um and but I think it's not
going to be zero in either direction and
and really want to have that really
clear understanding. Um and in addition
a really clear understanding of um what
this will and will not solve with our
budget next year. I think we need to be
really transparent with our community.
This is an immense amount of disruption,
but it's not going to close our budget
gap. But I want to be really, really
sure no one is taken by surprise when we
get to budgeting and still have to do
some painful things more likely than
not. And I want to be really honest um
with each other and with our community
about that. Thank you.
>> Yeah. And I appreciate that, Trusty.
Sorry, President Boswell. And one of the
things um that keeps coming up is offset
for turnaround plans, right? and and I I
caution lumping all of it all together
just because
we don't save any money or we don't do
anything and then we're still going to
do the turnaround plans, right? And so I
I just whenever we pull them together,
uh I think it is not telling the whole
story because there are lots of other
things that we spend dollars on. It's
not just the turnaround plans. It's not
just transportation. So my preference
would be to have both of them kind of
it's important to talk about them, share
what they are and progress them, but if
it ends up being that you're you're not
saving money because you're spending it,
but we're going to have to spend it
anyway. Um, so I just that's something
that we get kind of stuck on sometimes
when we tell the story because it is
going to be a cost reduction, but we're
also like we said, we we're going to
spend resources where our students have
the need, where we have the need to
spend. Um, so just that's one thing that
has been challenging as we model this
because there's been a lot of ask about,
you know, well, you're going to offset
this and the reality is, but we're going
to have that expense regardless if we're
going to be responsive to these surround
plans.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. Um, I want
to be conscious of our time. I think um
Josh can help us. Oh, Trusty Deio. Yep.
>> Sorry. I just wanted to touch quickly on
the special education transition plan
for some of the outstanding questions
that I know the community has. Um, one
early in the discussion we talked about
um, locations for centralized placements
and programming, you know, whether
especially at the elementary level like
SPS and scores are not on every campus
and so just how those are dispersed on
the district um, within the district,
but then also for the for the staffing
assignment and you know where students
are going to be. Um, I know families are
already asking teachers, particularly
at, you know, at schools that we're
closing, where they're going to end up.
Yeah.
>> And, you know, they're wanting to track
with that. And I think that also kind of
affects when they have other siblings
and and, you know, whether the siblings
going to go here, the other siblings
going to go there. Um, just, you know,
how how we're going to be able to look
at that and give information that the
families can then use to inform
transfers or any other decisions they're
going to be making. And um and I think
ensuring that the staffing is going to
kind of follow the student or the
students following staffing like kind of
how how that piece is going to go. And
then the last one just um you know we're
going to have to do a lot of hard
meetings in the spring I'm assuming and
and making sure that we're ready for
that that volume of getting those
through plus everybody else that had an
annual um due in the spring.
>> Do you want to I mean I know we're going
to be kind of tight on time. One of the
things I will say is that we we have
spent a lot of time talking about
transitioning um students that that have
um additional needs. Uh and what we're
going to do in the document that you see
on Friday is kind of outlining the
overall steps processes procedurally
what to expect and when. Um each campus
obviously is going to have a different
um a use a different uh approach and
strategy for that specific student group
and student population. Uh, and so what
we've been talking about, we meet with
with different schools is, hey, we need
to have the conversation with staff
included, with the principal included,
with everybody to make sure that the
transition is a successful one. We had a
conversation yesterday at Woodane that I
thought identified some of the things
that absolutely have to be in these
plans. But many of those things can't be
fully built out campus by campus until
we have those conversations. So right
now what we're doing is providing the
overall structure, the expectations, the
milestones, what we'll see procedurally
over the entire district and then the
expectations around when to see when
each of those campus by campus plans
will be developed. Um, I don't think I
need a a super detailed answer right
now, but I'm just hoping as as we
approach that deliverable that that's
going to be
>> inform those discussions for families
because I know they're asking teachers
now and and even just saying it's going
to be at least till January or whenever
that they're going to be able to
>> know because also applications at, you
know, schools are going to already have
started up and, you know, they're trying
to decide where to go. I do think one
thing to clarify is um we will have
plans that vary by campus, but the way
that we will expect arts and paperwork
um to look will be um very prescriptive,
right? to make to make sure that there's
consistency um across the district
because the last thing that students
need is for them to go to the receiving
campus and that campus is not sure um
how to provide the correct services. And
so we we talked to the vertical team
leaders yesterday. Dr. Lee presented a
draft of this plan to get their
feedback. Um and there was um a clear
consensus that that's necessary because
the principles are going to receive the
plans and they just want to make sure
that they are ready to serve the
students on the first day and so we are
going to put some guidelines around it.
>> Okay. Thank you. I would
>> just can I just do a time check? I I
feel like we either need to continue
asking general questions about these
overall programs or we need to go into
the focus areas, but we will not have
time to do both. I just want to make
sure that we make a deliberate decision
about that.
>> So, we have two hoursish left. We had
planned we have eight focus areas. We
had planned 20 minutes for each, but we
had this conversation. Um, I would
propose that maybe we spend 15 minutes
on each and go through. Do we think
we're in a good spot to do that and
Trusty Foster, I see that you have a
question. Do you want to ask it now or
hold? Well, the I think not derailing,
that's the wrong word, but I think part
of what's happening is we know we're
getting a document and there are things
that I want to ensure are in the
document and actually have asked for
them so that there's no upset later.
Yes.
>> So, do I hold off on that or ask it now?
>> I mean,
as far as So, there's lots of things
that we're producing as part of this
next deliverable. Yeah. There's
something specific that you want to
share with me. for you can shoot share
share with me now is fine but also I'll
happy to take because we're doing a a
lot to push this out lots of updates
that I've heard from not only the
trustees but also the entire community
>> I I guess so I I'll be brief to and to
be clear because this is responsive to
literally dozens and dozens and dozens
of folks that have asked for some
specific things. Um, one is that when it
comes to the academic framework
addendum, and I really appreciate you
saying there's specificity and there's
generals. There there's things that's
like universal and there's things that's
going to be specific. I would love to
see or my community would love to see
specificity around the academic like
what's going on at Northeast, what's
going on at Crockett. Some of that might
be general, but some of it might be
specific. So, a granularity when it
comes to the academic uh framework. Um
I'll ask again later as we get into it
but around dual language theory of
action why schoolwide why not this that
and the other that that be really
clearly articulated in the uh academic
framework. Um, and then also, I don't
know if this is another section
mirroring some of the work you've
already done, but some sort of from day
one planning to implementation
something that tells us how's the
community going to be involved each step
of the way and how the campus leaders
are going to be involved and how we are
going to be responsive to our emerging
awareness of shifts that are happening
like this many new kids are coming to
this campus. Folks are super hungry for
specificity on
once we've decided how are we going to
ensure that we follow through really
well. So I would love specific attention
to that in the in the next version.
>> Thank you. And Superintendent Sigura, do
you want to give us a deadline for
getting uh deliverable requests to you?
I know we are firing a lot of requests
at you.
>> Trustee said I think I'm not going to go
into it.
>> Yeah, just give us a deadline for new
things.
>> Just do I mean tomorrow by close of
business. I was going to say not all of
them are going to be in the 31st
deliverable, but I can
>> but they'll be there by the sixth.
>> I can well I can review everything see
which ones actually end up becoming a
hold deliverable versus modified
existing deliverable or already in a
deliverable.
So yeah,
>> thank you. Tomorrow by close of
business. So,
>> okay. Thank you.
>> I I think it's also important to
acknowledge there'll be a delay on
transitions, I'm sorry, translations.
Um, we hope to have them translate it by
early next week, but as we get more
feedback, we have to apply it and then
send it to translation. Um, so I do
think it's important for the community
to know that like we are aware that it's
not posted in Spanish, but it will be
posted shortly.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. That's an
important thing for people to know. I
appreciate that. All right, we ready.
And are we good with 15 minutes each?
>> So we can get through all eight
>> 15.
>> Yeah, we'll we'll do what we can. We can
talk fast.
>> All right. So the way we have this
structured in the topics is we are
putting basically what is in the
deliverable already, which I'm assuming
y'all have all read. [snorts] And
there's also just some additional data
from the original rubric that was
released in August. So this is here just
to reference as needed. And we really
just want to kind of remind how we got
to the October 3rd um proposal. Um so
and our first topic is really talking
about Sunset Valley. And so we've pulled
up other schools. If there are other
campus data points y'all want to look at
or maps y'all want to look at, we have
all of that pulled up and can kind of as
yall have questions and discuss, I'm
happy to pull up whatever would be
helpful. Effectively, if we look at
Cunningham, Joslin, ODM, Pleasant Hill,
St. Elmo, and Sunset Valley, they have
space for 3200 students and only 1,900
live in this area. And so what we
proposed in October was that um October
3rd was that two of these are non-zoned
and then one would close being Sunset
Valley. Um ODM and Josyn would be the
non-zone options in this area.
>> And this I'm sorry. So sorry Dr. French,
but I would I really want to save our
time to deliberate.
>> Yep. I'm done.
>> And so that was it.
>> Okay, good.
>> No, this is just a map. That was the
last thing I was going to say.
>> I appreciate it. Thank you.
So what I need to know I think is a
seating question is we've heard from um
different stakeholders uh you know is
there an opportunity why is Sunset
Valley? Why not Jocelyn? That's become
I'm I'm going to be really honest about
what I'm hearing just because I needed
everybody to put it all out there
>> please. Thank you.
>> Uh and you know what I need to
understand what to explore next or what
not to explore. Uh, and you know, there
are different things that can be done in
this area, but we want to communicate
what those things would be if there was
a consensus or a desire to actually move
away from um, Sunset Valley being the
school that was identified for closure
in the program moving to ODM. If that
were the case, ODM students have to be
reassigned, would not be reassigned,
right? They would stay at ODM, which
means that you would have to close
another school in that area, most likely
Pleasant Hill. And so I just I just want
to kind of share out there based on what
it would look like to move in a
different direction so that our trustees
kind of know, hey, we've been looking at
it. This is what it could look like,
what works, what doesn't work. Um
because so I just wanted to kind of
start there like I'm going to be pretty
blunt about what I've what I'm trying to
get shared.
Where would y'all like to start? Go
ahead. I'll jump in and I'm going to say
something that I don't want people to
freak out, but I do but this is based on
like real questions that I have. So, I'm
not trying to derail anything. I'm
really trying to understand. Um, so help
me do that. Okay. So, I'm really curious
to know I I would keep um the Joslyn
building open um but closing the Sunset
Valley building. Um the the Joslyn
building has a facility cost per student
that's about three times that of the
Sunset Valley building and and Sunset
Valley can accommodate more students. So
that is one question that I I have. I
know that's not one of our guiding
principles of like putting kids in
better facilities, but it is kind of
like a no-brainer in my mind of like
that we would want to do that and not
spend as much money on um on on building
costs if we can save it. Um I do have a
real question. I mean I love both
programs very much and I want to know
more in this um financial climate why
we would um we're prioritizing having
two language opt-in programs very close
to each other. um when at the same time
we have dual language programs
throughout the district and what I'm
hearing anecdotally anyway I spoke to
somebody today who told me that they
didn't have a single bilingual certified
teacher in their title one school last
year they just had substitutes so I just
want to make sure that um
we're not creating wall-to-wall programs
at the expense of
programs that are already in
neighborhoods serving kids that are not
fully staffed and not fully resourced.
Um, and I, you know, I would love to see
some data on that, like get a sense of
like where we are fully staffed and
where we're not. And um, so that's one
thing. The other thing is
I know in
um in south southeast Austin there are
schools that are now being um
uh zoned to Mendes which is fine except
Mendes does not have a dual language
program and so you've got kids coming
out of dual language and elementary
there's a gap there for middle school
but then they can go to Travis or Akens
and continue. So, I'm just kind of
curious to know what like the theory of
action is on that. Uh, and so that kind
of dips more into the academic vision,
but it it directly impacts the actual
facilities as well. Um, and you know, I
don't know if there has been thought
around um making it easier for English
native speaker native speakers who want
a dual language experience to identify
and enroll in one of the many dual
language programs throughout the
district. I don't think a lot of people
understand that you can access dual
language at any number of schools. It
doesn't have to be at one of the
wallto-w walls. And so that's really
just like a fundamental question I have
is where is it worth investing in a
wallto-wall? Is it really necessary to
have it to have two language programs in
like so close together in South Austin
and and one of them being in a really um
bad building. Um, and so just help me
understand some of that.
>> Well, so I'm gonna hand it over to vet.
The first thing you said though that I
think is I'm gonna be talking fast is um
the kind of our philosophical approach
to how that we got here, right? The wall
language programs have already been in
place for in some cases many many years.
And so when we started this process, it
was not about kind of changing our
overall approach to dual language. Um,
that conversation I think is more like a
philosophical conversation that I think
Trusty Foster you kind of maybe others
want to talk about. I don't know that we
ever would have had that conversation
unless we got to this point analyzing
like like area by area. And so that's
why it's this way. So we wouldn't I
don't think that we could have ever
gotten to a place, you know, to where we
say, well, we're going to not have
wall-to-wall dual language offerings.
We're just going to go through our use
our traditional models at other 57
schools. make sure they're robust. But
now that this change has occurred, you
know, we can we can talk about it, but
that would be a shift in all
wall-to-wall dual language programs,
right? Um, so when it comes to So I want
to speak, but when it comes to Sunset
Valley, I guess the question becomes
from the board consensus wise, is that
the question that needs to be answered
and addressed because I don't know that
I don't even know how that would what
that would mean. I'd have to really
think through by from all the four what
that would look like if we moved in that
direction without
>> Yeah.
>> Because I just I just want to because I
if I pull that conversation into this
then I can't apply just Sunset Valley.
Every one of them has to be applied to.
>> Yeah. So the reason I I brought it up
for Sunset Valley in particular is
because that doesn't involve a tap
>> and so there's a little bit more
flexibility there. And I think kind of
what what I would think about is, you
know, moving and I'm not saying I'm
advocating for this, but I'm wondering
could we move the Joselyn program into
the Sunset Valley building because that
is a unique program because it offers
the Mandarin as well, which is not
offered in 50 schools. Like, so I can I
understand the need to keep that
somewhere. Um, and then for Sunset
Valley families who would want to have a
dual language op, you know, access, they
could access some of the other wall-to-
walls or some of the other schools that
would have that program. Now, obviously
that's hard because I love Sunset Valley
and that community is very special. But,
um, I'm also worried about prioritizing
a Walaw and we have so many other so
much other need throughout the district
for Spanish in particular.
So thank you for that question. Um when
we looked across so so there's also when
we think about yes the purpose of dual
language programming is primarily it's
bilingual education for emergent
bilingual students. We also have um a
number of families over 1100 students
right that have made a commitment to
programming that are non-emergent
bilingual as well. Um and so when we
also look at locations across the
district, there are many more um dual
language campuses in the north area in
that crescent really the north area than
we do in the south. So in the south
there are not very many options for for
families um who that are not emergent
bilingual that would want to participate
in a dual language program. Um in the
north again there are many more options
um just because there are larger numbers
of emergent bilingual students living in
the north. Um also like your question
about where are we staffed and where are
we not that uh for the most part there
are bilingual exceptions or ESL waiverss
across the district. So it's not
necessarily on at any particular campus.
There is one campus, it's probably the
one that you mentioned earlier, that
does have a very large number of
bilingual exceptions and ESL waiverss.
Um, what I do want to at least say about
that campus is they had had vacancies in
the past, so they're staffed, but they
are working on getting their students
certified as I mean their their teachers
certified as well. So when I look across
all the campuses that have vacancies or
across all the vacancies that have
bilingual exceptions and ESL waiverss,
it's they most of them have at least one
and some have five or or more. Um so
it's varied. I can't say that it's one
particular area of town. I think that
just speaks right to the value of our
teachers and the fact that we really
need certified teachers in our campuses.
And so, um, I think that with this
process as well of going through the
consolidation and really reviewing all
the programs, we're also able to see
where in Austin we have large numbers of
emergent bilingual students and where
maybe the programs are no longer serving
our emergent bilingual students. Um, I
also wanted to talk a little bit about
um, Mendes Middle School. Well, I just I
want to state because men it's gonna
take us I want to talk about
>> Jocelyn programming and sensitive valley
because I just want to kind of keep it
to this region before we can because
we'll we'll talk about
>> I got eight minutes so far. I'm trying
to
>> guess I just want to know like with my
for my colleagues if that's something
that especially Dr. Kaufman um like
because is this a crazy idea? I mean,
you know, and if it is, and if no one is
really like interested, then I'm happy
to to drop it. But I felt like I had to
raise it because Joselyn, that building
is not great, and I want our kids to be
at least, you know, in a better in a
better building. I mean, that that's the
first thing that kind of made me even
think about this. So,
we're spending over we're spending about
over $1,000 more per kid. The building
cost is over $1,000 more per student at
Jocelyn than it is at Sunset Valley.
>> Can I just clarify because I didn't I'd
heard in the question is why Jocelyn and
I'm understanding some of the
geographical stuff but I still don't
understand building wise why Joselyn.
Yeah. So, so what I'll say is this is
one of the areas where you could have
gone kind of both ways. That's the
honest truth. Uh when we look at um kind
of where Sunset Valley is, the number of
transfers that come into that area, its
proximity against Ben White, you know,
neighborhood school versus other
neighborhood schools, like what does it
look like? Uh and the just kind of the
the need to take seats out of the this
geographic area. um that was the school
that um kind of could be supported by
Boon and Cunningham also neighborhood
schools kind of nestled in the
neighborhood and with a number of
transfers it just being against Ben
White kind of made it not as um what's
the word I was looking for it just when
you could because you could have gone
either way it it was really a function
of the transfers versus neighborhood
versus what impact you'd have to do
elsewhere to actually pull the students
out.
But will that current differential in
the cost per student for building will
that continue? Like is that literally
going to be a long-term
cost to us because the in the future the
additional students we place at Jaws
will be at a higher per student rate.
>> Yeah. So we don't have so the cost
differential a lot of times is based on
the number of students you have in the
school, right? And and and the
programming at Joslyn is there's three
languages there. I mean that that's the
way they use the school is very
different than other other way the way
that other schools use their school. And
so when you have the administrative cost
over the number of students, it's going
to increase the ratio. It's going to
increase the number of dollars allocated
per student. You're going to I think
you're going to see that when you have
more complex programming in a school,
you can't blend Mandarin and English and
Spanish. They have to have separate
spaces. And so you have more educators
and the classroom size doesn't quite get
to 22. So So that is I think one of the
drivers. If you move the program, you're
going to see the cost per student rise
at the school that supports the Mandarin
program and kind of the complexity of
running a wallto-wall while you're also
doing immersion, which is something that
I think we've talked about and the
complexity of doing that. I don't know
if you want to speak to that briefly,
real briefly, but [laughter]
>> I'm sorry.
>> I'm sorry. I know I love you, but
>> I know and I'm trying to talk really
fast, which I don't normally do. Um, so
yes, just exactly what what Mr. Sigura
is saying, right? when we've got because
our our district also makes the
commitment to staff by program. That
means that um we are really like it
could take up more classroom space if
you have two programs, right, happening
at the same time because you're staffing
for the Mandarin program and you're
staffing for the Spanish program as
well.
>> I appreciate that. Um I I don't think
like
I still haven't like really heard the
answer answer but but I think you know
the the FCA score is actually you know
much lower. It's much worse for Joselyn
than Sunset Valley. So I want to make
that clear. It's not because of the
number of students. Um and I think um oh
there was something else I was going to
say.
Um, oh yeah,
anecdotally again, I think I've heard
from families who who don't consider
Jocelyn because of the location and and
so I just think that we got to think
about that, too. Would we actually
attract more families into AISD if um it
was at, you know, what some parents may
perceive as a safer location?
So, is it is it to move the immersion
program? Is it
um would the idea So, I'm just trying to
think about how to analyze this. Is it
to move the immersion program to Jaws to
Sunset Valley? I I'm not sure we can run
both the immersion and the full wall to-
wall in the same way that that that's
one of the things that's the complexity
of this. You just couldn't move combine
them.
Go ahead.
>> I think what we heard at the Sunset
Valley meeting the other day was we can
move Sunset Valley schoolwide dual
language to another campus, but why not
then use the vacated Sunset Valley
campus to relocate the Jawsen
programming so that it's serving both
purposes. That's what I heard as a
proposal from the community. I might
have misheard
>> disrupt
three communities opposed to because now
it's ODM and Sunset Valley. ODM would
still change because they'd be
reassigned. Sunset Valley would go to
ODM and then JSON would go to Sunset
Valley. So that that would be the third
Dru I I mean
>> that's the prop that's proposal I heard.
>> You could you could do that or you could
not Yes, you could do that. You can move
Joselyn the Joselyn program into Sunset
Valley and Sunset Valley into ODM or you
could um put or you could put Joselyn
the Joselyn program into Sunset Valley
and then we've already reszoned the
Sunset Valley students
that you know would be zoned there.
There's not a whole lot of them and then
work with those families to put them to
find other dual language programs. I
know it's asking a lot and I'm not and
again I'm not necessarily advocating for
this. I just want it to be thought
through, but I I don't want to take up
too much time um with this, but I just
just raising that.
>> Uh so I just want to make sure trustees
seem um
you're would the idea the strategy that
we would could potentially look at
assuming that there's a lot enough to
look at it was to not ex not have a
wall-to-wall program at Sunset Valley,
>> right? because you have dual language
offerings elsewhere, right?
>> That's what that's and then receive the
immersion program from Joselyn,
>> right? Um and then JSON would be the
campus that would close.
>> Correct.
>> My main my main issue is Joselyn really
and put keeping students in a building
that's that's not great. That's my main
issue. But we can
>> Okay. Thank you. One other clarification
was the idea that ODM would then no
longer be a nonzone school or that's as
you said Josyn was maybe
>> that's really beyond [snorts] my like I
mean I originally kind of was thinking
about that because of like the the gaps
in in bilingual
education implementation throughout the
district. And I think that's even a
bigger conversation. I would defer to
Dr. Hoffman to to kind of be the trustee
who who could make recommendations on
that one on that piece of it or anyone
or
>> Avette.
Okay. So,
are we anybody else would like to share?
I I I haven't heard like a con consensus
to kind of shift.
>> I guess again I want to think about how
we're managing our time. Are we going to
go with a hard cut off to zoom through
15 or are we because
>> I've been told that we can go till
[clears throat] 9. I'm going to I'm
going to start setting a 15-minute timer
or we're at about 18 minutes on this.
>> Establish the 15 minutes. I just kind of
want to know are we going to cut
ourselves off or are we going to do what
we do which is continue the
conversations until we're done.
>> I just want to get a sense if anybody
else thinks that we should move Joselyn
program over to um you know if we should
close the building of Joslyn instead of
the building the Sunset Valley building.
That's that's pretty much what I think
would be helpful for the staff.
>> That's what we need to hear. That would
be helpful.
>> That's the question.
>> I am absolutely committed to having our
kids in safe schools. I'm also committed
into properly communicating the reality
of our schools so we don't have
misconceptions about safety. I find it
hard to believe that our students at
Joslin are in mortal danger every day
they go to school. When the times I've
been there, it's been a robust, lively,
wonderful place to be. And I've been
there many times. And so when we hear
the concerns raised about it, I think
those concerns are very real. But I
wonder whether the conditions that
people are concerned about are accurate.
And so I guess I would just want to
leave it in the hands of our
administration. I trust that everyone
who's running our schools and serving
our district wants our kids to be safe
and healthy. So I would just I would,
you know, I would say make sure our kids
are in a healthy safe school.
>> And I would leave it at that.
>> So
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. I mean, that's that's helpful. I
appreciate that. Um,
>> you're going to bring a recommendation
to us. I don't have any concerns about
the current recommendation. Trusty Singh
obviously does. Um, so whatever you guys
work out and for me, whatever is in that
recommendation is what I'll make my
decision based on.
I agree with the the points that Trusty
Kaufman has raised. I also would say
that um I did not have issues with the
initial recommendation and I've received
a lot of feedback from Jocelyn families
because that's a campus that I represent
about how they feel about the
recommendation. It seems to be with some
of the minor adjustments that you
mentioned at the start of the meeting
that they're acceptable. I would be
concerned about a pivot at this point
and proper engagement with the Josson
community because they're operating with
same as Sunset Valley has a certain
expectation of what's been proposed so
far. Um there was something else that I
was going to say and it left me. That's
the end.
>> I'm not going to die on this hill.
>> So
all right.
>> Okay. And I would say Trusty Gonzalez's
opinion carries a lot of weight with me.
He's closest to the issue.
>> Thank you. Thank you all.
>> All right, another
>> Okay, so we have a few different slides
of data for this one because there's
lots of moving parts. This was one
proposal from October 3rd that solved a
lot of different things through one move
and that's what we've talked about a lot
in this is how everything's connected.
So we had heard from the community um
that we want to maintain Monasuri, but
they also have a three unacceptable
ratings and a tap. So, we needed to move
them or do something as part of their
accountability requirements. Um, we also
have more seats in northwest northeast
Austin as well as in East Austin. Um,
and so there's data here on when and its
surrounding campuses which fed into
those decisions. And then the next page
has data on where we proposed to
relocate that monastery program to Go
Valley. Um, part of this move also
allowed us to move it to a part of town
that has twice as many seats as there
are students. So it was an opportunity
to keep a school operating as a school
because we just don't need as many
neighborhood schools in these parts of
Austin. Um the third slide just has a
map um showing the current location of
Win Monasuri as well as kind of the
revised boundaries um and the location
of Go Valley. Um, and again, as we've
mentioned previously in the board
workshop, we did kind of look at East
Austin as a group because we knew
between Sanchez, Zavala and Go Valley,
we really just needed one neighborhood
school and so that was why Zavala
because the remaining students that live
in that area live close to Zavala. Um,
that was initially selected. There's
other data points you have that we can
discuss and look at. Um, so and I
leaving it to y'all.
>> I have a question. You've mentioned um
the community wants Monttoauri.
So we're displacing a community, an
entire neighborhood school for a
boutique program. So I guess my question
is
in this
how sure
because when has a a waiting list of 200
or whatever in the location that it is
now do all those people want in to
Montasauri have we like checked that out
because displacing an entire community
for this program and then people don't
show up
even if they do show up displacing a
community for a boutique program I
really struggle with and I love Monasuri
I did Monasuri International House
children. Weird name, but a great place
off of Far West. Love sending my kid
there. Um, but I'm just really concerned
with the our the pressure that we are up
against with TEA cuz I'm going to be
honest and I don't mean any disrespect.
Y'all do a good job. Like Bridget worked
her butt off and everything she did, she
did on her own because we are not set up
to support Monasuri. We're not doing it
well, right? And so I mean no half
measures. This is supposed to be getting
it right. So whatever you put again in
the plan, what the administration
decides is what I'll base my decision
on. But I am just telling you now, I
have a lot of concerns about are we
fixing a problem, creating more problem?
Like will there be a domino? So that's
all I'm going to say on that piece.
Um, yeah, I'd like to just echo those
thoughts on I just don't I haven't seen
clearly how the monastery can perform
well in a high stakes testing
environment in the state of Texas like
it. Um, I also worry about uh displacing
our go our go valley families. Um, you
know, when they fought to have a
modernized building and then now, you
know, potentially could not be able to
go to the school that they fought so
hard to be in. Um,
so yeah, those are my concerns.
>> Yeah. So just briefly um when we started
this process uh what I heard from the
conversations we had with various
trustees and with in the community was
that there was a desire to have
programming that was desirable right and
there was evidence that it was
desirable. I agree with Trusty Hunter
that we as an organization haven't been
figured out how to support one of 116
right which is kind of what is happening
here. uh and so we have to um do a
couple things to to support the program
if we continue on. At the time we
started this process I had not heard
that there was ever a desire to move
away from Monasuri. I'd heard the
opposite in fact that we wanted more
monasteries in Austin ISD that there's a
desire to have that programming in
Austin ISD. Obviously I don't want to
expand something until we actually get
it right. Uh so in an effort to um
address the the weight of the t the
turnaround plans, position this the
program to be supported differently in
the district, we needed to relocate it
um and kind of rethink how we as an
administration support Monastery. And
with the added um idea of not wanting to
overburden closures in any one part of
Austin, the solution was to move an a
unzoneed school to uh East Austin
because you have a surplus of seats.
Originally we had considered Zavala. We
had considered other schools uh and it
really was was really a conversation
around was Zavala had been historic an
historic school. Um you know should it
be Go Valley? I've heard now from
community and I understand that like we
this school was built for that community
and now we're displacing that community.
That's not necessarily what we would
like to do, but I need to communicate
that if we do not move a program there,
then you're we're going to be faced with
the reality that you're going to have
lots of underenrolled schools in this
area which may lead to a closure without
the program. So that's that's where the
tension between these two things come.
And so I'm really looking for our
trustees to share with us any ideas
because we could move it to Zavala. We
could move it to Ortega. That could
work. Keeping it in the area, which is
something I've heard from different um
folks. There aren't lots of schools that
are available that don't have taps
themselves. So that that's not
necessarily going to be an option. I
heard Pan Springs that Pan Springs has a
tap. Sorry, I'll stop.
>> Sorry. I just have a quick question. Is
it possible at in a school in an
underenrolled area to have two programs
on one campus?
>> So, we tal Dr. Moxwell and I have talked
about this. Um I I'll certainly let her
speak, but
it it's kind of become if you're going
to do it, do it all the way through. Um
splitting it up either by grade level or
by strand um kind of creates a really
complex system within a school. I don't
know, Dr. Maxwell because that that's
really the guidance that we've been
working off.
>> Yeah. So, um just and we've had this
conversation around I think in a few
areas, but two programs within one
school does does present some pretty
significant challenges to uh leading
those programs and really set setting
them up for success. So we've seen some
um challenges with Montasauri even when
everyone in the school uh all the
teachers community included all the
students um begin to support and
understand and learn how to uh use that
program and um become more successful
with it. Uh having that on top of a
traditional program I think does
definitely pose some challenges. I think
they're um
even if I mean having two two strands of
it would I I think would be almost
impossible if you had say I think we've
had some um
questions around whether or not we could
do monosuri at the early levels and then
more traditional at the upper grade
levels that becomes a little bit of a
question on um how early and how long
the monasuri program lasts. I think
we've spent an entire year um talking a
lot about foundational and how important
it is and what we're doing in K2 both in
literacy and in math. Um that is where
some significant it's not just the
tested grade levels that it's a
challenge at Monasuri. It's it's the
foundational levels as well. Uh they
have um first, second, and third grade I
know that could probably look a little
bit different but they have first,
second, and third grade in the classroom
together. what first graders are
learning for foundational skills is
significantly different than what third
graders are learning for foundational
skills. You know, you simple phonics and
then actual um more difficult word
analysis in third grade is a good
example. And so h doing that within the
same classroom um has has some some some
real challenges for teachers uh and and
being able to um perform at the rigor
and the level of the standards if it
were younger if it were just second
grade right before that. Um I think also
we we have some challenges with first
and second grade not getting some of the
same foundational skills in Monasuri
that we we do see in structured literacy
um and in our numeracy program. What
monastery does right now is they work
very hard to they're they're working
harder on their systems to integrate
those into the early classrooms so that
they are set up for success as they get
older and older. Um again with two or
three grade levels in the classroom, it
poses challenges to make sure that every
single student is um at the level that
they should be. They they have pretty
significantly high numbers for our um
early literacy and our early numeracy
screeners that qualify or that first
indicator for interventions. So um now
you're talking about um monasuri
multiple grade levels foundational
skills that are that are uh difficult
and need to be taught explicitly and
systematically all the way through
second grade in the early levels and on
top of that high numbers of students who
are qualifying for interventions. So
it's not it's it it becomes difficult to
solve that in in tier one when you've
got three different grade level
standards to teach or two.
>> Thank you.
I do want to this is our opportunity to
reset Monastery. So to trustee Hunter's
point of not serving it well,
I think we probably should have been a
little more thoughtful at the inception
of the program because some of us are
now like tried to play catch-up on like
like how can we fix um past mistakes. I
do think we need to consider mobility.
If you're a student and you're in, you
pop into Monastery, you stay a couple
years and then you go back to a
traditional school or you come late. I
think my like my thoughts like we
shouldn't place it somewhere where we
have students that are going to be
highly mobile unless we have a plan to
support that. Um because as Dr. Maxwell
said like they're getting multiple
standards at the same time. Um, in a
traditional classroom, you know what the
first graders are supposed to master by
a certain date. Monosuri is a little
more self-paced. So, again, you can
leave when and go to Panon Springs and
[snorts] you may miss something, right?
Because we we can't keep the alignment
that we need for highly mobile kids.
>> Um, yeah, I'd like I'd like to speak to
it. Um, I would say one of my concerns
with Monasuri
um like like moving or or going away or
is that we have such a long wait list
for Monasuri because the standards are
developmentally appropriate and they are
higher for kids and so there is a big
concern about standardization um coming
down in the state and in this district.
Um, so I would say my concern is us
actually like leaning out of that. And I
think it's a problem that our students
can't go from place to place and get
developmentally appropriate experiences.
Um, having multiple grades in the
classroom allows um a teacher to work
with students who are having emerging
phonics skills. Um, Monasuri is very
very explicit in teaching numeracy um
and hands-on ways in teaching um phonics
and words um very very specifically and
it also gives students who are advanced
the ability to to go on and be and be
more advanced. So I I I do have a lot of
concerns with um just kind of like
picking up and moving it. Um, so this
this is one of these the 2023 like
sabotage schools that were sabotaged by
the the Texas accountability labels. Um,
so this isn't the fault of of Monastery.
This is the fault of our state. Um,
and you know, again, we have families
that are showing they they want a
diverse school um, and that they they
want these type of experiences. And
that's why there's a wait list because
they're concerned they're not going to
get it other places. And you know, and I
I send like, you know, my my peers are
people who are sending their kids to
school and making these decisions right
now. And I always say, go and visit a
school. And I know that Miss Far has
coffees every Friday. You can go visit
that school every single Friday. Um, I
was thinking about sending my son there,
which, you know, I don't want to have
two drop offs across town, but she's
like, he's three, you know, you know, in
January there's a like I would love that
school. Um, I sing their praises. I tell
everyone, um, you I tell everyone to
check out their school. And we have
schools that are on this list staying
open where I say, "Go check out your
school." And they're my friends are
told, "Oh, we don't do tours at the
school."
So, I need principles to be like Missfar
and take some responsibility of
recruiting people and making them feel
welcome. And
um you it's just it's just really sad to
me that so many of these programs that
have these strong leaders who have who
have gotten buy in from their
communities are like are are on the
chopping block right now. It just it
makes me really sad.
Um, so then what I'm hearing is if we
don't put a nonzone program in this part
of town, we'd have to close more schools
in this part of town.
>> Yes. That that that will Yes. That
that's one of the reasons that we did it
this way. If you're going to move move
to a place to keep the school open, a
school open. Have we considered other
programs aside from dual language and
monaster
>> um as far as movement into this part of
Austin
>> for nonzone?
>> Well the the I mean the wall to wall do
language program moving to Sanchez. So
Sanchez Zavala Go Valley Ortega they're
kind of all in this strand just north of
the river. Um that would be the other
one. Um, I wouldn't want to introduce a
program that we don't have already
successfully thriving in Austin ISD.
Launching something at this point to me
is very risky. Um, and as Trusty Willie
Chu said, there's something already very
desirable. I think it's an opportunity
to reset, do it well. I think the
question becomes, you know, is it Go
Valley or is it a different school? I
think that's the the the question
because what I keep hearing and what I
and I agree is that you built a school
for the community and now you're
potentially going to displace those
students. Um the reason it was chosen
this way, not the other way is because
Zavala is a historic neighborhood
school. So there's there's there's a lot
that kind of there's no school that's
going to be, you know, it's just hard.
Um but that's why the offset was
trade-off was there
>> and we're at 15. Not that I'm trying to
cut the conversation off, just time
check. Thank you.
So this one is um exceptionally
challenging uh for me uh from both
angles and I'm calling both angles our
monastery model and um you know a
historically rooted
multigenerational
community that is saying wow this is
going to happen to me again. Um I so
I've challenges on that side of the
equation you know
but I'll just focus on the monasteri
piece uh for a minute um so I had asked
a couple weeks ago um about the
viability of Montasauri in the context
of the state of Texas accountability
system and as uh trusty Whitley Chu
pointed out you know there's a great
extent to which the labels that are
being given have not to do with the
beauty and power and effectiveness of
what's going on in the building but
rather
failure of articulation. Um
on
so many features of our accountability
system just don't mesh. Um Mr. Drinks,
you talked about a reset.
um
you wonderfully and beautifully and
troublingly complicate, you know, showed
us like walked us through just how
complicated all of this is before we
talk about student mobility. There's so
much I guess the the mut nuts and bolts
question is well what's the answer to my
question? Is it viable? And if it's
viable, like I haven't heard anything
to indicate to me that Montasauri is
viable within this framework. Now I know
there's some places across the state
that seem to be doing it, but as
attested to far and wide, you have a
really strong principle. You have really
committed families. You have a lot going
on. Well, I don't know what the student
mobility rate is, but that's a big I'm
sure that's a big part of the the the
the equation. Is this viable? Is
Monasury viable, especially
schoolwide up and down the line?
So in an effort to support principal far
a couple of years ago, we had a
conversation and I said if we can find a
school in Texas that
is zoned, it meets accountability
and all of the things we will go like we
will find it. We will go we will see
what they're doing and we couldn't find
one. Um most of the monasteries that we
found in large urbans are magnet or they
are applicationbased.
So we were unable to find like a zoned
monastery in an urban district that
served the demographics that when
served. Again that was a conversation we
had about a year and a half ago. So
maybe there's been some evolution, but
at that point and again the disclaimer
was that they're meeting accountability,
right? And so it kind of goes back to
your point, Trusty Foster. It's we have
not found the sweet spot of navigating
that and it looks like our peers across
the state may not have either because we
can't find one. Again, maybe we
overlooked it, but we also had I also
had CDA because they they track
districts across the state. Um, we sat
with Carolyn before she left and we just
looked up again monasteries and large
urbans again that are zoned.
Have just real quick, have you
considered have you reviewed the list
that Nikki Schubet sent with urban
districts with 80 80 plus% poverty with
A and B ratings? Have you seen her list?
Does that include that you looked at
those schools? We have and and I know
again like I looked but I asked
principal far and I know that she goes
in and she turns over every stone and
the last response she gave to me was
that she she couldn't find one. But at
the end of the day like if we can find
one we are open to the successful model
that they're using. Um but at the time
that I had the conversation with her we
couldn't. And just to clarify, that was
part of the reason why we're proposing
it being nonzoned if it were to maintain
because that is one of the common
denominators of it working in other
districts.
>> All right. So
>> I mean this is important. I mean
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Um
All right. So there's a part of this
that I'm going to try to say carefully
lest it come off differently than I
intend.
um in the example
of the magnet
ones that are successful. So we can say
non-zone, we can say magnet.
Is it the case
that the resourcing of the kids and
families is significantly different?
In other words, that the monastery model
which is a beautiful model um also
in the experience statewide depends upon
a level of stability, food security,
housing security. um just less
challenges and then on top of the less
challenges greater supports because a
family has a capacity to sort of pitch
in and contribute this way or that way.
I'm wondering if there is not a
socioeconomic dimension to the
successful Montasauris.
>> Okay. Uh I have the I have the list
here. So we have um Dallas ISD IDB Wells
Monastery 65%
economically disadvantaged has an A. Um
Buckner Terrace Monastery Dallas ISD 86%
economically disadvantaged has a B. Um
thank you Nikki for this list. Um
Monasuri Academy Dallas ISD 76%
economically disadvantaged has a B.
Um,
>> so what what would you say is go because
you've looked at these schools. So what
would you say?
>> What we did is we took the list like
Trusty Whitley Chu is reading from and
then we dug into the school's website to
see how to go to the school like how if
I want to go to the school like do I
just enroll and most of them took us to
an application and we did this not too
long ago probably right before uh
Carolyn left. and we look there's one in
Aldine, there's one in I think Alieaf
just started one and everyone took us to
an application. Um again it's possible
that we missed one but I would say the a
significant number it is somehow tied to
an application
so that that which is in itself in
itself expression of a form of capital
in terms of capacity for engagement
navigating application etc etc. Although
it's really useful and interesting
information that we have examples of the
low eco disc in a critical mass and
success
>> and then what low eco like what schools
with extremely high amounts of numbers
of students who are economically
disadvantaged are doing well in Austin
ISD that aren't monastery
>> right and when I go to Austin ISD enroll
page it says start application when we
go to Austin it says we have to do an
application to go to any Austin school.
So, I think that that analysis would
have to be a little deeper into
understanding what their policies are.
>> It wasn't the district application. Some
of them were like the TEA charter school
application. So, again, it wasn't um
like Aleaf's wasn't like I just want to
enroll my child at a leaf. When you
clicked on the link for their monastery,
it was again like they used the template
that tea provided for charter
applications.
So I'm I'm hearing a back and forth on
this which is a very interesting and
informative back and forth. Um and then
another layer for me is the number of
plans we are trying to execute and
execute well. Um and I guess where I'm
falling is that there's an extent to
which we need to reduce complexity
and
This is our one the monastery
and it requires
different from central different types
of support. Um all things that probably
are things that every school should get
anyway by the way and yet we have so
many constraints on us. Um,
I'm still in the place, and this is, you
know, I guess in a sense why I'm here
and also why we're not always popular.
I'm I'm just not seeing it. I'm not
seeing
uh that this is a good way for us to go.
I'm giving the that it it is not a
substantial reduction of risk. It does
require it does require a great deal of
us. It's incredibly complex and we
haven't gotten it right yet. Um, so I
don't I don't know where the
conversation goes from there.
>> Yeah,
>> we're at 25 minutes. I'd love to just um
I wonder to what degree I really like
the idea of trying to be the district
that does get really developmentally
appropriate, ambitious education, right?
Um, you know, I give the example of
Travis Heights Elementary, which is a
real cross-section of our district and
leads hard into project-based learning.
Even though they have to do a really
heavy lift to make it work, and they
have some of the strongest scores for
some of our highest need students of any
campus, they do extremely well. And I
want to be this district that tries to
get that right. Um, I hate the idea of
displacing a neighborhood school. It
also is notable to me that you say
something would be recommended for
closure in that area. I think those are
things that um we need to kind of
reconcile, you know, the what and the
where. Um
and wonder if there might be a different
location. I'd love to kind of explore
that or at least talk with Go Valley
families and find out what they might be
looking for. And then I think the next
question I have is is it the dual
language monastery together that may be
adding those extra challenges because we
are also not doing an extremely good job
at many of our dual language campuses.
um you know seeing that we have 50 what
seven um of serving our students well
either because partly because we have
that concentrated economic need um and
yes there are shining examples but on
balance we know that it's a bigger hill
to climb because of what kids bring to
with them and and we know that we're not
doing the wraparound service as well. We
know that there's high mobility, that
there are so many other factors that we
know get in the way of students
performing in the system that we have.
>> Yeah, we entertained not um having dual
language, but um some of us have a
philosophical issue with offering a
program in this district and restricting
our bilingual emerging bilingual
students from participating because we
don't have dual language. So basically
we put families in a position to either
opt for monastery or opt for dual
language if we if we don't offer that.
Um it was definitely a point of
discussion.
>> I will say some of the proposals that
we've worked on with principal far
included like when it's non-zone you
have more control about making sure your
ratio in dual language is aligned. You
have better predictability of the number
of sections and teachers you need to
support dual language. Whereas now since
it's a neighborhood school, anyone who
qualifies full dual language that lives
in that zone has to receive those
services. So it makes it very difficult
to plan yeartoear. So that is something
we have discussed. Um I will also want
to note that there's a bullet on the
slide like um more than half of the
school is currently dual language. So,
if we weren't to offer it at least
temporarily, it would be effectively
needing to restart the program because
we wouldn't be able to continue with
those teachers and so I have a question.
We're almost at 30 minutes. Do you want
email feedback from us going forward?
What is helpful to you?
>> I I don't I mean, so
email doesn't help me drive towards
consensus and getting a recommendation
that'll be
>> so so that that's the I think the
challenge that I have. One of the things
I will say is we started this process
because we knew that Monasuri was an
offering in the school district that we
believed in. At least that was my
understanding when we started this. It I
agree that it hasn't been done well. I'm
not going to participate in something
that isn't done well which I think
Lisha's point a reset is appropriate and
we are committed to doing it and that's
what's in the plan. What I wanted to
move towards is this this tension
between displacing a a student
population who was selected as a
receiving community for a new school.
Right? So if we could if the first
elements of this are you know reasonably
accepted then the question becomes
would the would we be willing to accept
an alternative placement of the program
so that the new facility the modernized
facility isn't the one that's displacing
being the receiving campus given the
location it would either be Ortega or
Zavala um you know unless you go
completely in the area because what
again in the area we have too many seats
>> so that's why that kind of ends up being
the zone. So that's really what I want
to emails are great but it's not going
to I think drive to getting a
>> that's a helpful question. Thank you. So
trusty deoste and then Kintana.
>> So I I wanted to take opportunity I was
I'm glad this has come up highlighting
you know for this kind of entire
endeavor part of the thing that has been
a focus for me is the overall process
and and you know the theory of action
that we're approaching this with. And so
one I want to call out is that you know
every time we start talking about a
different school for these moves you
know anybody that's paying attention on
TV all of a sudden now it's a different
school but also I want to highlight for
the people that are watching that this
is the conversation this is what happens
when people are you know what about this
other school what about this change like
these are the discussions that happen so
I just want to call that out and name it
and in this community in particular
highlighting the effect that that has on
the larger community. So, as you're
saying, you know, this is a new
building. There's attachment there, but
also these other schools, uh, have
historical connections, too. Um, you
know, uh, Trusty Foster and I were just
recently, um, recently there and, you
know, the Go Valley families were
talking about how much it's been to, you
know, kind of rebuild the community
there. people transferring in and so you
know there's a dynamic tension there
between you know this was the community
school this was the rebuilt school like
that entire um piece of conversation and
so I think in approaching this as much
as we were just talking about all the
monastery part you know to me there has
been a conversation ongoing about
specialized programming and and you know
what that means to the district um you
know I appreciate the idea that if
something's not working we're not going
to you know continue to to I I'm trying
to think something that's not
inflammatory to say we're not going to
keep doing something that's not working.
Um, which doesn't sound like that's 100%
the conversation here. There's still,
you know, a chance to reset it and do
all that. So then I flip to the other
side of that conversation and with the
move that that we're contemplating to do
that and, you know, how does that affect
the community? A lot of these feedbacks,
you know, the rest that we're going to
go over, you know, again, gets into
these community decisions of now I have
to cross this street that I didn't want
to cross or, you know, the
transportation for my kids, they can't
bike, you know, all these pieces. So,
this move in particular, um, how that is
received by the community. And so I
think the idea of putting the students
in good schools, um the fact that we've
just, you know, remodeled that, we've
done all this work, uh it kind of speaks
to what was what was the procedural
intent here. And so for me, that makes
it something not just about Go Valley,
but the approach that we're using. You
are we giving students something and
then moving them to another place. Um, I
understand that's that's a lot of the
moves that we're making and and deciding
on those facilities. And so, um, I think
maybe to to again make this apply
everywhere is what are the other moves
that are also going on in this general
community, if that makes sense. Like how
many trades are we doing that, you know,
they've lost this building, what what
else are they gaining in in the overall
community? Um because that was that was
the piece I'm I'm concerned about is the
idea of moving a specialized program
into the east side into you know one of
the newer buildings right there and then
you know displacing some of those
students for you know a program that
it's not necessarily those families
looking for the monastery school. I
understand the monastery school needs a
home. I understand it offers the chance
for the reset. Um, and so I'm, you know,
that that's kind of my concern is is how
the community receives that, but then
the minute that you say, "Oh, maybe
Zavala instead," you know, then Zavala
families are are the ones that are
emailing us next. And so I think that is
kind of the community conversation.
>> Yeah. So I I know Tristan has a has a a
com what I would say is
you know
I I look in the up there you see Ortega
and Zavalo right as kind of the two
alternatives to for consideration given
the region and what we're trying to do
and not close more East Austin schools.
Um when I look at both Ortega and
Zavala, Zavala its historic nature and
the building itself is it's kind of set
right there isn't the opportunity to do
what we did at Go Valley which is a
complete modernization right now. You
probably do have that opportunity Ortega
at some point in the future. So the the
question becomes you know with those two
things being said assuming that or I
want monator is going to continue is
there an an an appetite or maybe a
consideration for us to do the work and
propose a different solution because I I
want to be responsive to what we're
hearing from the community and Tristan
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
>> Can you say that last part again? So um
so right now one of the things that
we're because Go Valley was modernized
in 2017 by way of the 2017 bond program
uh and we don't want to displace we
hearing not to displace community who
that school was designed for and vision
to support. Um if you look at the
alternative site locations in the area
that still remove the number of seats
then you have Zavala to the west and you
have Ortega to the east. given those two
schools if you think about future
investment one of them would would
support a full modernization the other
would not um and and as so Zavala its
historic nature the fact that it's
confined like adjacent to the
Pan-American center uh it it it's not
essentially what you would see as a
complete you know modernized facility so
long term you know if I if you were to
look at each one of those I would take
that into consideration as well does
that make sense
like Zavala
um you know it's a historic building
like you there's not we're not ever
really going to have the opportunity to
to completely modernize it you could
have [clears throat] that opportunity
with Ortega and a future investment so
should that weigh into the future
placement of a monastery program if so I
would potentially place them in a
location where the building is fixed the
location is is not likely going to have
to ever be torn down and rebuilt And if
you were to do that and go completely
modernized, it would be for a modernized
neighborhood school. Does that make
sense? Like that I'm just trying to like
project out again future investment,
future bond, future things, but I I want
to limit moves downstream. So I just
wanted to offer that. I think that would
something else to consider.
>> Yes.
[laughter]
I don't know. I'm not sure I'm quite
following. So, so we would want to move
the program to
um to Pon Springs.
I'm sorry, not to
>> Pon Springs or Ortega
>> or Artega
because there is room there to modernize
the facility.
uh if a full modernization like what Go
Valley experienced is not going to be
available at Zavala in the same way it
was at Go Valley because of the historic
nature of that building.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> But you could do that at Ortega.
>> So if you're going to rebuild a
modernized facility, you might have that
be for a neighborhood school, meaning
that you would pick Savala because it's
unlikely to be able to support a full
modernization.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm I'm just trying to kind
of forecast and and kind of share what
is likely to happen in future future
years. Um to limit whatever.
>> Yeah, I appreciate that. Um
yeah, I guess I would like to see
something that puts I guess the
monastery at Savala.
Um, I don't
I can't think that far in the future
with bonds and modernizations,
especially because we don't know what
our enrollment numbers are going to look
like to even support
um doing that. I mean, Lord, I knock on
wood, God forbid that we're back here
having this consolidation conversation
in the next five years. Um,
so yeah, I think I think I'd like to see
um, you know, how it could work at
Zavala and um, just how we can,
you know, make sure that we're not
displacing the the Zavala community that
um cuz because it kind of feels like
we're just moving it like we're just
moving it from not displacing one
community to displacing in another
community. And so, um, I'm not sure, you
know, what that would look like. I know
we talked about buses,
um, and things like that, but, um,
yeah. So then if families didn't want to
go to Monasuri at Zala, they would go to
Go Valley.
the neighborhood.
>> So the map you see on the screen would
effectively not change that gray area
that is currently zoned to Zavala. Those
same students would instead their
neighborhood school could be Go Valley
and Zavala is the nonzed monastery.
>> So this boundary wouldn't change.
>> Yes. The boundary can remain the same.
It's just which school is serving which
program.
>> Okay.
>> Good.
>> Okay. Trusty Singh for 40 minutes.
>> Okay. So,
um I'm kind of
what what uh Trusty Foster was saying
does resonate with me. So, I appreciate
um the conversation.
Um I think if I if if we have to keep a
Mont a wall-to-wall [snorts] Monttoauri
in the district
um
then I would not want to do it at Go
Valley. Like that's probably like my
biggest thing out of all of this is like
Go Valley has 36% of its students are
special education.
They have they don't have a tap. I think
>> they don't have a three. They have a two
They have a 2 UA tap.
>> Oh, two UA TP, but they're not at three.
They have a 59.
>> I think they're going to get over that
hump. I agree. I don't want to mess with
a school that's doing okay. I just I'll
be honest. It's a brand new school,
great community.
>> It's not underenrolled. Um it's
there's a lot more sped students there
than we see like that it's above the the
district average for sped students and I
know like they've just put so much into
getting that up that support there. I
really am worried about messing with
that. So then the question is do we even
do a a wall to Montasauri? And I I'm
going to have to lean into what my
colleague um Trusty Foster said is I'm I
love it. My own kids did Montasauri so I
get it. They weren't at that the strange
name one that you had but [laughter]
>> children but but they did
>> so mine went to Maraposa Montasaur but
um it was an amazing experience. I think
it would be great if we thought about
that as a prek program um throughout the
district. I would love to see it for for
itty bitties. Um and I don't even know
like I I don't want to displace Savala
either. Like I think I think there's a
way that we could think about you draw
using as a draw for enrollment as a
pre-k program um without having to
displace anybody. That that's kind of
where I am with it. But um but Go Valley
I I really hope that we we would just
leave that school um as it is.
>> Okay. Do we want to do a round?
>> Trusty Foster. No. Okay. Trusty Foster
thoughts. Um [laughter]
there's there's elephants
[clears throat] in the room on this one
on the side of the equation that I
didn't talk about that I think other
people are lifting up. Um that that
elephant is handled by not putting the
nonzoneed into this beautiful new
facility. Um so I'm there on that one at
the not at Go Valley.
>> Agree. Um
then the other thing I have to
acknowledge or not have to acknowledge
but the other side of it is this is
effectively
free from being in tip tap territory. Um
because it's going to be in a new it
would be in a new space and it would be
a fresh start. So, it's like if it got
an F, if it got an F, like
we've kicked the can effectively. Um,
>> yeah, I would I would say
>> we're going to share our
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. No, and I realize and I I I really
need to be careful with my words so that
I am not offensive.
I it is not my disbelief in Monasuri and
it's not my disbelief in our [snorts]
kids nor in our teachers or our program
rather the incompatibility with the
state system. I just I just [cough] it's
really really difficult for me to get
there. I question and I would have to go
to the schools. I question
agnostically
whether other places are doing it with
fidelity. like I I just I just can't I I
I it's it's such a leap for me. It's
such a leap. Um that having been said,
now we're going back to forjon era
stuff.
This is so tough to talk about, but it
is a reality about the retention of
folks in the district through
programming that they love. And the
history of our nation's public education
for the last since civil rights forward
is that one way that urbans retain folks
is through specialized programming. And
then that's really cool, but the
specialized programming invariably
ends up trending towards inequity. It we
don't have the national models or
instances where it doesn't. So there's
like just so many pitfalls, so many
dangers. That having been said, um I
think there's a compromise space that
for me I can live with that it's not in
Go Valley.
um that that option is available to
parents who want it, that we do what
that community's already been doing with
enrollment guidelines
um and enrollment like expectations in
terms of balance and that we actually
fund that which is a hard piece that you
fund it. You're not going to keep
maintain the equity without
transportation for those who need it. So
basically I guess where I would be
seating territory is giving in to
complexity when I think we need to
simplify.
But I can at the end of the day be okay
with us taking this risk
um because we do have a substantial
community that wants it and we won't be
harming Go Valley if we don't do it
there. And so I can kind of live with
this.
I don't believe yet in the accountabil
the the articulation of the models, but
how awesome would it be if I would prove
it wrong? Like [clears throat] I would
three years from now be just jumping for
joy that to Trusty Whitley Chu's point,
we found a way to do this beautiful
thing well even given the state's
constraints. So I guess that's the
middle ground that I can find even if it
took 45 minutes.
>> It's okay,
>> Madam President.
>> Um, we good. Do you have what you need?
Anyone else? I'm there.
>> I just want to add quickly. Please do
not place a program in East Austin that
does not have a bilingual program.
>> Yes. Thank you. With you.
>> Okay. Um, moving on. We're going to
extend our meeting a little bit. Um,
let's try to really keep it to 15
minutes if we can.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Um, thank you.
>> And I know that's this is I just want to
say this is um
>> not the way to go about this. And I
really want to speak just speak take a
couple of our precious minutes to speak
up about um the system we are expected
to operate under and that it is not a
system that makes room for something
that we're having to navigate with a c a
funding crisis an accountability system
that changed um rapidly a few years ago
and the economic need that we have and
the need to serve our students well um
doesn't acknowledge the good work that
the administration is doing and the
progress that's being shown and and
we're in uh a situation that is very
difficult to we should be able to talk
about this as long as we need to and I'm
sorry that we're having to manage our
time this way because this all deserves
this and so much more. Thank you.
>> And our community members have one
minute to make comments on these very
important issues that are dear and near
to their hearts. I think we can try to
hold ourselves to the same standard and
have a one minute comment each, which
would be eight minutes per eight or nine
minutes per topic and we could get
through a lot faster.
>> All right, next one.
>> All right, I'm got my minute timer. All
right, we're talking about Northeast
Austin feeders. So, effectively, this is
looking at the boundary for Marshall
Middle School and which elementaryaries
feed into it. We've um what you see on
the screen is some of the logic that
went into initially selecting what you
saw on October 3rd. There were the eight
elementary schools that we considered
because those were the eight that were
assigned. So that is Andrews, Bllandon,
Harris, Jordan, Norman Sims, Overton,
Pan Springs, and Win. Um and so we
looked at Marshall is literally in
Blandon's boundary. It is also our
furthest comprehensive middle school
east. So that brought in Overton,
Jordan, Pon Springs, which are on the
east. Um, and then we just looked at,
well, how much more how many more
students could we fit. Norman Sims can
all fit because we were really
prioritizing no splits. That was what we
had heard at the time. Harris and
Andrews are closer to web, part of their
new boundaries. So, that was why they
were assigned to web, but we have heard
from the community um that they were
very disappointed to see that Northeast
Austin was being split up. They want
they saw this as an opportunity to bring
together Windsor Park and University
Hills. So, we have looked at an
alternative um that we wanted to present
to you all today and get feedback on. Um
we did have a focus group with north
with some northeast Austin families that
represented many of the schools of the
eight um which just informed this
approach. Just what you see on the
screen on the left is um the current
October 3rd plan. The caveat the what
you see on the right does bring Andrews
and Harris south of 290 into Marshall
Middle School. So it does introduce a
split for those elementaryaries. Those
students that live south of 290 would go
to Marshall. Those that live north of
290 would go to Web. It also sends
Norman Sims to Keeling instead of
Marshall. So those are the two changes
in this that does unite Northeast Austin
at middle school. Um it also when you
see this from a percent utilization
based on who lives in this zone, it will
look over full. It'll be um looking and
we'll we're working with our
demographers on the official number. But
if you look at this zone today, number
of kids students enrolled today, there
are 913 middle school students that live
in this boundary
that we we don't ever want to put more
than 800 in this school. I know that the
capacity shows 9:15, but this is one
where the enrollment capacity is really
less than the facility capacity, at
least now that we're learning the
building. That could change over time,
but right now that would be the max. But
if you look at which students in that
zone currently choose Sadler Means or
Gus Garcia, you only have 721 middle
school students left. Many of those do
choose Keeling, they choose Lively,
they're transferring to other campuses.
So, we we could do this. It just does
mean that we need need to make sure we
monitor enrollment, make sure we're
still recruiting into our single gender
schools, but this this is one option for
you all to discuss.
>> Thank you. And one question to follow
up. What does this do at high school?
Great question. So, this would send
Blandon that would not change those
boundaries. So, it would effectively
Blandon, Paris, and Andrews would move
to Northeast. So, and then Pan Springs,
Overton, and Jordan would move to LBJ.
So it would be a fairly even split for
Marshall Middle School into those two
high schools. Yeah.
>> Thank you. Yes. Good. Um also, uh just
two questions that the community has
really lifted up and I need to ask you
now. Um the first question is why
weren't the single genders looked at?
>> Yeah. So um I'm happy to answer that.
This is one of those um really big
questions uh that when we started the
process um we [clears throat] weren't
able to to consider. I would say the
same is true of magnets. That was also
something I shared that last night with
the community. you know magnets single
gender and even now as you talk about
some of the philosophical
you know ideologies around wallto-wall
whether we should or shouldn't um and so
we started this process you know earth
sets Gus Garcia had been making progress
they had been in the in in the
organization thriving especially
recently um you know given how they came
about the complexity it just was a big
big thing to like consider. So it wasn't
a focus. That's the honest truth. We re
we would look at that at the same time
we look at magnets and both of those are
huge huge endeavors. I think as we move
forward once we get past this I do think
that we have to explore all of these
things if the board you know would have
the administration do that. Um but
that's why it wasn't included as part of
this specific work. That's just
>> that's just a question I had from the
community. And then for my last that was
just the 30 seconds the first part David
and for the last um 30 seconds um there
is an appetite in um sort of the um
University Hills Windsor Park to have
another allgender and that's really
something that has been asked and I'm
not saying that this happens now during
this plan but it's something that
because we have children at Overton and
Jordan they pass two middle schools to
get to their middle school right and
then they're going to come back to go to
their high school, which is how it's set
up now. And it's a lot less than it used
to be, right? It was all over the place.
So, this is I'm just sharing with you
what I've heard from the community. But
as far as the new like keeping uh that
hole from 290 to 51st hole, I think that
this is what they were asking for.
>> Okay, we good. Oh, sorry. I'm sorry,
President Boswell like talking when you
should talk.
>> No, go this. It's a workshop. It's super
casual. So, please
Trusty Foster, you have a comment.
>> Um,
I apologize for not being able to like
follow all the boundaries that it gets
confusing to me. So, I'll just speak in
plain terms the way it's coming to me
from community um
the Mueller. So between Mayor Airport
51st, that triangle that is Mueller um
currently or in the in the plan was
splitting to [clears throat]
Campbell and Blandon at elementary.
Correct. And then so where's Campbell
going now?
>> Keeling.
>> Campbell goes to Keeling. Where does
half of Mueller that goes to Campbell?
Did the Mueller boundaries get changed
at all?
>> No. And that was a product of Maplewood,
which is now C part of Campbell and
Campbell, were not one of the eight
elementary schools that were initially
considered for Marshall. And that was
our starting point. One option to get
all of Mueller into Marshall would be to
divide up the Maplewood community and
reassign some to Blandon and some to
Campbell.
>> And what would that do for us? I'm
sorry, say that again. It would allow
the Mueller community to all go to
Marshall. I can't speak for how the
Maplewood community feel about being
split because that was part of the logic
in combining them into Campbell's
building.
>> Correct. But we were able to move all of
them together into Campbell's building.
We could split them and send some to
Blandon, but it would be divi and change
Bllandon's boundary um because then it
would align with the feeders. But we
don't have enough space at Marshall to
take all of Campbell's new boundary.
>> So help me. This is where some, you
know, sort of forward and long-term
thinking comes in. One of the things I'd
like to see is because we and thank you
for like the the the
vertical just getting cleaned up to such
a great extent. Um,
one of the things that Mueller also is
split on the high school level,
Northeast Macallum, does that retain
as well?
>> They will rejoin together at high school
at Northeast.
>> At Northeast,
>> correct?
>> So, I'm I'm I'm looking down and I
apologize for this taking long like I I
can't like vote on stuff and have it not
be talked about. Um
I think that part of the strength of
Northeast is going to be the strength of
the communities kind of feeding in. And
one of the things that we did with
Mueller that I had a
not only sympathetic to but advocated
for was to put a middle school in
Mueller instead of an elementary school
which kind of sacrificed walkability.
But I think a whole bunch of us felt
like that gave us a better shot of
having Marshall be something integrated
serving much of the east. The trade-off
was that that very, you know, large area
lost elementary walkability. Um, if
we're asking that community to invest in
Northeast, which I am asking,
um, I would think we would have greater
success in having that if they all fed
together. So, if the Muellerites are
going to
I don't know what else to say, Meroska,
whatever. If the Muellerites are are um
going to this elementary school and that
elementary school, fine, that's one
split. Come back whole to Marshall and
then come back whole to Northeast. I
think we will retain more families and
be able to build a sense of community
and investment that is really good for
Northeast. Um, so I guess that's a I
guess I' I'd love to hear an alternative
theory of action of how we're going to
have communities invest in Northeast
if we don't work with them to help build
a good path.
So one thing I would offer Trusty Foster
is that this is I hope an improvement to
getting to having aligned
having alignment and having communities
move together through the system. So I
think it's an improvement from where we
were. I think this is one of those areas
where it comes into direct conflict with
another guiding principle which is if
you're going to make a change and you
can keep community together then try to
to do that. And so the Maplewood split
is one that I think you know if we're
making if we're going to consolidate a
school we had really tried to keep the
mass the majority of the campus
together. A split would kind of run
counter to that. So it's really two
things. Um my offering would be you know
is this one of those things where as
this plays out and then we commit to
revisiting boundaries you know every
three or four years you say okay like
we've had three or four years of us
operating in this configuration what did
we learn what did we miss you know
revisit it so that you know as we
progress on as an organization we don't
have to wait 20 years or 100 year to do
something um I'm just this is just going
to create a conflict you know regarding
that kind of guiding principle is if
you're going to make a change, try to
have everybody go together. They were
already split up. We're trying to bring
the other elements of the vertical
closer together. Um to get all the way
there, I now create a split down here at
Maplewood going wholly into Campbell.
So, that's just one of the things that
it's makes this so complex, honestly.
>> Can I turn to Trusty Hunter? I don't
know if you you like don't don't put me
in this, but do you
um so we're
we're serving the same communities. Um
do you have thoughts on
what I'm speaking to in terms of the
Mueller split and all this?
Generally speaking,
if you have this community go to two
high schools, especially the two high
schools that you have, there's already
um tension about they don't have fill in
the blank. They don't have fill in the
blank. Um I think even you mentioned
like, you know, every school has arts,
you know, or whatever, you know, that
sort of thing. And I think that's the
tension. I would love it if everyone was
zoned to Northeast. I think that's
fantastic. Northeast is an actual
wonderful place where my child graduated
from. My other child would have gone
there if she didn't, you know, get an
application into Macau. So, it's just I
don't know how I'm glad that's your job,
but um how do you kind of solve for
that? Because then you're just going to
like stress unless you really line up
and tighten up the transfer policy,
you're just going to have a bunch of
people jumping ship or trying to jump
ship. So, if you keep the splits in high
schools like you have them and you
tighten up the transfer policy, I think
it'll be fine. Right.
>> Just to confirm, they what you see in
maroon is going to northeast. So, they
do all um this would be Harris, Andrews,
Blandon, and part of Campbell. This is a
split because this community is so close
to east side. So, that does create a
split for the new Campbell. This is the
area in the current proposal that would
go to Norththeast.
>> Speaking to what Kevin was speaking
about Mueller,
>> right? All of Mueller would go to
Northeast in this. They split it middle
school. So part this part of Mueller did
something
>> Mueller was never all going to Marshall
because the currentit was always been
split because Maplewood was not one of
the eight that we even considered for
the boundary.
>> Remember that? And so now
you have everyone going to Northeast.
>> Yes. But part of me part of Mueller does
go to Keeling.
>> Yeah.
>> Go back to the original.
>> So what you see in yellow are your
middle school lines.
[snorts]
>> And I can also do the reverse.
>> I don't
>> that will be updated on Friday.
And so what families want want to know
there and that's where the academics
come in. What will their what will they
be able to have at Nor at Northeast
where they need to see their schools.
They need to get a tour when they go and
they need to know academically what is
going to be offered. We need strong
academic offerings at every single
campus.
I will tell them they get that really
cool VR math class where they put the VR
things on and do math.
>> I would also be remiss to highlight
because this didn't make it on the slide
when we were revising them. What this
does do is it does introduce a three-way
split at Keeling. So, this Keeling goes
to Marshall or Keeling goes to
Northeast, East Side, and LBJ.
Our steering committee went back and
forth on this and those very familiar
with the Keeling program felt like since
it's already part magnet, this was if
you were to have a middle school that
had a three-way split, it was one that
>> they're already splitting anyway.
>> Yeah. So, I but I didn't I didn't want
to leave here without making sure y'all
were aware that that is another kind of
consequence of this change.
>> So, you're going to have half of Mueller
going
Campbell
Keeling northeast. So, south, further
south, jump north.
>> Yes. [clears throat]
>> So,
>> and we hit 15. I'm adding five.
>> I I um
you know, by principle,
I have a leaning towards building in
just equity in so many different
directions. And
I do think that
we are going to lose hearts and minds, I
guess you'd say, um, if we don't
follow through on a theory of action
that creates an appropriate alignment, I
think to ask a community to say, "Okay,
this time around we didn't give you an
elementary because we gave you we well,
we didn't give you an elementary. we put
in the middle instead. And then to say
now as we go back around, we're going to
close this one school and we're going to
affect a split that sends you all to
this school camp. So your Maplewood's
closed, you're going to go to Campbell,
then you're going to go to Keeling, then
you go to Northeast. They ain't going.
And it's to again to Trusty Whitley
Chu's point, I have great faith in
Northeast
at where it is going from F to D to C. I
have great faith in Northeast and
um
I need to lean into that. But I also
think that a community
doesn't have an unreasonable ask to have
the cleanness of a pattern for their
neighborhood. The hit that I am willing
to and it's not a hit to me is to say,
"Okay, we're going to clean this up. No,
you were going to Macllum. Now it's
Northeast."
I should give something that's
consistent with that along the way. Does
that Does that follow? Do you understand
what I'm saying?
>> Not really.
>> I I I So, yes to what Trusty Whitley Chu
said, yes to what I think you're about
to say. That's part of the work that
we're going to have to do across the
district, right? Any school, any
transition that's occurring, what's
occurring at high school A versus high
school B, middle school A versus middle
school B. How do we seed programming to
communicate and communicate effectively
that this is what your child will
experience? You're going to be prepared
when you're when you get here. But also
these are also the other amazing things
that are happening at this school that
you may not know about that's happening
now that that that is also part of the
problem is that they some families feel
like what is happening at their school
this school is the only great thing
happening and then the other schools
like these great things are happening
but they don't know about it.
>> So so we're doing that work now. We're
pulling students we're identifying their
pathways what programs have have been
attractive to those communities. So, so
the programmatic side and the preparing
side to ensure that those students have
>> nice
>> they see themselves throughout the
feeder pattern. Yes, that's all part of
our work on the our work.
>> This was meant to be we heard from our
community that this was a a concern that
the way that this the like the issue
we're trying to address university hills
in Windsor Park like so if we can find a
solution which is what we're offering to
do it we can do it this way. Um, that is
really what what I I need to understand
because that's going to have other,
right? Because that creates a a conflict
in the three-way split that we talked
about. Three-way split is what I said
was like in the ceiling and then you
challenged me to say get to two, right?
But this is going to be one of those
things where what what is the trade-off?
If I don't keep the neighborhood
together, then I can go back to two-way
split, but that doesn't so that that's
what I really need like help to like
guide the conversation forward and the
work forward.
>> Got it. So um and one of the things we
talked about is the academic visioning
piece and so in the academic framework
the academic approach and part of that
articulation come plan like 1.2 or 2.0
or whatever on Friday is going to
reassure people of a practice that we
already have which is to track who's
likely to come to the school, who would
have been zoned here and what they would
have been doing. And so we know in all
likelihood we're going to need to
provide this here because we're gonna
have students that want it.
>> Yes. So, um, what we have ready for
Friday or what we will have ready for
Friday is the process that we're going
through to make it just transparent to
look across the district at all of the
programs, all of the courses that are
being offered. Um, gathering that,
verifying that information, and then
starting to run campus bycampus analysis
of uh, the courses that are offered. But
then we're also pulling specific student
schedules who are being reszoned to see
what classes they those specific
students are enrolled in and kind of uh
project uh what the uh future pathway of
those students would be and also to know
the most enrolled courses at those
campus. Uh so we're starting there. Um
we will be able to on Friday at the
granular level offer that campus
bycampus analysis analysis from Macallum
to Northeast and also from Austin High
School to Crockett.
>> And your granular analysis what you're
saying is it is a gr the granularity
isn't just regional. It's not just
school. It's really to the kids. So we
can say this is the trajectory. This
many kids going in this direction.
>> Yes. at these courses at these schools
and and then also explaining the next
steps in the process. We see gaps here
at this campus or we or you may not even
know the things that this campus has
that they are doing and so we want to
highlight those as well. um alternative
courses, but also uh start started
conversations and work with
administrators today at the secondary
level about course offerings about new
students coming to their schools about
different enrollment that they may have
previously seen as underenrolled
campuses and then starting to make
preparations for having conversations
with teachers. um you know how we will
make those sections and those courses
happen and be able to find teachers for
it and offer those courses at at
campuses that may not currently have it.
So all of that will be part of Friday
>> and and with apologies I have over 30
unique
>> comments to
Northeast programming.
>> I have over 300 responses in my survey
and I have over 30 unique questions
about Northeast academic programming.
And so that's why I'm raising this up
with apologies.
>> That's that's one of the reasons in the
comment card we see that as well. And so
that's one of the reasons we started
with these two specific uh shifts
because there are significant questions
about those campuses. So to highlight
the programs that are happening, but
also recognize where there are gaps and
start communicating the process for
filling any gaps.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you for that. And I would say that
applies too to been reszoned to Crockett
from Austin High to people who've who've
been reszoned to web to people and it's
a middle school issue. It's a high
school issue and I would add to that.
Thank you for the work and I I'm excited
to see that. Really hope that we'll
start having open houses before a vote.
Communities are hungry to come together.
Um there was a community member who
proposed having a meeting with the two
principles getting together uh with
community and having a principalled
meeting just to have that conversation
together. when people get together, they
have good conversations, they build
relationships, they learn things about
each other, I think there's real value.
And the more we can do to help people
understand the offerings, I think the
better. And I would also say it's not
just what course is offered on paper,
it's how that course is taught. It is
who's reading novels. It's what the
writing rubric looks like. We have had a
moment not in the very distant past
where the our high school writing
rubrics, one asked for a topic sentence,
three body sentences, a closing
sentence. It asked for capitalization
and punctuation for a high school
writing rubric. The other was complexity
of thought, use of vocabulary. We need
to understand the rigor and and the
excellence in all of our campuses. It's
what we've been asking for as a
community for a really long time to make
sure it's it goes back to what's
developmentally appropriate. It goes
back to that richness to make sure we're
also understanding how things are taught
and be being really supportive of
trusting every one of our students to
get a really engaging, exciting, rich,
ambitious education. Um because one
English class doesn't look like another
English class across our district. We
know our teachers are ready for that,
totally prepared for that. and we need
to be offering that and I want to be
sure we're being really honest about
that too. Thank you.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And just a quick note
on that, um there will also be uh uh
information on what that larger academic
framework looks like that you do build
out for all classrooms over time. We've
been working as as you all know to
really build consistency across campuses
and high expectations. Um, and then this
framework will talk more to the the
depth of that work and the long-term
work and community engagement with that
as well.
>> Thank you. And I would say what we hear
from our community is not that it's a a
cookie cutter approach, right? That it's
a high level and that campuses our we
trust our teachers at high school with
some autonomy and and I think that's
what I'm hearing from the community, but
that we have that richness and that
excellence everywhere.
>> Thank you.
>> So, quick comment. I just want to make
be responsive to something you said,
President Boswell, around open houses
before a vote takes place. Um, I think
as we move towards a vote, I I certainly
want to create the space for that. I
worry about
doing too much before a vote because
there's still anxiousness in the
community about what will or will not
happen. If I go to a community and we
just talked about that school being
here, I can't set the expectation that
they'll have there's just a balance
there. So, I just wanted to acknowledge
that.
>> Thank you. just sharing an idea from the
community that says they would just be
eager to at least start having those
those whatif conversations more than an
it will be. And I really appreciate the
responsiveness to our community, you
know, saying this isn't what will be,
it's what's proposed. So, thank you for
that as well.
>> Um, okay, where are we on this one? I
think I'm hearing
>> just just one quick 30 seconds or less.
um in regards to you know you spoke
about Maplewood as an example of the
community and I just wanted to highlight
the difference between the feedback at
least that I'm getting between
elementary level and secondary level you
know the the feedback I get from the
elementary people is very much about
community in the people sense you know
the neighborhood the kids the the
collaboration there and how much of a
difference it is in the feedback um even
at General Marshall the two-way
engagement that we did about programming
specifically and whether those moves are
resulting in equitable programming or
that they have access to the same things
that they were going to have at Macllum.
Um so there is a difference there and I
think when you're approaching splits and
those elements um you know to be mindful
of those differences because those
elementary communities in particular are
are you know extremely sensitive to the
effect on the the social element for the
for the kids whereas you know it's just
very different at high school. Like
certainly they're still friends and
you've known them, but I mean at that
point you can go.
>> Oh yeah. No, I thank you for making that
distinction because I I I agree with you
and as you get larger and larger
attendance boundaries, the area gets
larger than neighborhoods. It just
becomes a whole area of the city. So
appreciate that comment. All right,
we're going to roll to the next one.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> So this next one, similarly, we have
just data for you all to reference. On
the first slide, we are discussing um
the area of South Central Austin in
which we are proposing to close Becker
and Dawson. We have heard ample
community feedback around the boundary
and so are providing an alternative to
discuss. Just to share some of the logic
that went into our initial proposal,
um Dawson and Becker have the fewest
number of neighborhood students in this
area. I don't um and we did and so that
led to kind of that and other elements
led to other programmatic moves that
we've talked about at length. Anyway, so
we're looking at we did explore what you
see on the right which was reassigning
Becker down to so this is what you saw
on October 3rd. Becker is zoned into
Zilker
current Zilker part of Zilker's boundary
and this is part of Joslin. We're zoned
into Galindo. So purple is Galindo, blue
is Zilker on the right, which is one we
can discuss. Blue is Zilker, purple is
Galindo. Um, and here are just some of
the elements of the change. The main
driver of our initial decision was just
really based on student need in this
area and our confidence in being able to
support students. We have discussed at
length these plans and my colleagues can
answer any questions around more of
that, but leaving it to y'all to
discuss.
>> Yeah. So are just a quick question. Are
you saying that the proposed change
creates accountability concerns? Not
accountability. No. Okay.
>> Yeah. No, I I think President Boswell,
this is one of those ones where when we
started the
>> Yeah. Sorry.
>> Um President Basel, we started the
process. Uh we were trying to to kind of
make all the shifts um work um and then
kind of acknowledge that, you know, with
different student needs, there's
different resources and kind of the
balance of support that we have uh in
the area. We've heard from community
that um there's different configurations
they'd like to to see considered. We
have discussed as a team like the Lindo
is going to be successful period. Like
we're very confident about that. So I I
there's I don't have a concern. We don't
have a concern. We heard it from the
community. Uh but wanted to share with
you all because it it's one that's come
up a lot and I've heard it from lots of
different trustees and so wanted to
offer it. So to me we can accommodate
it. We're very confident we'll we'll
provide the needs to our students. Um
our students will excel. So, I'm happy
to to make the adjustment. I just
because of how much it's come out, I
want to just put it out there.
>> Thank you. I mean, I'd love to say I,
you know, I've heard a lot from these
this community. This is in my trusty
district. Um, Becker is as well. And I
think, um, you know, this is walkable
and bikable for these families right
now. I've driven the new routes. Um, you
know, Becker, Galindo,
that neighborhood to Galindo. It's not a
very safe drive. It's really windy and
hilly and um it's not bikable. It's not.
And I think um when when we chose
minimize disruption and keep communities
together as two of our four values, I
meant those in equal measure to other
things. And to me, minimize disruption
means
don't move people without a really good
reason. Um that's part of what I was
looking for. And and people's lives are
kind of built around where your child
care is. You can't get new child care.
you probably signed your kid up before
your kid was born. Um, so I would be
supportive of this and I also know that
the Becker community has made a
different proposal um that this could
accommodate this doesn't close the door
on that. I don't know, you know, if
you've considered that or if you've seen
it. I've put it in in one of my comment
cards, but I do I would be very
supportive of this.
I did want to just acknowledge because
it didn't the big difference for folks
that are not as familiar with this area
because what we have heard a lot from
the Zilker community. This does reassign
Becker to an entirely different school.
So those resident students that choose
not to relocate with the dual language
program. So I just want to acknowledge
that that is a change. It might I don't
I don't know how people feel about the
change, but I would be remiss to not
highlight that as something for y'all to
just note. But either way, Becker would
be going to a different school than they
go to currently.
>> That's correct.
>> And the Becker students have the
opportunity to move together.
>> That's correct. Yes. Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'll say I haven't heard a huge
amount from the Becker community about
this specific move because I think the
focus has been on remaining together on
having another option. And I think plan
A for them, you know, I have asked for
ABC. I know Trusty Henry has asked for
good, better, best and and A is
obviously remain where they are. B has
been remain together in South Austin
somewhere and C is remain together
somewhere else. So I think um
you know the the hope is to remain
together somewhere. Um, President
Boswell, since you mentioned it, do you
want to just
um comm community-driven kind of idea
was because I I we've looked at it. I
just want to make sure that it's clear
because it it wasn't explicitly
explicitly stated.
>> Yeah, I will have to pull it up from my
email, but it's a a kind of a a
neighborhoodwide
Becker Dawson Galindo kind of [snorts]
um move that would do that and also
support this. So, I think there's and
and would keep those families. I have
driven that Becker to Sanchez and it is
not an easy drive. Um it is not nearby.
I know there uh some families at that in
the Becker community are also really
concerned about students from Metobrook
which is a a city of Austin housing
authority development. Um they're very
concerned about that. Thank you Trusty
Kintana for sharing that. Yeah. Um, and
I know those the families in the Becker
community are really concerned about
Mebook families not having equitable
access if if Becker moves to Sanchez.
Uh, and I know that's been a real
concern as well. Um, so I think this the
proposal that they've brought addresses
a lot of their concerns and keeps them
in in what they consider their larger
neighborhood and really I think is just
more workable um, not only for the
students but also for a lot of the
staff. So, um, I'll welcome the
administration's input on that as well,
but thank you.
>> Okay,
Trustee Coffman, I thought you were
about to say something.
>> I was just going to echo that same
sentiment, especially around ensuring
you've considered the data and the
suggestions proposed by the the Becker
group.
>> Yeah. and and as we get we get lots of
different ideas and so every time we can
respond to them they'll be in the
comment. I mean that's part of our work
as well. [snorts]
Okay. Um so I appreciate that. We can
hop to the next one. Um
>> okay that's
>> all right. So uh Martin Middle School
and just so everybody's there wasn't a
particular order. Um if anybody's asking
like why we've I was
>> we are going to make time for it all. It
all matters and we're going to make time
for it.
>> Yeah. Um so Martin Middle School uh
y'all are I'm sure aware of the plan. Um
M Martin would be closed re the um
students would be assigned to other
schools. The majority being a keen keen
would receive the tap. One of the things
that uh we have heard is that um there
was really a desire to to think through
and and kind of reimagine what was going
to occur at Martin. Uh and we at the
community meeting that we had and lots
of feedback that I've gotten is kind of
acknowledgement that hey you know we'd
like to do that but what does the
timeline look like and being transparent
around the time that it would take to
build out a program you know work with
community you know there's been
different ideas floated around and one
of the things we heard is like well we
want to have input in and I agree and
that's going to take time uh and so the
current if to go through that process in
the deliverable or in the plan to the
board that ultimately gets voted I want
to have clear concrete timelines and say
we're going to do this at this point,
this at this point, this at this point.
But that still really ends up being kind
of a 27 28 timeline horizon at the
earliest because of where we are now and
what's required and what the agency's
role is in approval of any new school,
etc. So, I wanted to offer this um to uh
the trustees, y'all. it's in the plan
because there are other things that
we've heard um you know heard about
prek8 dual language
there's been other ideas that that have
kind of metriculated up um that I'd like
to kind of just pose to see if there's
an appetite to have us consider it or
not in an effort to kind of have Martin
be activated sooner than the 2728 time
horizon that makes any sense.
So, um, does that sound like that's
that's that's what I want to drive the
discussion because that's what I've been
hearing from community like two years is
too long. We want
>> Thank you.
>> So,
>> yeah. Um, a couple things that I would
say and I'm kind of going out on a limb
here because
to president, sorry, trustee Singh's
comment. [snorts] You don't really once
you kind of get into it as long as we
have and all the things that we're
trying to see and and accomplish more
things kind of you see more things. And
so one uh idea that's kind of come about
um in an effort to to kind of activate
and and move this to do this would be
could we consider um moving um Garza
from its current location moving it to
Martin uh expanding the uh grade levels
uh and going 6 through 12. Uh there's
been um a lot of desire uh that I've
heard in the community that we don't
have that offering for middle school
students. Um I've heard it a lot. I know
that we've talked about it. We've never
had the ability to expand at Garza. It's
just not going to be possible there. But
it would allow us to So this is one of
those things where like it's pretty it's
it's this is like
just a lot of things kind we're working
through. So please stay with me until I
finish the the idea then. So Garza would
move to um uh to Martin. So we can start
that immediately because it's an
existing program. We'd have the space to
expand. It doesn't require approval,
right? You can move programs. We we do
that. That's we're doing that now. And
then Garza would then um receive um the
alternative learning center at Mendes.
Um because one of the things that that
we know right now is that men ALC is
temporarily located at Mendes. Um that's
because of the need the Nita Koy housing
project.
In the future, Mendes um will be an
Austin ISD school and depending on how
we you know support that school and what
the student needs are um having kind of
access to the entire school um was going
to create more opportunity if that makes
any sense. Um and so at some point we're
going to have to solve for several of
these things. Um, it does require some
moves. All the programs exist. There's
no new programs. I think for for us,
what's really could be really exciting
is it is providing an offering uh for
middle school. And then because it's a
hub like right there, it could be
activated. It's students in the
community, which we know what the
community would love to see. And then if
if there's any additional space, we
could have partner programming come in
and really build on that. Um, we're just
seeing more and more students in middle
school need this support. Um, so it's an
it is one of those things that addresses
many things at the same time. I know I
haven't shared this. It's not something
that's been out there. I wanted to kind
of see um what the feedback might be
because a traditional process would
require
time and probably a couple years for for
for sure to get there. And and even at
that point, the agency will still have
to approve whatever that plan is and the
CDN number.
I know it's a lot. I apologize. It's a
lot, but again, you don't see things
until you see things is maybe what I
would say. [snorts]
>> Um, so that's that's
>> trustana. Yeah. Thank you.
>> Um, I like it. I like the idea of a 612.
Um, having gone to a 612 myself
is a tad different, but um, we know it
works. And um you're right about not
having to, you know, entirely
develop a new sort of model and program
in the district. Um and I do like the
idea of, you know, starting back at
Martin sooner rather than later. um
especially as we think about
you know as as as we go throughout this
process and um think about you know
students who leave us and might not come
back. Um
I did want to ask though if we put
Garza
and the alternative learning center at
Martin
>> No.
>> Oh you saying a different idea.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Sorry. Can we use the building
that Garza is in? Could we do like an
Anita Koy like something there
>> as far as like a
>> housing project? [snorts]
Um it's a tight footprint. I I I think
the setbacks might be a challenge. Um
you know, given the height um
restrictions, it would have to be multif
family.
>> Um so more of an apartment complex,
higher density.
>> I I would have to test that. Honestly, I
I'm kind of I know what we could likely
do, but I really want to test that and
see what's possible.
>> Okay. But, um I just wanted to throw
that out there. But I really like the
the 612 or the or the prek8.
>> So, yeah. So, the prek8 um so that's one
that we've talked about and and I was
committed to exploring that model and
we're still committed to exploring it.
Um that model would still be on the
timeline horizon of
>> two years. Yeah, because it because it
it would require the planning time. It
would require um the approval process.
We we don't have that model now.
>> Um so we would have to to really ensure
that it was going to be successful and
we're able to support it.
>> So So to me that would be available in a
traditional timeline.
>> Okay.
>> So So that that's that's what we're I'm
trying to and at the end of the day
we're still going to have to perhaps
solve for the other moves as well.
>> I'm sorry. Um, go ahead.
>> I would also just like to raise uh the
concern around staffing and you know
seeing how we can bring Martin staff
back um with whatever we do. Um so just
want to throw that wrench in there.
[snorts]
>> Yeah. No, I I appreciate that. Um we're
committed to ensuring all staff are
prioritized through this process. um you
know obviously I don't want to say
obviously but as part of this um the
students that will be moving to Keeling
there'll be additional staff required at
Keeling and our expectation of principal
Estus as he knows is to ensure that he's
welcoming staff first and foremost from
Martin um that also being said if
there's an expansion of the program you
know if this were to be the an idea that
is worth again this is an idea so I I
need to we need to work on it but we
think there's enough here to to really
put energy into it. Uh the off the 612 I
mean um the the what's missing right now
Garza is the the 67 and 8 part. Now it's
not going to be the same type of
programming because it's a unique
program. There's different offerings. Uh
but you have more of an opportunity for
Martin educators to stay at that site
with this type of solution than perhaps
maybe the two-year runway to go EC8. Um,
so, so I'm I think that the opportunity
exists for sure in in another way that
it also does already exist at Keine.
>> Right. Well, I'd love to hear what my
colleagues have to say.
>> I think my one I like the idea of adding
we've had a lot of families ask for a
Garza like auction for middle school and
I know that's a need. So, I really like
the idea of that um somewhere. And I
just want to um say before we were to
consider the the other idea of putting
ALC and Garza in the same on the same
campus, I would want to have a really
clear understanding and I know that's
not what you propose, but I know it's
been mentioned and I just want to say I
know a lot of kids go to Garza for a
whole lot of reasons and sometimes it's
for a clean start to get away from
something and I want to be really really
thoughtful. one of our mandatory two of
our mandatory removals. You know,
substance is a mandatory removal and I
would want to be really thoughtful about
um how different communities felt about
that and just protecting that that
really beautiful really life-changing
life-saving bubble that Garza is for our
students. It's it's such a safe place
for so many so many reasons. um and
being really thoughtful about that.
>> Having a griffin griffith my griffin
myself, um I've often wondered like why
do you have to struggle and endure all
the way to 10th grade before you could
like finally get some help if you
persist and last that long? But a
concern that I have, one is uh Drew has
that program set up like it needs to be
set up and it runs the accountability
like gotta find transportation gota he's
very clear he meets with every single
student. Um pulling in 6th through 12
does it because Garza right now is a
special program. If you add six,
seventh, eighth, I guess really ninth
honestly would it trigger
accountability?
>> Yeah. So I
>> Yeah, I mean so so we know the way that
I mean it's it's a special program sorry
special programming um and so the
accountability is already different for
for Garza and and we know that um that's
why I think what what makes this idea
intriguing to me is that you don't have
to expand all the grade levels
immediately,
>> right? You could you could start the
move and like what we did with General
Marshall build out sixth and seventh and
eighth. You know, we could do an initial
expansion, but you don't have to do it
all immediately. So,
>> you would go backwards.
>> I'm sorry.
>> You would go backwards, not forwards.
So, you would say ninth grade, eighth
grade, or you saying start with six?
>> I This is This is why it's an idea.
Okay. Because I I I there's enough here
to have
>> The question becomes this is an idea
from the board. Um, is there enough here
to give the administration the ability
to move forward and work? Because I'm
not going to present something in a plan
that I know can't be done. There's I
know enough. We know enough. It solves
lots of challenges that we have and
creates new opportunities and at the
same time we think it's workable, but I
I haven't been like, let's go, right?
Because that that time takes time and
energy and resources. Um, but to be
responsive to what we're hearing from
the community about wanting to restart
Martin and at the same time
acknowledging that there are other
things in the area and that just in
general that we have to
>> account for at some point in the future.
Um, this could be a unique solution. Um,
but I don't have the details yet um,
Trusty Hunter, but I I would do all of
that work. That's what we're going to
>> especially we would have to uh the
administration would definitely most
definitely need to uh talk with the
experts who are the people who are
already doing that work. Oh, 100%.
>> I I I I think it's an idea worth
exploring.
>> If you can answer that question for me.
>> Oh, I will answer all the questions. I
just want
>> You can answer that question for me
because there's support to to move
forward with that. Um, do you want to
move on to the next
>> talk? Just quick, can it handle the the
transit? Like, is there enough parking
and and
>> Oh, yeah. Well, Martin's much bigger
than Garza.
Yeah, but with the added grade levels
and everything.
>> Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Martin is
not.
>> Yeah. So, so Martin, so Martin, so that
when you think about So, so I'm going to
just like touch on this, but Martin is
severely underenrolled currently. Um,
and so there there is ample space um to
support the programming to expand and
also probably add additional programs.
Uh space is not a concern at Martin with
the expansion.
>> Yeah. I I mean parking.
>> No, no. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
>> Yeah. There's a lot of Well, well, so
it's parking is not one to one of the
city of Austin when it comes to student
populations. It's it's very different. I
I feel confident on the parking side. Um
that that won't be an issue for us.
I'm I'm surprised about the the the
Garza piece and I
see great possibility and excitement. Um
I have very specific pointed worries
that I will share I guess offline or in
in email and followup in the interest of
time.
>> That a check
>> and I just have one question. If that
were to happen, would that take away the
opportunity for it to be a K8, preK8 at
some point? Is it Do we think it's a
one-way door?
>> Yeah, I I Yeah, that we I would because
of the sequence of moves, I I do not
want to move ALC. Um we've been working
with Dr. Green. Um there's been a lot of
work about, you know, improving the
programming, providing new opportunities
and experiences for our students. Like
this is an opportunity to almost kind of
reset ALC as well. The way I view it, um
a campus that's their own. I mean,
they've always been kind of sharing. Uh
there's there's things to work through,
but yes, it would it would essentially
eliminate EC8 at this school because I
wouldn't want to make another move in
the future. Um, but for this specific
site, not from our portfolio of
offerings, but from this site
specifically, but it could open up new
opportunities at Mendes
Better Middle School. Uh so uh one of
the things that um we have been working
through is is just you know there's a
surplus of middle school seats uh in the
area. There's a turnaround plan for 3UA
for both Petta and Betachch. There's
been conversations and questions around
so why Petta and and why not Betachch or
why why why not Petta instead of
Betachch and I wanted to be with
information here just communicate that
it really comes down to geography
um you know the Betachch is surrounded
by other middle schools and so when it
comes to uh being able to accept and
receive the students um we're able to do
it because of just where it's located
geog geographically there's just schools
around it that can absorb we did make
adjustments and reduce the number of
schools that um Betachch would be u
moving to. At one point in the original
plan, I think there was five schools.
>> Yes.
>> Four.
>> Oh, no, there was
>> there was five because it was like a 004
that was going to Henry. Uh so we've
been able to make changes there uh to to
improve that. But I wanted to kind of
create the space here to talk about the
expectation on a restart um or what it
looks like moving forward with um
betach. Um, so you can see here you can
Yeah, just show it just show it quick.
This is just because we were just we
were referencing it. I think it's
pertinent to this conversation what the
moves like. Would you want you want to
see?
>> Yeah, there's just a lot of numbers I
want to explain. So here's like what are
all these things? Okay, so white shows
the betach splits. The teal because this
also links to it's a layer cake. I use
that metaphor is the teal is like
elementary. So we also were able to
resolve the three-way split at Williams
and the two-way split at Pleasant Hill
with this change. And so what you see on
the left was October 3rd and on the
right instead of sending this rectangle
in pink to Lively, this whole top area
is instead of Betachch being reassigned
to U Mendes, the central area as a whole
will be reassigned to Covington and then
the bottom area to Pettis. So it solved
many different kind of splits at once.
>> And this is a small boundary adjustment
that we've made on our side that's not
in your packet. Correct. It also aligns
at high school which was a request for
the Travis community to keep West
Congress part of the Travis boundary. So
it was a very fruitful endeavor.
>> Yeah. So, so the question for the
trustees and the feedback is regarding
um kind of the similar to what we had at
Martin is the commitment and the
timeline and the plan to progress a a
new and reinvisioned kind of campus. And
so I wanted to hear from our trustees
um what what you've heard ideas um you
know I want to make sure that we have
adjustments in the boundary. we've
reduced the number of splits. Um but uh
other ideas to be considered um for
betach. Um so just kind of wanted to
open it up. Um I've gotten different
things and ideas, but I I really want to
understand like where we should spend
our resources to and time to progress.
Um to provide that assurance to our
community and to our board that, you
know, we're going to go through a
process and and we will get there. Um,
so to the extent possible, I want to
include that in the plan. I know it's
important to to make that commitment.
Uh, so that's really what this part of
the conversation should be around.
>> Comments or thoughts?
>> I guess it's it's hard to provide
specific feedback because the map is
difficult to see when it's not in our
packet and I'm looking at it from the
screen. Um, this one and we have not had
the bet.
>> This one's in their packet.
>> Sorry, this one is in your packet. This
one.
>> Yeah, I I know, but the side by side
isn't. And so it's hard to evaluate what
the the changes are versus what was
>> uh initially proposed.
>> Um, and I will say unfortunately the
betichek uh engagement around this
proposal has not happened yet. It's not
proposed until next week. And so it's
difficult to operate on anything other
than what I've heard um directed to me.
Um I appreciate the reduction in the
splits. U there was a lot of concern
about Bichek going to you know five or
four different middle schools. Um, I
guess overall I'm still just concerned
about the the revisions to middle school
that are proposed in this plan and
whether or not they respond to
reservations that you see when you look
at the number of transfers that people
are requesting to go to different middle
schools across the city. Um, I also know
that we have
issues ini continuing uh in the dual
language track from elementary through
high school. And I know because I go to
the trustee awards every year at
Crockett and Akens that there are a lot
of students that are graduating with
their seals of biiteracy. And I also
have heard um
concerns about the ODM zoned
neighborhood families that are being
redirected towards Pleasant Hill um
due to what's going on with Sunset
Valley as Trusty Singh brought up
earlier. And so I I just um
wonder what the
potential is for responding to multiple
of those concerns in BetCh Middle
School. um to an opportunity for
creating a K8 alignment in South Austin
as 45 where Betitech is located is also
one of those hot uh spots for a lot of
emergent bilingual that reside in the
area. Um, and I, you know, you and I
were both at that Palm meeting the other
night and we heard from a father who's
at Palm and is going to be losing
Mendes, I mean losing Betachch, uh, and
is not choosing Mendes for other
reasons. And um,
yeah, just being directed away from from
that that campus. And when I look at the
reside population for Betachch versus
the amount that are attending the
school, there's a greater proportion of
the reside community that are choosing
Betachch. Um, and when I look at
Covington, where the majority of those
students are being redirected, there's a
much smaller reside population and
there's a much smaller number of that
reside population that are choosing to
go to Covington. And we're asking
Betachch families to cross William
Cannon almost all the way to Mopac to to
take their students to Covington. Um,
and so I'm just wondering long term what
the what the plan is uh and what
possible other programmatic misalignment
you can resolve uh through a repurposing
or reimagining of the betich uh campus.
Um yeah, I'll stop there.
>> I mean, do you want to
>> Yeah. And I'm going to probably toss to
Evette because our idea was along the
lines of expanding dual language, but
instead of prek um 8, we were thinking
more of a 612
um as that strand and then also
including Mandarin. I will say as we've
explored different options, that is
probably the best way to go
accountabilitywise.
Um but I'll let you talk about the need
for DL. Yeah, thank you so much. So, as
you've already mentioned, right, there's
a gap, especially we know the dual
language elementary campuses that are in
Southeast Austin, right? Bettis,
Langford, um, Houston, they only have
one really viable option because Mendes
does not offer dual language and so
that's Pedes. Fortunately, we have an an
agreement, right? and the students
currently in those campuses can choose
dual language at pararees. But it still
leaves like a a gap. It still leaves a
need. And as you were saying, trustee
Gonzalez, there are emergent bilingual
students, right, that could also benefit
from continuing dual language even after
they reclassify and become English
proficient towards their journey of um a
seal of biiteracy.
So that's where we started to talk about
the possibility of a 6 through 12 um
dual language campus um designing it. So
it's it's great to have the opportunity
to get your input on that.
Thank you. Other comments?
[laughter]
>> No, that's okay. I mean, this is very
general, but I just I think it's really
important at
Martin and at Betitech to consider the
preK8 option as a way of retaining our
kids going to middle school.
So just I I don't want to throw out the
idea especially around losing a
neighborhood school in the Martin
neighborhood. So I I appreciate the idea
you brought up, but I also want to keep
on the table the benefits of potentially
having a redesigned K through8 at both
of these schools.
So, um, one of the things that we're
going to have to consider, uh,
so this is great because I what what I
want to do is when we when we present to
the trustees the plan to be voted on, my
based on what I heard in the last couple
meetings, I want to have some certainty
around the direction we're going in
these schools so that our trustees are
comfortable and I can commit that we're
going to do this in this period of time,
right? And and that's not a universe of
op of ideas. it's these set but working
with community to ultimately get there.
Um the one thing I will will offer is
that in order to stabilize an EC8 it's
likely that another middle elementary
schools have to come offline right so
just to be clear like if we pursue an
EC8 at Betachch we're likely going to
have to pull off a campus at some point
in the future whenever that campus and
whenever that program comes together. Um
and so that's so my we don't know what
campus that'll be. can probably offer
what I think it would be. In this case,
it would probably be Pleasant Hill if it
was Betachch. Um,
but that I want to be really transparent
like that's what we'll end up doing
because the students have to come from
somewhere we need to see the program and
then go you K1 two three and then six
you know five and just build up or six
and then seven and four and then eight
and five. Uh so so as we move forward um
from this group uh sorry this group the
board of trustees I apologize. Uh what
would that be a um a thoughtful way to
approach the um the set of expectations
of the administration to move forward
through this process because in one if I
commit if I commit to EC8 I'm committing
to a timeline right that's 2728 at the
earliest um and and that means that
we're going to be having the
conversation around the students in the
area and in the time we'll plan with
community We'll improve the facility.
We'll probably get rid of all the
portables. We're going to take care of
betach. You know, we're going to do it
the right way. But that's how far out we
are, right, to get there. Um, and as
long as we're we're comfortable with
that process and that conversation, then
then we will continue down that path.
Um, Martin to me, you know, given we
would want to engage with community, but
being responsive to what we heard about
wanting to activate, I can kind of solve
for that in this plan. I don't know that
I have an easy way to solve for it at
Betachch without
doing something very very kind of unique
and I don't know what that would even be
at this point. Um but that's why I
wanted to offer it. Um Christy Gonzalez,
I don't know if you have any thoughts or
>> I guess when we initially began this
process, I was expecting
more of um an EC8 approach because
there's excess seats in middle school
and expecting that a closure of
elementary schools would wrap into and
lend itself towards a pivot to that
model. That's my own personal opinion.
Obviously, that's not the direction that
the draft proposal went in. Um, so
that's what I'll say. But if you're
saying that a 6 through 12 would not
create additional elementary seats uh
and provide better opportunity for
programmatic alignment vertically, then
that's what you're saying.
>> Well,
I think we we can we have the ability to
explore both. I just want to be I just
wanted to let you know that the
different things we were considering as
move forward to progress it because I I
I want to be able to offer what I know
we can execute and in the timeline that
I know we can execute it in and based on
the ECA model which we're we want to
introduce into the system. It cannot be
done um without the the planning
required. That's just the honest truth.
I I wouldn't be able to do it especially
if there are schools that exist that
have taps attied to them. So I have to
kind of clear all of these things at the
same time while progressing the model.
So I I to me it's part of this. It's
just a function of time. But what I want
to get to is a commitment to do it as
early as possible which is why this
conversation to me is so important
because if I on November 20th if it's we
don't know what's going to happen at
Betach I don't want to be there. What I
would prefer to say is this is the
expectation that we have for the
administration to do this work in this
sequence with the community in this
period of time because so that the
trustees have an understanding of what
we're going to do and how we're going to
work with the community to drive that
final solution and recommendation for
that specific site instead of leaving it
open-ended and then there's no
commitment, right? Like I don't want
that. It really needs to be a commitment
to do the work. um which is what I think
I heard from from you specifically about
like we need some more like detail
before we can take the next step. So
that's what I'm trying to get to drive
to.
>> I would say that's still true for me. Um
and the same thing with Martin and I
guess with the caveat that I would want
to know that those are directions that
both of those places are interested in
going in as well.
>> Yeah. And that's I think the challenge
is um like when we went to the Martin uh
committee meeting uh that Tristana was
out one of the things we heard is you
know because EC8 was even I think
proposed in at it wasn't proposed by us
at the time but it was said in the kind
of group and then there was another
community group uh that said well we
want to actually spend time and work to
think through what it would be or what
it wouldn't be and not just offer a
solution early. Um, so that I just so I
agree with you. We need a plan with
community, but I don't know that I could
get all the way there with all the steps
to a final recommendation that it still
wouldn't be implemented for two years
like in the time that we have. But I
want to create assurances that what we
will do and what we will explore and
create Martin I think is slightly
different because we do have a solution
that could be implemented sooner. Um,
better check something more complicated.
>> Okay, that's 15 minutes. This is my
district so I'm comfortable moving on.
And I would just say as we're thinking
about preK8 or 612, uh, you know, I know
we have a lot of things to balance. I
know we have a lot of some space at high
schools, too. And I know that some of
our, you know, our charters have been
very successful with that prek8 and
creating that continuity for families.
And I know that um that transition from
f 5th to sixth is when we lose
>> so many of our families. And I know
there's really good data out there that
shows that that can be a very successful
model for communities and and to have
that number of years together. Um when
children are young, you're building
those relationships, you're building
that community that then can follow
people when they do go to a high school.
Um I really um would love to explore
that with the community really
thoughtfully
um as we look not just in that
neighborhood but maybe in some of our
other areas as well. um where there is a
lot of mobility, there is a lot of you
know kind of break in in those
relationships. So we can try to add a
lot of that drop off from fifth to six.
So thank you.
>> Okay, next area we have 30 minutes left,
I understand. Is that the
>> two more?
>> 32 32 minutes left. Okay, we'll we'll
we'll get through the this one. I think
we some time. Um, so this Southwest
Austin, uh, this is, uh, the three-way
high school split at small middle
school. Uh, there's been lots of
conversations around this. Um, one of
the things that I, I I want to make sure
our trustees and our community know when
you look at the map, uh, is that, you
know, originally there was actually more
of a shift from the Travis um, country
community um, down to Crockett. Um
really that was a function of just
transportation
uh kind of um you know distance lots of
different things and so as we move
towards the October third deliver rule
we try to balance that in a better way
that created a three-way split at small
right and so as we've heard from
community there's been um you know a lot
of comments around the specific area it
is a complex area there's lots of things
kind of converging in this kind of
corner of Austin uh there are a couple
things that can and can't be done. So,
we want to kind of share with you, hey,
if we go this way, reduce a split, but
this is what you end up with as far as
utilization at both Crockett and Austin
High. If you don't do it, then you
remain here. And I think that's just the
the question that we have to just pose
as a as a group and say, are are we
okay? And I think we we are kind of
adjusting and creating, you know, this
um just creating adjustments whenever
there's like two things in conflict with
one another, right? number of splits as
well as you know utilization target like
those are both you know guiding princ
guiding goals of the work but it's
complex you can't everything can't be
done together [snorts] necessarily so um
do you want to just kind of walk us
through very briefly or quickly
>> yeah so what you see in the image is
high school the colors reflect the high
school boundaries that were proposed on
the third what you see is the numbers
are the parts of small that split so we
of into Buoie into Austin High and into
Crockett. The what you see here it was
really driven by utilization at the high
school level. So as you all know we have
a lot of disparity between how many kids
are in each of our high school school
zones versus the size of each campus and
that was part of our effort in this was
balancing that. So what you do see here
would put Austin high at 89% and
Covington or [snorts] sorry Crockett
rather at um 83.
Um the reverse to where
you know if we were to put this area
back
at or sorry where the three is back at
Austin it would bring that up to 105 or
106 around there and then Crockett would
be down to 67. So that's the difference
that we would see because it's a small
area but it's very dense of students. So
it's quite impactful to the overall
number of students assigned to Crockett
>> and this is for utilization. So 106%
utilized versus Crockett at 677%
>> correct? So that would and that's based
on who just lives in that zone. So if
every student who went who lives in the
Austin High boundary went to Austin High
in this scenario, it would be 89% full.
The inverse if we did resolve the split
in that way um would be 105
to 106 depending on this little yellow
area here. And and I think one one thing
to um in both in both scenarios uh
Crockett does see an increase. I think
it's important to know like it you know
even though it it's 106 versus 67 67 is
still an increase from where it is
currently as far as livein um enroll
sorry live in reside attendance.
>> Okay. And Crockett also has a
significant transfer in rate right?
>> I don't know what the number pull the
number up. I do have
>> the number.
>> Okay.
>> Um
>> 33%.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you point to that little yellow area
that you're referring to?
>> Well, I'm really So there's this is
where the feathering that you'll hear us
talk about comes into play. So there's
also down at the elementary level of the
cake layer cake. I'm going to make me
hungry. I want some some sweets after
this. Um is Boone Elementary. And that I
know is one that we we heard a lot from
those communities. But Boon was one that
was very its boundary was very small
compared to the size of its school. So
it was one that we needed to increase
and the location of these
elementaryaries to one another as well
as the respective which ones are too
full and which ones are too empty. We
were limited in options and how to
actually move boundaries to make them
more balanced. And so this is one to
where if we were to make this change if
we didn't want to then introduce more
splits at the elementary level. This is
that yellow line I was talking about. So
if you look here underneath and actually
here I'll pull up this map because it
allows us to kind of look in at all
different levels um and we can kind of
explore different options. So this is
what I was referring to. It's aligned at
Boone up to Covington. And so this now
becomes the boundary between Covington
and Small Middle School.
>> [snorts]
>> And so if this area here was reassigned
back to Austin, so not the whole thing,
but this area, that is what would put
Austin high at 106. So if we were to
also reassign
the entire kind of triangle, and I don't
know why the colors go away if I zoom in
too much, it would be even higher than
that and it would put Crockett even
lower.
>> And this is south of 290,
>> correct?
>> So So this is the the Becca Village,
Western. Thank you. And western oak.
That's the area you're talking about is
that right? Okay.
>> Right. So I did not include them in that
106 figure. So Austin would be even
higher if we put them back at Austin as
well.
>> If we put them back as well.
>> Correct. There is also we could there
another one to explore as you see here
in this hatched area is the former
O'Henry boundary. If that was reinstated
it would increase O'Henry because we
have added on and there's been other
changes made to a line in that part of
Austin. So that would further reduce
Smalls reside but it would resolve the
split. Um and I think I have those
numbers. So that would bring Henry oh
Henry up to 95% and it would reduce
small down to 71. But this would also
introduce more the same transportation
challenges we have now which is just one
of the big drivers in the proposed
change in the first place.
>> Just getting north to the river.
>> Correct. And and what I would say about
this is I know the community has um kind
of in that whole region come together a
lot and there are a lot of people who
are traveling farther to schools. Um a
lot of neighborhoods that feel like they
operate as a unit that are being split
up. Um there there's a whole lot of
complexity there. And I know those
neighborhoods have a lot of them have
come together to make proposals and
suggestions. And I know there also a lot
of neighborhoods. I was in um Barton
View and there's a single middle
schooler in that neighborhood who's
getting sent to another place away from
her other friends in the neighborhood.
So I know and I know that um Becket
Meadows and Western Oaks are fairly
small populations. So, I think there's I
don't think I can fully process what I'm
seeing on the map, but I do feel like
this is an area where I think a lot of
people feel like they were moved around
kind of swapping one group for another
without a lot of returns. So, I would
just love for that whole area to really
be considered and for the the
information that families have brought
to be thought about. And I, you know, I
think it's a something similar that
we're seeing in some other neighborhoods
where people have been moved from one to
another and and they've put a lot of
time and thought into other ideas.
>> Thank you. That's exactly
>> and I would really love for some of that
to be looked at. And I think the splits
it, you know, I I would love to see that
split resolved. And I know there are a
handful of areas who feel like they're
splitting, moving, splitting, moving uh
much more than some others. Yeah, I will
[snorts] say since it is in the board
docs and on the appendix that we went
through the Barton View is a part of
Austin or maybe that is an area that we
have looked at and it is such a small
number that that is an area that does
not move the percentage either way on
the high schools. So, it's one that we
are able to recommend
reverting or changing from the previous.
I will say there are much more students
in the Becket Meadows area. So it's not
I would not necessarily equate those
because we it does move the capacity
substantially between either school.
>> Yeah.
>> I
>> or utilization. Sorry.
>> I would just say I I hear the concerns
around transportation and the increased
travel time. I would just caution that
what gives specific transportation
concerns more weight than others. My
particular neighborhood was zoned away
from Akens and into Crockett and it's
I'm significantly closer to Akens than I
am to Crockett. I'm just saying it's it
could be a slippery slope if we start to
consider every single transportation
ramification out of the plant.
>> This one, and I'll have you chime in,
Christine, if there's more detail, but
this really had to do with our bus
system and the cost. So, it's not just
travel time, but the distance that we
have to travel. we're not able to
actually use the same bus for different
routes. It actually requires additional
buses. So any students that were able to
not have to make that distance will
reduce the number of buses we require as
a district. So I will agree this so this
is different than just travel time.
>> Yeah. And also just travel time in the
bus.
>> Yeah.
>> For students.
>> So I think this one is representative of
a lot of the concerns coming out of
Southwest Austin. in southwest Austin I
think is unique in this plan because of
the the accountability status of schools
the the capacity of schools I think
there's less sense of what are we trying
to solve for by the community right and
so the the thing that is mostly being
solved for is balancing utilization of
schools but I think it would be helpful
to pin more specific impacts on that by
doing this this would not allow us to
remove portables from this school by
provide the programming needed at this
school. Um because I think in some ways
it looks again like we're just saying
these two things need to be closer to
the same size rather than we're trying
to solve for a problem. And since
overall this plan doesn't result in
every elementary school having 500 kids,
right? It doesn't result in every middle
school having the same number of kids,
which that I could see as a solution to
something because that would be saying
we now can provide the same staffing at
each school. We can provide the same
course offerings at every school. we can
provide the same extracurriculars
because we don't have a 3,000 person
school and a 200 person school. But when
we're just saying let's balance the
numbers some I don't think people feel
the benefit of their sacrifice. So this
is one example of that I think so if you
could pin some more specific things are
we solving for a problem at Crockett by
doing this. are we solving for a problem
with utilization at Austin rather than
you mean more than just the percentage?
And so I think that is kind of what I'm
hearing. I I hear a lot from communities
that they understand and are willing to
make sacrifices to achieve a better
outcomes for kids throughout the
community. But when it what I think a
lot of people are telling me, they feel
like it's just we're trying to say we're
not going to concentrate the pain of
this plan on one on the traditionally
marginalized neighborhoods. Therefore,
we're going to just move you around so
that you feel the pain. Also, I don't
believe that's what we're trying to do
in this plan. But that's what it feels
like when we're not pinning specific
things saying by changing this we're
going to improve the situation at this
school because we're not going to be
able to pull portables out or we're
going to be able to solve the problem at
this school because now we can provide
more rich course offerings or whatever.
So, that's what I would just say on
this. I think then I would echo Lynn's
points around just really um
I think there's a lot of good data and
information being provided by
neighborhood groups and I just really
want to ensure my commitment to them is
that that that will be considered and
looked at. Not that things will change
necessarily, but that their their
concerns will be heard.
>> Thank you. Yeah, I feel like this one
just uh it's so complex. I would love
another kind of just to make sure it's
looked at and really responded to.
>> Thank you.
>> I would appreciate I mean I definitely
would like a sit down um just to look at
you perhaps with
>> that would be great to look at some of
these particular neighborhoods that are
being impacted to get more
>> or oneonone.
>> Thank you.
>> Trusty Singh. Yes. And then Trusty
Hunter has and then Trusty Hunter has
Oh,
>> when you finish
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. I was just going to second that. I
did have a quick question and you may
have said it and I missed it. Um, but if
you I I appreciate understanding better
the ramifications of the high school if
the if those two patent neighborhoods
get moved to Boone. Um, if we kept the
patent kids at Patton
um like they are currently, that
wouldn't o overpop populate that school,
right?
Patton did receive students from Oak
Hill which was too full and so that and
that is a portable situation that they
are having to use portables and so that
is a campus Oakill Elementary moving to
Patton and then
>> Oak Hill with the new building has
portables.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Because that the
>> it's a partial modernization.
>> Yeah. It was a it was remember um the
open space concept. It wasn't a square
footage improvement.
>> Yeah. I know not new but yeah the new
construction still. [clears throat]
Okay.
>> What is the capacity going to be at Oak
what is the capacity at Oakill? The um
the reside population
going to like what
what is the actual numbers I guess?
>> Oh it's going to make me
>> okay it's going to break my computer. Um
620 is the capacity at Oakill. Thank
you.
>> Okay. And the projected reside is 695.
>> Projected reside is 695. Okay.
All right. Yeah,
>> that's helpful. Okay. So, so by moving
these two neighborhoods out of Patton,
it would help and and moving the covered
bridge into Patton, it really it's
really to help Oakill.
>> Oakill and Boone. And Patton is in
between the two.
>> Okay. [snorts] And we do have a lot of
dual language students that get transfer
that get transported to Oakhill. So I
bet that could speak more to that, but
we do have a lot of dual language
students at Oakhill.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> That will be fair.
>> And just to be clear when you say that
you're talking about students who are
emerging bilingual students who are Yes.
>> not provided a program at their school.
Therefore, they're provided free
transportation to be enrolled in a dual
language program at Oakill.
>> Yes, that is correct.
>> Yeah. I think it's really important
because I think we there there continues
to be a mystique around dual language
being a boutique program for rich white
families, but we want to make sure we're
making that distinction.
>> Okay. So, um sounds like the action is
for
perhaps a one-on-one conversation with
or two
>> I will figure it out. I will figure it
out. some kind of more detailed
conversation because it's a very complex
situation. Thank you.
>> The one thing I I just
>> Yes. And we will do that. But um and I
took Trusty Kaufman to your comment
around all the different things. I think
it's important to know that that's not
the purpose. We don't want to disrupt to
for the sake of disruption. I would
that's not worth it.
>> I think we need to understand fully what
it is other than that.
>> No. No. And but I also um uh want to
just kind of like anytime we can make an
adjustment back or refine it or figure
out a solution, we are and you'll see
that in the as the plan continues on. Um
the other thing is just philosophically
when it comes to what do you lose or
what do you gain by some of these shifts
you know like Crockett going down to 67%
it's still greater than it is now but
when we talk about offerings of larger
comprehensive high schools when you
don't get to a larger student population
those offerings don't exist. So to go
and say you're not going to get this.
It's really, you know, you don't have
this now, you will not have the
opportunity to get it. Not so, so it's
just, you know, and again, it's still an
improvement, but it's not as simple as
saying, you know, because of this now,
all of a sudden this will change. It it
can sometimes be a little more complex.
Um but I can try to like talk about some
of the benefits of these changes area by
area opposed to um
>> and just to clarify the current reside
utilization of Crockett is actually 67.
So this doesn't move the needle for
Crockett. It does the whole plan does
move the needle for Akens. It moves the
needle for other schools, but Crockett
in this instance, while there are moves,
it still ends up being the same
utilization if we were to send that
portion out of Crockett.
>> Okay.
>> I think it'll help to kind of sit and
look at the whole thing together. So,
thank you for that. Appreciate that.
>> Last one.
>> All right. We are now going to talk
about um Breer Woods. This is one in
which we have spent a lot of time doing
more. There's two factors that are
leading to this potential change for us
to discuss. So, this is one that very
much um want to hear feedback from you
all and we are meeting with this campus
tomorrow. Um we heard that transfer
students want to remain with their
peers. There was room in the October 3rd
plan to fit all of the reside Berwood
students. There would not be room to fit
the transfer students. So, we've been
working with space planning, looking at
the floor plans of Cassiss and
Brentwood, the other schools that are
adjacent to Breerwoods, and that is
really what has driven a potential
scenario to share with you all today and
get feedback on. Um, we've also heard
feedback about the UT housing being very
core to Matthews Elementary. Um, and
we've also heard feedback from
Brekerwood's families about just asking
questions about proximity and why it was
Matthews versus Cassiss or Brentwood
depending on where they were. So, we do
feel like this does respond to a lot of
those. The the flip side of that is
before we were trying to, you know, keep
Breaker Woods together as we've kind of
iterated. That was always our first goal
was to keep a community together, at
least the reside population. So, this
does split that. It's a pretty health
like it's a bigger split. You're not
sending just three kids to one school.
It's 80 to these are all kind of
approximate but about 80 kids to
Brentwood and 136 would be reassigned to
Cassiss and then there would be room at
either school for those transfer
students to choose which one and stay
with some of their peers. So this is
just a kind of a another proposal for
y'all to consider.
>> Okay. Um, I would love to have the
opportunity to hear from Breakerwood
specifically about this tomorrow since
we're meeting with them and this is a
change um to what has been proposed. So,
I I think it would be I would love to
hear what the community has to say about
this. And I know, you know, asking for
ABC, good, better, best. Um, you know,
this wouldn't be the first choice for
the Breakerwoods community, but I do
think um it would be valuable to hear
from people about this. And I know that
I've, you know, sat down and met with a
lot of the transfer families who were
really upset. And I know the
um the excess of seats is a whole lot
less in this area than it is in many
other areas. And so I know there was um
people were upset about that. So I I
think that's important to understand. Um
and I also think as we look at it, you
know, the Oveta Rosedale, the affordable
housing community that's going in 70
units at 30, 50, 60% MFI, there's 60, it
is being marketed as a family-friendly
unit. They've got high quality prek on
site. Um, they're going to be 65
non-primary bedrooms at 30, 50, 60% MFI.
And I am concerned. I know our [snorts]
demographer estimated 12 students. It's
not in our main demographic report that
I can see, but I'm really worried that
there's going there going to be
significantly more students in the
neighborhood. It's the first affordable
housing in in council district 10. I'm
really excited to see it. And then I
know that we've also seen kindergarten
enrollment at Brekerwoods really spike.
um you know 20 more 21 more students
from two years ago, 11 more than one
year ago and just want to be sure we're
not creating other problems. So I think
it'll be um I'll be interested to hear
what the community has to say about it
tomorrow.
>> And then I have I have questions about
what alternatives can be explored
instead of closing Berwoods.
uh trusty will. So kind of what we
talked about um kind of north of the
river with Zeala Sanchez, you know,
Ortega and Go Valley, we we look at
things in areas and we say, okay, you
know, h how do we address a goal in an
area? Um excess seeds, speeder pattern
alignment, programmatic alignment. And
then we kind of take the available
information and and we kind of make
adjustments, make adjustments, and then
refine, refine, refine, and get to um a
plan. So, this this map here is kind of
a zoomed out a little bit. It's probably
a little more zoomed out than it needs
to be, honestly. Probably don't need to
go all the way to past the river, but um
you know,
when it comes to the area, there's lots
of movement already occurring. You have
Richtop. Uh there's Riley. Um we talked
about the sixth grade at Matthews. Maybe
we haven't talked about the sixth grade
at Matthews and Lee and some of the
changes. So, you know, we are going to
have to pull seats out of this area.
Like I mean that that that is one of the
things that we would like to have
considered or be part of the plan. So
the question becomes like what other
opportunities exist um in this area to
find
those those available seats. Um that
that's the process we would go through.
Uh I will tell you like when we when
we're going through this there are lots
of different ideas. Um you know some of
them include schools that are adjacent
um some a little further away. Um, you
know, we're so what to date what we've
been responding to is feedback from the
community around how to improve like the
movement of students. Um,
you know, so that that's kind of the
approach that we would take if if that
was
something.
Yeah, I would I would like to see a a
plan that that has an alternative to to
closing Berwoods
because I don't see the financial
benefit to closing Berwoods.
And if there's, you know, it's one
that's not wrapped up in a tap. It's one
that is not part of a wall-to-wall
change.
And so I'd like to see,
you know, see what alternatives there
are.
>> Are there any alternatives like
I'm just curious like yay all spaces I'm
not.
>> So I think one of the things you run
into is um
you know an alternative would require a
the closure or like leave another school
which is why I'm hesitant to just kind
of offer without like kind of spending
the like I that's that's what I would we
would have to figure out. Okay. Well I
don't want to just say a school name
without really thinking through what it
could look like. Um if that was the if
that's like you know you know if we were
to do that you know we would look at
where either disruption was already
occurring or like how net over the area
you can pull out the number of seats to
get to um the same goal because I mean
at the end of the day balanced
enrollment was one of the goals of the
overall effort. Um you know we do have
Ridgetop closing to the north. um
Riley's going through a disruption and
then you know remaining open
um you know Gallette boundary didn't
really change right
um so it would have to whatever the
solution would be it would have to be
like another
closure elsewhere um kind of in the area
but I would be hesitant to just like
offer a school because we looked at lots
of different ways to do it um you know
west to east we looked at just different
opportunities, solutions.
Um, you know, I think it would be a
pretty it would be lots of boundary
moves to find a solution that worked.
Um, but I think we could, you know, if
that was the ask, I mean, we we will do
the work. Um, it just it I think it's
likely to get um,
you know, kind of more elaborate when it
comes to the boundaries to to solve for
it if that makes any sense. Yeah,
exploring it would really be which again
anything is possible. We can explore it.
It would involve a substantial redraw of
kind of all of central Austin which
would then affect our middle school
boundaries and our high school
boundaries. So if we were to go down
that path, it would just be a very
different plan to then discuss
um much more.
>> I think one question I have is you had
mentioned President Boswell affordable
housing
Has that population been included in the
enroll projection?
>> That one is listed in there is a chart
in the demographic report that lists
that it's not directly included and
that's why you don't see the 12. But if
you look at the typical yield that we
see of that type of unit, 80 units would
yield about 12 students. And this is
something where I am not the dem
demographer, but when we've spoken with
them, yeah, I know Christine, you took
some
>> Yeah, we did. We did speak with her. We
double checked about this and she did
say that um they've double checked the
timelines with the development and uh
she has a lot of they have a lot of
confidence in the projections also with
the declining birth rate. Um she's seen
significant experience in just different
states um and that the developments
don't offset the declining birth rates
and a lot of the times that they're
deemed affordable. it's not necessarily
the affordable that many families are
truly needing. Um, so it's a major
factor tempering in an estimated student
yield for new housing. So if it's
anything ever miscalculated or there's
something that they don't, we still have
the flexibility within the schools to
receive more students.
>> Yep, that's correct. Like in this
proposal for example, there is Matthews
would be their utilization based on
reside is still low. So there would be
plenty of room to explore in the future
if we do see which would that would be a
wonderful thing to have to do, right? We
get way more students than we're
expecting. We do have space in this part
of town to redraw boundaries as part of
our regular boundary review that we are
planning to start doing.
>> There are three edges of boundary.
>> Correct. And I would say I've spent a
lot of time with this and the Grove is
one of the only, it's a dense multi-use
development that's one of the only areas
in central Austin that's actually adding
a bunch of new housing and a bunch more
still to come online that has a bunch of
young families and and this um I've
talked to several affordable housing
people about the the development that is
going in. It's 70 units. It is deeply
affordable. All but one of the two and
threebedroom units are 30, 50, and 60%
um MFI. So, it is deeply affordable. And
there's 65 non primary bedrooms. Um 49
two and threebedroom units. So, there's
65 non-primary bedrooms total in the
development. Um those in in our area, I
think what people are telling me is
there are no comparables because nothing
like this has ever been made in our
area. District 10 has been very slow to
get affordable housing and people are
very excited this is going in. It has
been marketed as close to schools and
there's high quality prek onsite. They
are expecting families
and you know a lot of the apartments in
my neighborhood 100% you have a
two-bedroom apartment. It's a second
office. You know it's an office. It's a
a workout room. It's something else. But
if you have, you know, if if you qualify
for a 30% 50, 60% MFI, there will be
people living in those bedrooms. And I
think I just want to be sure we're not
setting ourselves up for a different
problem by closing something in an area
that actually is growing. So, thank you.
>> And so, my answer is yes. I would I
would like to see that an alternative
plan. um this is something that's going
to affect our entire district for the
rest of our lives. So, so yes, I I would
like to see an alternative to closing a
well-enrolled school.
>> President Boswell.
>> Well, I think while we're talking about
closing well-enrolled schools, I'd like
to see an alternative plan for Palm
Elementary. Um they have a higher
enrollment. they have um a good
accountability rating. Um
they I just I just worry about taking
schools off and on the list like you
have cautioned us to do. Um to make
exceptions for one school over another
because
what you know what gives one school more
weight than another? I'm supportive of
seeing an alternative plan for Palm
Elementary.
>> Then we have to talk about other schools
to close. And so that would be putting,
you know, another community
on a very tight timeline between now and
November 20th to have these
conversations.
So, kind of framing this on the on the
other end, a question that I've had that
I don't think maybe maybe this is a time
that we could discuss a little bit, but
from when we were first planning or
first con conceptualizing this like you
know end of the spring going into the
summer um you know the numbers I
remember were 85% to 95% occupancy you
know for the healthy district and this
plan doesn't get us that far into
Um I think my memory might be off but
from that discussion I I thought we
talked about trying to target 90%.
And which just for in the context of the
proposal you know why
I'm trying to think the right way to
frame this. We're we're not hitting that
number and I know you all have done a
lot of planning. You have you know
there's more that comes after this piece
of the puzzle. So to put it like
inelegantly, why are we not closing more
schools? Why is that not the proposal?
Why do you think this is sufficient
enough [snorts] to hit, you know, 82 83%
occupancy um since since for the larger
discussion?
>> No, I think that's a that's a great
question and and that's why there
there are lots of goals that we set out,
right? This plan also doesn't have two
feeder patterns per no more than one
split per elementary school, middle
school, right? I mean, we attempted to
get there. We got close but we couldn't
achieve it right. I mean you talked
about the split that we just small was
one um you know if we introduced another
one you know we we really were trying to
um identify what moves the system but
also doesn't break the system. I mean I
think that's like a way that I would
describe it. You know we haven't made
hard decisions in in quite a while. Like
these boundaries should be revisited
every four years, every five years. We
don't do that. Haven't done in a very
long time. we don't really, you know,
assess programming in a way that would
give us the ability to make pretty
significant changes. And now we're
talking about just in the beginning of
this meeting, pretty significant
changes, you know, and we're talking
about them only now because we've got
into the weeds of it, the details of it.
Um, and so my fear is that
um is that we don't get through this
process together. And together to me is
very very important because this
organization is going to continue on.
it's going to thrive 5 10 15 20 years.
So we need to make a substantial
significant move in the right direction.
Um but we're also going to be here in
three years, four years, 5 years, right?
To refine and improve and find and
improve. Um so so the goals were goals.
I I I I wish I there was an easy way to
find efficiencies without creating more
disruption. I think we're at that kind
of like really sensitive point already
where more disruption could potentially
make it to where it doesn't go anywhere
or you know you really begin to see us
move in the in the wrong direction and
and not ever get anything done like the
vote doesn't happen you know the plan
doesn't occur like that that's kind of
where I feel our threshold is at this
moment my hope is that we have a
successful vote whatever that vote looks
like and then we can take some of the
energy and the pressure off the system,
move towards getting to a vibrant,
balanced, well-resourced school school
district. Um, so do I wish there were
other schools that were easily
identified? Yes. Do I wish there were
easier ways to align feeder patterns?
Yes. Do I wish there were easier ways
to, you know, um, move programming to
ensure viability for the next 15, 20
years? Yes. It's just there's so many
things competing at the exact same time.
Um, so that's that's what I I would say
about it is this, you know, I I I don't
I don't know that I could give more
without really introducing like pain
that I don't know is recoverable is
maybe the way I would say it as a
system. Um, but we're g this is not
going to end. Like we have to continue
on. If we do this and then in five years
just don't look at boundaries again and
then five years that look at boundaries
again, then we're setting ourselves up
for failure, you know, here in 10, 15,
20 years. like it that's not a good way
or an elegant way to answer your
question, but that's why I think we've
gone as far as we can in this iteration
of it. Um I think more is is really
difficult with the time that we have. Um
that's just my honest perspective on it.
I I appreciate that answer and you know
I think as much as we've gotten into
discussion about budget and we've gotten
into discussion about um accountability
which realistically I think is is how
well are we serving students and stuff.
Uh I think what I'm hearing is about
system stability which has been kind of
an undertone through all of the
discussion that we've been having. Um so
I appreciate that in the context of of
you know your
administrative you know judgment on on
where you think the threshold is on how
much system stability we can maintain
through you know these changes and so as
we get into this you know these
refinements on this and the community
discussion piece and you know I do think
that is a very valid through line to be
looking at. I mean, I think that's what
the families are talking about when
they're saying, "Oh, we're going to lose
students or people are going to leave if
they're not happy about this." You know,
that that's also long-term stability. I
think also, um, very an elegant term
again, but like horse trading on which
schools are are bearing the brunt of
things. Um, you know, that also is a
system stability question. you know,
even you know, Go Valley versus VA and
looking now you you have historical
elements versus modernized elements and
you know, commitments to communities.
Um, you know, I think ultimately that
system stability piece is going to be
based on what the community can
tolerate. And um and so that's that's
one of the ones I think being a very new
board member uh you know cautioning us
on on our understanding of the
community's tolerance because I think
we're getting feedback from the
community. It I I am hesitant to
overestimate how much the community is
going to tolerate as far as that system
stress. And um I don't know that I have
a a real firm solution or answer on any
of that part. Um you know I hope the
community's understanding in this
meeting looking at the discussions we're
having how much we are considering that
piece. Um I I really hope that we can
get into more of the long-term
conversations about what happens after
this. Um because you know this needs to
lead to other things and I think you
know President Boswell was alluding to
you know there's still going to be
conversations in the spring when we get
into the budget talk. And so I hope as
much as people are paying attention now
that we can foster that into two-way
engagement so that there is back and
forth on it. Um because these are really
tough decisions we're making now and
it's it's just only going to lead into
more. But I think what pulls the
community in is seeing that this is
going to lead to stronger outcomes in
the system. So I I I do believe in that
guiding principle of like the stability
is going to allow us to build into
things. Um it just gets really nebulous
when we're at this point in the
conversation.
>> So I'm going to make a brief comment. Um
one of the things that we as a district
I don't want to say this the wrong way
because I don't want people to to to
feel a certain way but but
implementation is where sometimes we
fail. Right? We just talked about it at
Monasuri. Um, there are lots of great
plans this district's had for the last
20, 30 years. Um, and what I don't want
to do is fail in implementation.
Like to me, like it's critically
important that we are thoughtful, we're
responsive, there are we're built up
organically and I know for certain I can
execute these plans and deliver to our
community, right? And ensure that our
students are successful starting the
2627 27 28 school year and so on. So, so
that's why for me um the timelines
matter. Uh if if there's a conversation
to be had around what um an adjustment
looks like, you know, the we need time
to plan in certain areas, but what you
don't want to deliberate is the action,
right? Because it
>> So, I hear you, but it's not our fault
that we don't have any time. we were
just given this plan and so now it's
kind of being saying like oh well but
the plan can't change because there's
not time. So President Boswell would you
like to see an alternative plan to
closing Riker Woods? Would you like the
administration to provide that or
>> I'm open to see a plan and I also I know
it's going to take an immense amount of
work and you know what I've said to the
breaker roads community is that any
change needs five votes and I don't know
if there are five votes in the room to
do that. We're not going to count votes
here. I know we're not going to do that.
Um conscious that it would be you know
it's going to take a lot of work and I'm
I'm absolutely open to seeing that
because I do have real concerns. um
knowing the neighborhood well that we
are going to create one problem by doing
that and that there isn't a real glut of
seats in the area. Um but I also know
that means something really hard and
horrible and difficult for another
community and and I'm very conscious of
that. Um
so you know and I know we're we're
working to to take care of a whole
system. Um, and I've been really
transparent about that with the
Breakerwoods community from the
beginning and some people have been very
unhappy with me about that. Um, so I am
absolutely open to seeing that
completely. Um, and if the will of all
of our colleagues is that that is not a
good use of the administration's time,
I'm really open to hearing that as well.
How many schools need to be restarted
with a new principal, new staff under
this closure plan?
>> Um, like can you name them and I'll
>> Yeah.
>> Um, I'm I'm going to start. So, restart.
I'm I'm going to be really precise in my
response only because some of them are
taps, some of them are program. I mean,
there's there's a lot.
>> And then you could say tap or something.
Yeah.
>> Um,
>> four restarts. Okay, that was the easy
answer.
>> What? Which which ones?
>> Uh, so
>> Pan Springs.
>> Uhuh.
>> Lind
>> Linder
Riley.
Um, as a function of a, you know, a
programmatic move there. There's going
to be a shift there. Pretty
kind of in a slightly different way, but
Parees. What's the other one?
Waldridge.
>> Okay.
And then the other ones that the
closures we already
>> And are any of those restarts not tied
to TAP plans and we're just restarting
them because
>> Riley is the only one.
>> Riley. Which one's the one? Just Riley.
>> That's it. Just Riley.
>> Okay. So, we're going to close a We're
going to close a school and then what?
So what are we what's the plan for Riley
>> to make that
>> Riley is the wall to wall dual language
program
>> they made it a wall towall dual language
program to make it a desirable school
and it has become one but now that's
moving
>> so what's the plan for Riley
>> yeah so the plan for Riley is for the
Riley program the Walto Dage program to
move to Wooten Elementary School um and
then for the Riley
campus the site to convert into a
neighborhood school
>> for for the Yeah. For the or the area.
Yes. For the area that's adjacent, which
is southeast to Richtop, which is
Ridgetop is closing. The program is
moving and going to pickle, but Richtop
is closing and not returning to a
neighborhood school.
>> And what percentage of students transfer
out of ridgetop? What percentage of
students currently transfer out of
Riley?
>> Yep. I have to pull those up real quick.
Trusty, I don't have Let me get my
binder, too.
>> I threw it back over here.
>> I have 37% of students transfer out of
Riley and so
and most of those transfer to Brentwood
or Berwoods.
Ridgetop 28% most of them transfer to
Lee or Berwoods.
It's like how many students would we
expect to be at Riley next year? Like
how would we know who to hire?
Oh, like um the projected reside I mean
what do you want to I don't know she
show
>> the well and I think I mean there is an
element of this and if Victoria needs to
come up and clarify but that is why we
are working with our principles to get
folks to tell us early where they plan
to enroll is to have more clarity
because we do have estimates on the
reside projections and who lives there.
But we also know that those families, as
do really all our families, but they
have they have choice. And so I think
for all of our schools, we know that
there is choice in all of this. So we're
taking very intentional efforts to work
with our principles and our different
parental supports to make sure that
families understand how important it is
to tell us where they want to go next
year as soon as possible. And so that's
another effort. So it's hard to give an
exact number. We are doing a lot of
space planning to look at kind of both
ends of the spectrum and make and really
more concerned about not having enough
space. [clears throat] So that is what
we are solving for. Um
>> so what's the what's the
>> the total reside together
would be
>> I don't have a Mac. I don't know how to
do that combine like Adam.
>> Yeah. So there's 386 students that now
live in the new Oh well part of Riley
was reassigned. So that that data is in
the redistricting report that is posted
to the website.
>> So Trusty Wichu, would you be suggesting
that Ridgetop could move to Berwoods,
that Riley could move to Brentwood?
>> So I would like to see plans that the
community supports. I'd like
>> I'd like us to ask people where they
would like to go
>> down to Riley
>> for any plan for any plan that we're
doing
>> and if we're closing a school I' I'd
like to see why that that is going to be
better for the district for any plan
that we're doing.
>> There's 314 students projected to live
in the new Riley school zone in 2627. I
say that has nothing to do with how many
students are going to go there next
year.
>> Correct. Which is why I kind of gave a
two long answer to when you asked.
>> So I guess that's that's
a concern with the plan is, you know,
restarting a school that was functioning
very very well
um with kind of no plan to restart, not
knowing how that's going to be. And
we're also having to do restarts that if
they don't go correctly, we'll get our
entire district taken over. So that it
just seems like a lot of effort to do
that. Well, so I am either concerned I'm
concerned that either it won't be done
well or because there's not the capacity
to do it or we're going to be taking
away from a restart that is required by
TEA. So those are my concerns. I'd like
to see all the options. I'd like to see
what saves money. Um, I want us to to
get to make a plan. And again, it's it's
not any of our fault that we're just now
getting a plan. And, you know, I I do
feel like I do I am concerned that we're
getting it very last minute, so there
can't be any changes to it.
And and it's, you know, I live in North
Austin. That's the area I know well. And
yeah, I'd like I'd like people to have
options.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm super um
I'm always proud of Austinites. Um and
sometimes I'm not proud of us in all of
our moments. I'm not always proud of
myself in all of my moments, but um
the the families, the many many many
many families I I've spoken to, um
the the Riley community has has really
been amazing. Ridgetop has really been
all the communities have been amazing.
Um, one of the things that the Riley
uh, parents asked me in overwhelming
numbers um, was about Mandarin Chinese
going to Wooten and I saw in the
adjustments that that um, was there. Um,
another thing that Riley families are
asking for, that is to say, the Riley
folks who are going to be the new Riley
folks, which is current Riley folks who
are like, you know what, we're going to
stay. We're not going to go to Wooten.
We're going to stay. And then ridgetop
families who are like now part of the
new imagined Riley. Uh, one of the thing
and the the the beauty and graciousness
is like borderline overwhelming. What
families have said is let's focus on
getting Wooten right but or and please
don't forget about us. We're going to be
a neighborhood school and we don't want
to be kind of lost in the shuffle as we
pay really good close attention to what
happens at the new pickle at the new
Wooten etc. So, I would definitely share
an ask in um when we get to that
academic piece um really with some
specificity leaning into
um a Riley, a neighborhood school. You
know, the these schools, well, all of
our schools are just so important and
this just being one of them. It doesn't
get lost in the shuffle. Um so, I just
want to kind of add that piece into uh I
guess the equation. it's already there,
but make it explicit. Uh, and that sort
of goes along with Trusty Whitley Chu's
point. Um, at the same time, I do not
have a particular appetite.
The way I view this plan and the way
I've spoken to community members about
it and the way they've spoken to me
about it, um, is good bones, good start.
Now, it's time for version two. and that
version two is building on the bones and
that there might be substantive
uh I don't want to say tweaks but
substantive
alterations adjustments
but not taking the fundamental step back
to a different list of closures or take
these off or take those off that sort of
thing. So, I guess I would say I do not
have an appetite for a big switcheroo.
Um, I would have an appetite for what I
see you all doing and what I think
you're getting consistently proud to do
even more of, which is leaning in with
specificity, creating greater detail,
creating adjustments where necessary,
but keeping this moving forward. Um,
that's that's where I am.
Um, first of all, I want to apologize.
Um, I'm going to express a little
pertibbation, but also this is 100% on
me. As I began flipping through this
chart, I'm like, where's Maplewood?
Where is where is Bington? And Arthy
says, did you answer the email? What
email?
And so I go and I did find that email.
And um the perturbation is with myself
for like I'm getting 50 million emails.
So in the future if like you don't hear
from me. This is East Austin. Four of my
schools are on the closure list. You
didn't hear from me. You should probably
call me and see if I'm okay because it
means I either didn't get it or I
probably died or something like that. I
mean because that would be the only
other reason that that happened. And I
have I have abundant apologies for uh
the three communities which I had
planned on which I am going to take 5
seconds supposed to start the timer. Um
>> and that's all me trust. I I was trying
to keep up with all the movement and
feedback and build the agenda with the
so
>> and I'm not sure that we would have had
an opportunity to fully cover what needs
to be covered but I I said that I was
going to share with the board and so I'm
going to do that. The Bington community
feels unheard. They feel unseen and they
are going to need a lot of care, plain
and simple. That's where they are. They
are very fearful about special education
that is not in the schools where they
are that they are cited to be going. And
so they need love and care. And that's
really the only ask they have. I mean,
they're just like stunned and they're
like, why? Right? They they still don't
have those questions answered. Um I'm
not going to ask that Maplewood be taken
off the list. And I told Maplewood that
I would not ask that they be taken off
the list. But what I did what I did say
I would do is tell you what their ask
is. They want more time. They don't feel
like them and and um Campbell are in any
rush and they're asking the district for
more time. They're not saying take me
off the list. They're saying give us a
plan we can live with. That's what
they're asking and I said I would bring
that. But I did tell them I would not
ask that they be taken off the list and
they understood that. Um, I don't know
that they all loved it, but they did
understood it. When I told them if there
was a school that I would pick, it
wouldn't be them. It would be Oak
Springs. But I'm not asking you to take
Oak Springs off either. But what I am
asking you is to do a lot of love and
care because parents who could walk
across the street, 1.1 miles is a lot.
They are worried about transportation.
And they are going to quickly be wrapped
up and covered by every charter that I
can't even like from airport to 290. And
so we need to be having conversations
with them and we're going to meet with
them next week. I feel like it's almost
too late, right? But to really kind of
hear them and listen to them and really
not provide them with platitudes, but
address their actual real concerns.
Again, I should have checked my email
more deeply. I did not do that. They did
not wind up on this list. I would like
the opportunity to meet with you all one
on like not one on three, right? to meet
or 104 whatever to meet with you all and
share like I have notes that I have
taken at all of the meetings and I would
like the opportunity to share that. I
would like the opportunity to share
information that we received from
Campbell parents um that were at a
two-way discussion. So I'm committing to
doing that and I'm also committing to
take what we say there back to those
parents. Um and just for those of you
who don't know I am caring for a
vulnerable adult. I am working a 49hour
job. I need a little bit of grace and
I'm asking for that. Thank you.
>> Um, Trusty Hunter, can I have one quick
question? That's okay.
>> Uh, when you say more time,
uh, how do you envision that potentially
occurring?
>> Enision that
>> I'm tell I'm doing what I'm supposed to
do and bring that to you and say,
>> sorry, I'm bringing to you what they
that community is requesting. Yeah. And
what they are requesting is a year. They
are requesting I think to 27. That is
what they have asked. I have had
conversations with them and I've
explained how things are sort of like
dovetailed and crooked. But I'm telling
you what they're asking because that's
my responsibility to share that with
you. And if there is if that any kind of
possible way, I don't want it to be said
that I didn't even ask and there was an
opportunity for that.
>> And I and I heard that this when when
you and I were at the meeting this
morning, I I definitely heard that as
well. So I appreciate you sharing that.
>> Thank you. and we're happy to offer the
space. Again, I apologize for not
following up with a call. Um, it's with
everything going on, I I've been trying.
So,
>> okay. In the interest of time, we are at
10:24.
>> Well, yeah. And and I I know people are
tired of hearing me and want to rush
this process. Um, you know, everyone's
saying that this is a they've heard this
is a good plan. the the people who do
not like this plan are the people whose
schools are being closed.
If you are not a parent of elementary
children, if that is not your world
right now, then you are not feeling this
the way I am feeling this and that the
way they are. And we are talking about
closing schools like it's this
inevitability, like it's a really great
way to save money. Um,
this plan doesn't So, even draft one
didn't say that it was going to
decrease our deficit. It said it's going
to raise money to pay a vendor to do
restarts.
That's what we're doing with this plan.
Um, we're closing schools that people
have chosen, that people have liked,
that people have been encouraged to
choose, by our district's own enrollment
policies, by our shopping policies, um,
by our website that I have complained
about over and over that shows that a
school has a a bad rating that you can
pick seven different schools to go to. I
have been pushing and pushing against
that, and that is what we have done. And
there are schools that have made their
schools more diverse, more um
more appealing, and now those schools
are on the list for that. Um because we
want, you know, we want say sameness. We
want everyone having the same academic
program. But that's not that is not what
families want. Um I think this is a
devestment. This is going to cause
unenrollment. I'm I'm really really
concerned about this plan period. Um
so you know saying like oh it's gone
through this fair process there are
people on this list they do not feel
treated fairly at all. They haven't been
listened to at all.
Um
and including you know you know people
people who are here who have not gone
and talked to them and you're going to
vote to close their school. I don't
think that that's okay.
Um, and we are also here talking about
closing elementary schools because
um, everyone here didn't want to touch
any middle schools.
That's something that is not working
well in this district. We have major
underenrollment in middle schools. We
have people leave and come back in high
schools because they do not like how we
do middle school. Um, so we've done
nothing to advance K through eight,
which we've had communities ask for.
They could move across the street, their
whole family could be together and do an
EC through8. And we're like, uh, we
don't know how to do that. Well, we
don't even know how to do a
comprehensive title one middle school.
Well, so, you know, maybe we should try
something that works. Um, so we are
stuck in in a plan where we cannot close
three middle schools. um because that's
that's what the board decided to do. A
middle school that's the least
disruptive thing to close. That was
something that was created not because
of academics but um for integration in
the south that Austin has completely
given up on and we we're leaning into
these hard lines. Um so a middle school
can be you could even sunset a middle
school in two years. elementary schools,
people are there if they start, we have
kids who start in ECSE at two and some
of our schools go through sixth grade.
So, we are disrupting the most
vulnerable families at the most
vulnerable time in their life and
telling them to shut up about it because
that you weren't here in 20, you know,
19 and you don't even know this is so
much better.
Um,
so yeah, I would I would like to be not
be the only one standing up for people,
but um,
you know, if that's if y'all want to
just
>> I'm going to need you not to do that.
I'm going to need you not to do that.
>> We all care for our communities and I
get that you're passionate right now
because you're in that stage of life,
>> but we all care for our communities and
we're trying to figure out the best way
to get there. Because we're not doing it
the way you feel does not mean we don't
care. I'd like to see evidence that it's
going to get us where we need. I see no
evidence it's going to get us where we
need to go.
>> That I see it's going to maybe save
money, which I doubt. I think this is
going to people are going to leave the
district because they're get they're
getting um tours at charter schools.
They're getting tours at private
schools. And when I send them to the
school they've been zoned to, they get
told that we don't do tours.
So,
I just I have a lot of concerns about us
losing enrollment. I'm I'm very
concerned about this plan and we we need
to see evidence that it works. I don't
think we have it.
Okay. So, in the interest of time and um
moving forward,
are we okay with the administration
bringing what it would look like to
choose a different school from Breaker
Woods and to keep that open so at least
we have an understanding of what that
would look like. Um the administration
will recommend what it recommends. Um
you know, and I will say personally, and
that's my neighborhood. I've lived in
Parker Woods for 25 years. I, you know,
left for eight years, moved back right
to the same neighborhood. Um, I am
heartbroken that it's there. I I have my
own opinions that I don't think it
belongs on the list. That doesn't mean
that that we all don't believe, you
know, that that's the right thing to do.
So, I understand this. Um, and I have a
really hard time with with all of this.
Um, it's a manufactured crisis and I'm
sorry we're in this this place.
um
you know, we need to get to something
that all of us can get behind and and I
have major concerns that remain that I
appreciate you addressing, you know,
beginning to address them. And I'm
seeing evidence here that a lot of what
our community is saying is being heard
and I think that is essential. Um and we
haven't gotten to talk about the
turnaround plans yet. And um we need to
do that as well. Uh because those are
profoundly important and that is fully
existential.
Um
so in the interest of kind of moving
forward if that were to be created so we
have a concrete thing to look look at
and respond to um perhaps a palm
conversation as well if that's
important. Um and we can come back
unless people have other thoughts. I I
would just suggest if the if we're going
to ask the administration to spend
significant time on an alternative plan
for my part, I would ask for a plan on
what it would look like to do the
one-year delay that they're that the
community is asking to to sit here and
negotiate between different schools and
dramatic changes on the plan. I think
personally is not appropriate for the
board. Um, as much as I I'm not going to
speak about my personal opinions on
Lonear Governance, I think the
difference between governance and
administration is perfectly in in my
opinion demonstrated in this
conversation. They're giving us a plan
to consolidate. We asked for one. I
think we can vote on whether they want
to consolidate or not. A a large
direction change into doing a pause to
me falls under the, you know, purview of
governance. I think the the reason I
would ask for that distinction is
because if we're actually going to delay
and do the, you know, longer
conversation, all this stuff, I want to
see how we're going to cover the budget
for the year that we're going to need to
cover it. How we're going to avoid the
accountability strikes that, you know,
would be coming. We we need to implement
all these turnaround plans, all these
things. Certainly, if there's going to
be a no vote, uh, which I I have said,
you know, there's a possibility that the
board votes no, then we need to have
alternate turnaround plans. We need to
be able to submit everything to TEA
immediately the next day. Um, you know,
I I would assume that due diligence is
is, you know, that there is a, you know,
catastrophic plan for, you know, if the
vote goes no. Um, I think that makes
much more sense if we're going to ask
the administration to put a bunch of
time into an alternative plan than just
doing one or two changes to specific
schools because then that starts a
cascade of every, you know, district
having specific concerns. And I don't
think we have time to do multiple
multiple drafts. Um, so that that would
be my two cents because I think if
they're going to use some time, use it
to do
the most extreme on the other side,
which is to delay for a year and do a
full consolidation. And then I can
decide between those two things. But I
for for my part as an atlarge, I don't
want to micromanage
>> some of these shifts. I think voicing
the community's concerns and saying,
"Hey, this is what I'm hearing from my
constituents makes total sense." Um but
yeah,
>> I did ask
>> this is the time we have to deliberate.
So I think this is an important
conversation
>> because I did ask a question in the
tracker about the delay the the cascade
the ramifications what it would take
like I put a whole list of things like
about a pause or delay.
>> I don't know that that was answered
>> because we just look at that.
>> So um
couple things. Um I'm going to choose
try to choose my words carefully. Uh the
first thing I would say is that um I
don't when you think about alternative
plan I think about al alternative
elements to a plan not a comprehensive
plan redo. I don't think that you're
going to find the same guard rails find
the same goals and somehow magically end
up with something so different that
you're not going to be right here a year
from now doing the exact same thing but
with the risk being that much bigger. Um
so so I I don't because the goals were
the goals right I mean balance
enrollment there were things that we
asked to do and that led the work and
unless the goals fundamentally changed
for y'all then then you're not going to
see I would think a huge shift globally
now are there elements in it that can
refine and improve yes I think that does
exist um because there are different
ways to arrive at a solution but you're
not going to ever find a solution that
says don't close schools or you don't
want to align programs then that's a
goal, get rid of that goal, right? But
then that's going to create a whole
different set of um changes in the plan
that will ultimately lead to different
solutions, right? So, um I I would
really caution the board about doing a
fullyear delay. I in fact, I would
probably be adamant that we don't go
down that path. Now, for the full thing,
um when I Trusty Hunter made the comment
around a delay for
um Maplewood and Campbell, I heard that
as take the vote, but the implementation
of that vote is a year delayed, right?
Because school districts can do that.
They'll they'll take a vote there. They
do it all the time. They're going to
close x amount of schools or make these
changes the next three years, and this
is the timeline in which we do it. That
to me is those are two different things
because the amount of energy like
consumed in the system and the things
that we're not doing because we're doing
this work is gargantuan. Like I mean
every executive director that should be
supporting our principles, every
principal that's in community meetings
like guess what they're not doing?
They're not being with their kids. So I
don't want and I don't the risks aren't
going to go away. They're only going to
get bigger. So, what I would offer is if
there are things that we need to work
through to improve the plan, we will
work through them. Um, you know, I I
hesitate to like make huge shifts for
sure in this in the overall plan, but I
do think there's refinements as changes
that are going to occur by way of this
deliberation. I mean, we talked about
one early on with Martin. That's a
pretty significant like thing that I
have to work through. That's a pretty
big change that I need. like some of the
staff behind me didn't even know about
that idea and that's the honest truth
because I I you know I want to make sure
that I have the runway to actually do
it. So if the board is asking Matias not
maybe to to your point Trusty Dod say
what a full delay is but what a modified
plan given the risk that we're managing
looks like that would be a different
conversation because the taps are tied
to pretty specific timelines that is
anchoring a lot of the things in the
plan. I would I would be really really
concerned about changing the structure
of the plan that is tied to certain
elements within it. But not all elements
are the same. That was a probably a long
way to say it, but that's that is
helpful. Then I
>> Why are we moving students? So that the
top plans say that
TEA says we need to move students from
schools to schools that have
A B and C's.
Why are we getting exceptions in our TAP
plans to move students to schools with
D's and Fs? And why do we think that
will lower risk and not get us taken
over? and and why will that be
successful?
>> Yeah. So, this is part of the
conversation we'll have tomorrow because
we're going to present in the
superintendent update all the TAP plans.
Um, what I would say is that if we had A
and B and C schools around all of our
schools that have historic that don't
have the accountability risk the way
that we're quantifying it, um, then we'd
be able to meet that expectation and be
simple. Move, move, move, reassign,
solve, break the accountability chain.
We don't have that. But what I think the
agency would respond favorably to is a
comprehensive plan that
>> I I think we do have that. And we're
going to have fewer when we close these
schools. When we close Palm, when we
close Maplewood,
if we close Biker Woods, Ridgetop,
Becker,
Riley, we we have we have fewer. And
then if I'm looking at Houston right
now,
if a school district gets taken over,
then this the schools that are the TAP
plans that were, you know, having
stricter models
that, [snorts] you know, I have little
kids. So this this is the educational
model that will be in their school
district. So even the more TAP plans we
have, the stricter we're getting and the
more structured the curriculum is and
the more scripted um and the less
appropriate it is. So when we have fewer
schools that are more free, we have more
schools that are going in a direction
that Austinites don't want their
education to go to to go to scripted, to
go to state
mandated.
Um,
and you know when we look we look at
Houston ISTD there schools they have
this the NES rate you know they they are
less free and then you have schools that
are that are more free. Um and so I
think this puts us at higher risk of
takeover and at a higher risk of
if the district is taking being taken
over having a a more punitive takeover
here.
And so [snorts] these are the concerns
that we have who our kids have many many
years
>> in Austin ISD that we hope we hope they
have these years in Austin IC. I don't
know it's not funny to me.
So
I think about um risk in the district
like hourly. I mean that's all that's
all since I came into this organization
that's all it's ever been is how to
mitigate risk as an organization to
ensure their local control so that you
as the nine trustees can lead this
organiz that's I mean that's that the
first day I was on the job that's what
we talked about and so I do believe that
this plan reduces risk the scale that
we're having to operate given our size
with the number of three UAS and two UAS
makes it to where there aren't
exceptions but the idea is if you have a
comprehensive plan, you can demonstrate
that you're going to allocate the
resources to meet the needs of our
students and you do it well. And I think
that what I hope that I've demonstrated
is that we can do things and we can do
hard things and I can we can do them
well. We need time to implement and then
I need the ability to deliver like the
opportunity to deliver is what I would
say. So if you do a comprehensive plan,
I think that's how you get to a place
where it's not an exception. It's just a
recognition that because we're trying to
lift the whole that, you know, you can
make different um adjustments throughout
the entire plan because to your point A,
B, C, you know, F or D, you know, this
20% of the students are going here, but
we're also going to provide resources to
those that percent also. We we've said
like the district has said they were
going to do that over and over and like
that we can have schools
I mean that it's leaning into like an an
old idea that's never worked here or or
anywhere else um where you can have
schools where we isolate students in
poverty, isolate students
um who are emergent bilingual, isolate
them from peers who speak English
and
then put certain resources and that will
move test scores.
>> We're not trying to isolate any student
population.
>> That's I mean that's what we're doing
when we take these lines and make them
really really hard like that's how our
school district looks. We have
>> which lines
>> a diverse school district
>> the boundaries.
>> Yeah. these boundaries,
they don't make our schools more
economically diverse. We're we're
closing the schools that are
economically diverse.
And we're, you know, and even Campbell,
which isn't isn't a school closure, per
se, but that program
is a program that people choose to be a
part of. And so combining it with a
whole another school, it it's not going
to be the same. And then that's that's a
program that's been doing better and
better that I think is going to make
accountability, you know, that's going
to do fine. Aren't they one of our one
point away schools this year and they
have a longtime principal? Um that it
just seems that any school that's do you
know we have IB program we have
monastery any anything that's someone
who's doing something different is being
like penalized in this in this plan with
a closure.
>> I mean trusty really true we we we don't
we don't have the ability to do
everything everywhere. I mean that's
just the honest truth. Like I I don't
know what other way to to dis to
describe the situation that we're in
except that we're trying to navigate
multiple risks all at once. Um,
you know, reducing the accountability
risk is something we absolutely have to
do. Um, we we have to ensure that our
students are on grade level achieving
academically but doing it our way. If
you lose control at the district, forget
>> what what's our way?
>> Can I make
just to be really I mean
>> and I'm glad we get to talk about the
turnaround plans tomorrow.
>> I know. Me too. And um trust this is
like really like you're making so many
good points. You really are and I I
appreciate that. And I'm just like but
what's the alternative? Like I really
don't know when when the state has kind
of put so many restrictions on us and
imposed rules.
Like I like I know that
like I'm not sure what the alternative
is like when you have when you don't
have what what I think I heard the
superintendent say um when you have tap
schools and there are not A and B
schools that are close by
>> there there are
>> like schools that are close by.
>> Yeah, we can pull up the map.
>> Palm is being closed instead of having
students
come to Palm.
>> Palm is not a a Yeah, that's not a
>> they're academically acceptable.
>> Yeah. But but again, this is where you
know the utilization the seats is there
was a flood there in 2013 2015 there are
thousands of homes that were there then
that are not there now. And so as a
system if we're going to you know have
resources to distribute them to meet the
needs of our students we have to find
those resources somewhere. No one's
going to come save us. So I can't that's
that's what's happening. So Palm is a
great example, right? Pal this is a plan
that puts kids in good buildings,
>> but when people are looking for when
people are looking for schools, they're
they're choosing what what they perceive
to be a good school over a good building
like over and over.
So I think this is this is a solid, I
guess, building utilization plan.
So, I mean, this is really hard, but I
want to go back and answer a question
that came up like half an hour ago,
which was, do we need to see another
plan that has like a different like
different schools closing? I'm not sure.
I I really feel like that's the best use
of our time given the short timeline. I
would much rather have the staff working
on like this is what Northeast is going
to be offering because I'm really
worried that we're we will have an
exodus of students in certain areas
because they're they have concerns which
I know we can meet. I'm confident in
y'all to be able to do that. I know Dr.
Maxwelli who told me you're actually
going transcript like you're looking at
individual students transcripts to see
what courses that you would expect them
to want to see at um at Northeast. So
you were planning already and that's
what a good solid district should be
doing. So I appreciate that people don't
know that that's happening but like
these things are happening and I would
really I I personally would rather see
our staff spending the time on bulking
up um our amazing schools that are like
Northeast Crockett. You know, these are
schools that have been underappreciated,
but they have they're doing well and
they have so much potential. And we've
got to really work on a attitude change,
a cultural shift in our community to see
these schools in in a light where they
would actually want to see their kids
there and thriving there if they weren't
thinking about that previously. And so
that's where I really want to see our
administration focused on personally is
is forward-looking. And I also at the
same time want to see very clear budget
justification which I shared earlier
which I think will help us um ensure
that we are um staying accountable to
ourselves um and being the good
[clears throat] fiscal stewards that we
should be. And this is not to to
downgrade I mean the pain that we're
feeling largely is imposed by things out
of our control. And I I feel like we're
moving in the right direction. I don't
want to get too um pulled in and I
really admire like Trusty Hunter like
you're not asking to take Maplewood off
the list like that's like I really
respect that you know I don't see Trusty
Foster asking for Mueller to stay at
Macllum you know like I really respect
that I think we're trying to move
towards something bigger and better um
and and minimize harm and I don't know
it's not that like I I get what you're
saying I just don't think it's realistic
for for us to to really make so many big
changes at this point. Um, and I'm
somebody who was asking for big changes,
you know, but I really don't I, you
know, the more I lean in and listen to
my colleagues and and the
administration, I I kind of feel like we
got to keep moving on this path and just
focus on bulking up the academics for
our kiddos.
>> I think that's the power and the
importance of being able to be in the
room together and hear each other is
important. midnights this process. I
wish we had had a lot more hours of this
over a lot more weeks.
>> I I wish we would we had we've gotten
good plans from the community like good
plans and good ideas and I wish we had
started there because I still feel there
are things on this that are arbitrary
and not justifiable
and
If it's not and if they're not tied into
anyone else, then just,
you know,
>> well, I hope that I know we haven't
talked about everything that
>> everything in here has to be justified.
It has to be. You cannot close any
school without without justification.
>> And I I don't I don't see it.
And I I think we should all feel really
confident that it's that it's justified
that it's g that each of these closures
is going to serve a purpose and we need
to show why. Not that oh, it's too
tangled in so I can't show you. That's
that's not acceptable.
>> I that's not what I I would never I mean
I don't that's not I've never said that
like that they're too tangled in. I I
would say that because we're mo trying
to address multiple things at the same
time, every one of thing impacts
something else. That's that's always
been the case. And so whatever we do,
just I'll communicate what those changes
are and how it impacts everything else.
Um that's just how it is. We're a large
elaborate complex
public education system.
>> Okay.
I was just wondering sort of where we
are in this and
>> well I think it's 10:50. I think we can
keep talking or we can adjourn and we've
already blown way past our time but I
also think it's worth blowing past our
time force. So
>> we're going to have a chance to talk
again tomorrow about the turnaround
plans which I think is a really part of
this work and um I think we have a lot
of questions about we've heard a lot
from our community about so uh if we can
adjourn if we're ready. Well, I I so the
plan coming Friday.
Friday.
>> Yeah. Um
and um you've given us
we had this starting point and um I
think dutifully I think the trustees
have been working so hard to to just
lean in and listen and we've heard so
much so much good powerful stuff and I'm
really excited that several things like
I'm seeing them reflected. Um, then
there's still remaining questions and
then there's things where it's like, you
know, I was hoping for this and I kind
of in a sense got a no in a way where
what you've kind of said is this is why
we're rolling this way. And I didn't
hear a course of people saying change
direction. So I imagine that some of the
things that I would like to see won't
quite be exactly like I would like them,
but I'm one of nine. Um that said,
um
as we move forward for this final um or
for for what comes next that we will
vote up or down on um
as you all articulate the academic sort
of commitment and then the approach and
then hopefully a hint of the sort of
resourcing of what we're going to do say
at a Northeast or here or there or at
O'Reilly, a neighborhood school. Um, I'm
really curious to hear or I want to ever
more richly understand
on our dual language programming that
our English language learners in
particular
are excellently served even as we have a
sort of expansive and robust
programming.
um this is ops and this is facilities
and this is what's going to be in a
building. But when you boil it down, I
have way too many conversations
with families
say I won't name this particular
schools, but I've got a third grader, a
fifth grader, a seventh grader.
My seventh grader doesn't really speak
English well yet, and we've been here
this many years. And so I have like
wonderings about our dual language
programming
and how it rolls out. And when I look at
our actual conversation around our
multilingual programming, I see really
good things about our commitments to
everybody being multilingual. But I
don't see something that I would like to
see, which is that first and foremost,
we ensure that English language learners
learn English as part of the equation.
And that's that we haven't chosen to
articulate that that's not but I would
like to see that lifted up as a value
that yes we want everyone to be
multilingual but we like
families are desperate and they say okay
my one's in seventh and that's where I
am but I also have a fourth grader and I
need to see X. So, so that fleshed out
in the academic uh framework and
approach and then likewise it was
actually spoken to a little bit the gap
of dual language not dual language dual
language opportunity again in other
words what's the vertical flow from
elementary to middle to high um I I
think this plan should capture that and
the ops and the buildings and everything
should be a reflection
of our commitment in that direction. Um,
middle schools haven't really, and you
know, to Trusty Chu's point, um, we have
a severe underenrollment in some areas
and there's some conversations we
haven't had yet.
I would like to see not that we dive
back into this or dive into it yet
because I think this is enough of a lift
for today so to speak or for this
season, but we have this beautiful
uh school run by a just an amazing
principal
in a beautiful building that's about to
come online with fewer than 200
students. And I'm talking about birth of
saddler means and I have lingering
questions about our vision around our
single gender schools. And I'm actually
wondering and I'm sorry for taking so
long, but I I'm actually wondering how
many of our challenges would be
addressed if we took that on next. If we
said we've got to have some
conversations about our aortionment of
middle school seats in the Northeast,
I would love to see Well, I'll stop with
that one, but can that be not a part of
the plan like, hey, let's make this part
of the plan now, but a commitment to
continued or to an initial power
empowered conversation that would have
us take action eventually around
figuring out this piece of the puzzle.
Um, and then there's a piece about
transportation, and this is very
important to me because I think it just
reflects a nationwide reality. I've said
a million times, nonzone schools do not
typically end up equitable over time.
They trend almost invariably towards
inequity. No evildoers. It's just kind
of how it happens when some people have
cars and some people have public
transportation and some people have this
access and some people don't. So, when
it comes to nonzone schools, if we're
going to commit to that sort of thing,
we not only need enrollment guidelines,
we not only need guard rail saying,
"Thou shalt not this, thou shalt not
that." You got to resource it. in and I
you have to act powerfully and
affirmatively to counter what will
invariably otherwise happen which is it
will become inequitable over time. So
when we do the transportation thank you
for
and I understand it's hard to get the
language. Thank you for if you
previously were zoned to this school and
receiving transportation and now you
still want to go back to the nonzone
school but wouldn't get transportation.
you will get trans like thank you for
that piece which is so hard to like I
don't know how you're going to get that
into a sentence or whatever
but I think we need to seriously find
the way the means the money to provide
transportation for English language
learners because right now what we're
doing is chasing demographics oh let's
go to St. John's that's where the kids
are guess what St. John's will gentrify
too. And so either we're going to move
the schools every 3 years or we're going
to or maybe we do that also. But we have
to find a way to ensure that we can
retain the balance. We need tools to
retain the balance. So I would request a
consideration of transportation for
English language learners to the
non-zone schools and transportation for
kids on free and reduced lunch for the
non-zone schools. And I do understand
it's a big ass because it's another
it's a money dip,
but I do not see
equity being continuing for more than a
year or two if you don't put resources
behind it. Um, so with apologies,
President Boswell, those are my
additional asks of this.
>> Appreciate that. So we are back together
in 18 hours. Are we uh ready to adjourn?
Do I have a motion to adjurnn?
>> So moved.
>> All right. Um, we are adjourned at
>> 10:59 p.m. Thank you all.